GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO THE JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE ON CLIMATE
CRISIS RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION AND THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WERE
MEETING JOINTLY THIS MORNING.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. FOR
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE YOU MAY BE
HERE IN THE ROOM WE'RE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING AND EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
IN A LARGE VENUE IN THE
CAPITAL. WE STILL CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN
KEEP SIX FEET OF SPACING
BETWEEN US. THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. NOW
RESTATE THIS WHEN PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. WISHES TO SPEAK. THEY
WILL RAISE THEIR HANDS AND I'LL
ASK THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. ALAS THE PUBLIC
RESPECT FOR THE CALL
DISTANCING. AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. WE ARE ALLOTTING
ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND PUBLIC COMMENT WILL. OCCUR
AT THE END OF THE MEETING AFTER
ALL THE PANELS. I HAVE MADE
THEIR PRESENTATIONS AND AFTER
MEMBERS HAVE ASKED QUESTIONS.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
DONE OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT
PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA AND L. A. OR APPEARING
REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THERE WILL BE NO VOTE
IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY THIS IS
INFORMATIONAL ONLY. WITH
RESPECT TO PUBLIC COMMENT-
FOLKS WHO ARE NOT IN THE
BUILDING WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
GALLERY AND ON THE PHONE BUT
THE PHONE NUMBER THAT YOU NEED
TO KNOW TO CONNECT TO THE
COMMITTEE. IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ALSO ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN I'LL REPEAT THAT
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN AS THE PHONE
NUMBERS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
WITH THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE OF.
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL HELP YOU. AGAIN THAT
NUMBER IS 916-319-2099.
SPEAKING AT THE END OF THE
MEETING IS NOT THE ONLY WAY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING OR YOU COULD SUBMIT
AFTER. PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB THREE
AT S. M. DOT CA DOT GOV. IF IT
ARRIVES AFTER IT MAY NOT BE
PART OF THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
BUT IT'S STILL SOMETHING THAT
WE WOULD TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. TODAY WE HAVE
TWO PANELS ONE WILL FOCUS ON
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN AND FUNDING PLAN.
AND THE SECOND WILL FOCUS ON
INVESTMENTS IN OTHER CORRIDORS.
ARE PLAN TODAY IS TO HAVE OUR
SECOND PANEL BEGIN PROMPTLY AT
ELEVEN AM. FOR MEMBERS. WE WANT
TO BE THROUGH OUR PANEL AND ARE
QUESTIONING ON THE FIRST PANEL-
BY ELEVEN SO THAT WE CAN START
PROMPTLY AT ELEVEN WITH THE
SECOND PANEL. IN ORDER FOR IT
TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE TIME FOR Q.
AND A FOR THE FIRST PANEL. I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT WE ARE WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF- VERY BRIEF
REMARKS BY. PICTURE FRIEDMAN
AND MYSELF ASSET WE SKIP
OPENING REMARKS AND BEGIN WITH
OUR PRESENTATION BY THE
PANELISTS. OUR FIRST PANEL. ON
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY'S
DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN A FUNDING PLAN INCLUDES
BRIAN KELLY THE CHIEF EXECUTVE
OFFICER OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY AND BRIAN
ANNIS THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER WITH THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY. LOUIS THOMPSON
THE CHAIR OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL PEER REVIEW GROUP
AND HELEN CARE CENTER.
PRINCIPLE FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYST WITH THE FELLOW. A
LITTLE HISTORY ABOUT HIGH SPEED
RAIL SUB THREE HAS BEEN AN
INTEGRAL PART OF HIGH SPEED
RAILS JOURNEY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE PREDECESSOR
ASSEMBLY RICH GARDEN HEARD HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROPOSALS BEFORE IT
WENT TO THE BALLOT THAT WAS A
LONG TIME AGO. HIGH SPEED RAIL
pHISTORICALLY GONE THROUGH SUB
THREE INCLUDING THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR CAP AND TRADE THE
REALITY IS THESE DECISIONS ON
HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN FOR A LONG LONG TIME
MY NOTES HERE SAY LONG AFTER
I'M GONE AND- YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW THAT I'LL BE. DEAD BUT- IT
IS GONNA TAKE A LONG TIME FOR
THIS PROJECT TO BE BUILT. WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO HELP GUIDE OUR
DECISIONS THAT WILL SHAPE HOW
CALIFORNIA MOVES INTO THE
FUTURE. AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE
CHAIR FRIEDMAN IF SHE HAS THE
REMARKS SHOULD LIKE TO MAKE.
THANK YOU TERRIBLE- JUST A VERY
VERY BRIEFLY- I'M VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO- THIS. THIS
HEARING THIS MORNING TO
UNDERSTAND THE STATE OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT AND
ABOUT THE BEST PATH FORWARD. TO
BE PERFECTLY TRANSPARENT I AM A
HUGE HIGH SPEED RAIL SUPPORTER-
AND MY GOAL IS TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
BILLS NOT JUST THE SECTION BUT
THE ENTIRE. SYSTEM AS SUPPORTED
BY THE VOTERS AND AS ENVISIONED
WITH THAT DREAM OF CONNECTING
OUR MAJOR POPULATION CENTERS. I
ALSO BELIEVE THOUGH THAT WE
WILL BE DOING A HUGE DISSERVICE
TO THIS PROJECT AND WE WOULD
NOT BE DOING OUR JOBS AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS IF WE DIDN'T
ASK TOUGH QUESTIONS. IF WE
DIDN'T EVALUATE ALL PASSED
FORWARD- THAT WE COULD TAKE IF
WE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
DECISION POINTS AND THE TIMING
OF THOSE DECISION POINTS. SO
THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE ASKED
TODAY I FROM MY PERSPECTIVE FOR
ME OR NOT AN ATTACK ON THE
PROJECT BUT RATHER INTENDED TO
MAKE THE PROJECT BETTER- AND
MORE TRANSPARENT. WITH THAT
I'LL TURN IT BACK TO YOUR
BOTTOM THANK YOU AND- A BLISTER
FONG HAS- JOINED US AND I'D
LIKE TO ASK A FEW OF THE BRIEF
COMMENTS THAT HE LEADS. I THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN FRIEDMAN- RIGHT AT
THE GATE I JUST WANT TO PUT
INTO PERSPECTIVE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE. THE ENORMITY OF THE
PROJECT. WE'RE HERE DISCUSSING
AND CERTAINLY HAS AS CHAIR OF
THEM INDICATED WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
HERE BEFORE REVIEWING- BUSINESS
PLAN AT THE BUSINESS PLAN. BUT
THE PROPOSED BUSINESS PLAN FOR
THIS PROJECT. IS PROJECTED TO
BE ONE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
ME JUST SAY THAT AGAIN A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS. IN
JUST THIS YEAR ALONE. THE
PROJECT IS BUDGETED TO COST
TAXPAYERS MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER DAY. WE'VE
BEEN HERE BEFORE ANOTHER
BUSINESS PLAN OUTLINING MORE
DELAYS OR COST OVERRUNS. FOR
ISSUES THE MISMANAGEMENT AND
MORE EXCUSES AND I APPRECIATE
THE- CARE FREEDMAN ARE TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT WE
NEED MORE ACCOUNTABILITY- IN
THIS PROJECT FOR SURE. IN ANY
EVENT OF LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. HAS REPEATEDLY ISSUED
THE SAME CONCERNS WITH EACH
REVIEW. THE DEFINITION OF
INSANITY IS DOING THE SAME
THING AND EXPECTING A DIFFERENT
RESULT. AND WHEN WE ARE DIGGING
OURSELVES INTO A HOLE. WE NEED
TO FIRST START DIGGING. I BRING
THIS UP SO THAT THERE IS
OPENNESS AND HOW WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE CURRENT BUSINESS PLAN
FOR MERCED THE BIGGEST FILLED.
WELL AND FOR THIS PROJECT AND
WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR HAS NOT
BEEN PROMISING. WE'VE ALREADY
SPENT TEN BILLION DOLLARS OVER
BUDGET FOR THE INCOMPLETE
MADERA SHAFTER SEGMENT. THAT'S
A HUNDRED AND 68% ABOVE. THE
ORIGINAL PRICE TAG. WHERE FOR
YEARS PAST THE DATE OF
COMPLETION AND THE MADERA
SHAFTER SEGMENT. IS LESS THAN
50% COMPLETE. AN ENGINEERING
ANALYSIS FOUND CORROSION AND
THEY COLLECT READING A QUOTE. A
HORRIBLE SEQUENCE OF MISTAKES
AND QUOTE IN THE INTERNAL
TRACKS DOCTOR. AND THE
AUTHORITY SIMPLY FAIL TO
DELIVER TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT PARCEL LAND PURCHASE
PURCHASE. NEEDED FOR ONGOING
CONSTRUCTION. WE CANNOT IGNORE
REALITY. I AM REMINDED OF THE
PRINCIPLE THAT THE BEST
PREDICTOR OF FUTURE BEHAVIOR IS
PAST BEHAVIOR. I DON'T BELIEVE
WE CAN CONTINUE TO HOPE AND
WISH THAT EVERYTHING IS GOING
TO BE OKAY. IF SOMETHING DOES
NOT FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROJECT IS
CLEARLY OFF THE RAILS I BELIEVE
WE MUST TAKE A HARD LOOK. AND
BE VERY HONEST WITH OURSELVES.
AS THIS COMMITTEES AS WITH
THESE COMMITTEES AND AS LESS AS
THE LEGISLATURE. ABOUT THE
BUSINESS PLAN IN THE FUTURE
THIS PROJECT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DISCUSSION TODAY. I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF WILL BE
AGAIN- WITH OUR PANEL NOW.
BEGINNING WITH A BRIAN CALLEY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT- MISTER KELLY
MAY HAVE A- UNSTABLE
CONNECTIONS. THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF YOU CAN HEAR ME I
THINK WE'RE OKAY CAN YOU HEAR
ME ALRIGHT YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
JUST FINE WELCOME TO THE
HEARING. RIGHT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
ALL MEMBERS I OF COURSE
APPRECIATE IN A HONORED BY THE
OPPORTUNITY. ADJUSTED FOR THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AND PERCENT.
ARE REVISED DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN
FOR TWENTY TWENTY. IT'S A
LITTLE ODD TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
WE'RE IN NOW GETTING DEEPLY
INTO TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BUT
THE- EVENTS OF THE PAST YEAR OF
A- PUSH THIS OUT BACK AND-
AGAIN I'M- A BIT ANXIOUS TO GET
HERE TALK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE
WHERE WE'RE GOING. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO DO SO TODAY
I HAVE A BRIEF. A POWER POINT.
PRESENTATION THAT I WANT TO.
GIVE UP SUMMARIZING THE
BUSINESS PLAN WHERE WE ARE. I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE CONCLUSION OF
THAT. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WITH ME ON
THIS PANEL IS. OUR CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER BRIAN ANNIS
WHO MANY OF YOU KNOW. VERY WELL
FROM HIS YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE-
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY- THAT'S-
BRIAN IS JOINED ME. TODAY ON
THIS BILL. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO JUMP INTO THE- PRESENTATION
SUMMARY THE BUSINESS. GREAT I
THE MISTER KELLY BEFORE YOU
BEGIN- ONE OTHER THING I WANTED
TO- ADD TO FOR THE BENEFIT OF
MEMBERS IS WHEN WE GET TO Q.
AND A- WE ARE GOING TO ALLOW.
EACH OF YOU TO ASK A QUESTION
AND THEY WERE GOING TO MOVE TO
ANOTHER MEMBER AND WE'RE GONNA
TRYING TO YOU KNOW DO ONE
ROUND. AND THEN YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO ASK A SECOND QUESTION TIME
PERMITTING SO- THAT'S THE WAY
WILL PROCEED BUT- I WANT TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE WE HAVE A
TENDENCY TO. YOU KNOW MAKE A
LITTLE SPEECH BEFORE THE ACTUAL
QUESTION- YOU KNOW. AT SOME
COLOR- WE WERE TRYING TO AVOID
THAT AND REALLY FOCUS IN ON THE
QUESTIONS HERE- WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WERE ANTICIPATING A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WANT
TO. ADD PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE
END SO WE WANT TO A LOT TIME
FOR ASKING QUESTIONS AND FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND FOR THE
PANELS IT'S A LOT TO DO IN THE
TIME THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
TODAY. SO I ASK FOR YOUR
COOPERATION MR CALLACE SORRY
FOR THE INTERRUPTION. I KNOW NO
PROBLEM MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU. OKAY THEN WITH MOVEMENTS
LIKE- AGAIN I'M HERE TO PRESENT
THE SUMMARY OF THE DRAFT THE
REVISED DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN WE
RELEASED THIS ON FEBRUARY NINTH
WE ARE NOW IN A THIRTY DAY
PUBLIC REVIEW PERIOD- ON THIS-
REPORT THIS PLAN. THAT ENDS ON
MARCH TWELFTH IN UNDER OUR
AGREEMENT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP UP MY BOARD IS TO
ADOPT THE FINAL A PLAN BY APRIL
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
DO THINK THERE'S VALUE IN IT
CAN OF COURSE SAYING TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND LEGISLATORS THAT
NOT WITHSTANDING. THE ACTION OF
THE ADOPTION OF OUR BUSINESS
PLAN IN APRIL WE CERTAINLY
EXPECT A CONVERSATION TO
CONTINUE BEYOND THAT BROKE
CERTAINLY THROUGH THIS BUDGET
CYCLE IS WE NOT ONLY A PERCENT
OF THE BUSINESS PLAN BUT WE
HAVE A COMPANY FUNDING PLAN AS
WELL. TO ACCESS REMAINING BOND
DOLLARS DEDICATED TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL- AND THAT'S BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE I KNOW THAT'LL BE A
PART OF THE BUDGET CONVERSATION
WELL BEYOND THE ADOPTION OF OUR
BUSINESS PLAN SO I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANOTHER
CONVERSATIONS WILL CERTAINLY GO
BEYOND APRIL FIFTEENTH FOR
ACTIONS THIS YEAR BUT THAT IS
THE SCHEDULE. WE HAVE FOR THE
WORK OF MY POOR. LOOKS LIKE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
BUSINESS COVERS THAT THAT WE
REALLY HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
MUCH PUBLICLY IS THE IMPACT OF
CARBON NINETEEN ON THIS PROJECT
OF COURSE IT'S IMPACTED ALL
PARTS OF OUR SOCIETY AND THE
MANY PUBLIC TRANSIT OPERATORS
AROUND THE STATE THAT AROUND
THE COUNTRY BUT- IMPACTED
DRAMATICALLY. WHILE WE ARE NOT
AN OPERATING SERVICE YET
CERTAINLY THEIR IMPACTS ON OUR
WORK RECORD TEAM OF MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
EMPLOYEES BUT AT THIS POINT-
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY-
AUCTIONS FOR CAP AND TRADE UP
THE INITIAL AUCTION- THAT OCCUR
RIGHT AFTER THE PANDEMIC HIT-
COST US DEARLY AND IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE LOST ABOUT. GET CHECK
CAME IN WITH JUST ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION LAST HUNDRED
EIGHT MILLION LESSON CAP AND
TRADE REVENUE FOR THIS PROJECT
THAT IS MORE OF A CASH FLOW
ISSUE THE WAY THE AUCTIONS WORK
WE EXPECT THESE ALLOWANCES WILL
BE SOLD FUTURE AUCTIONS. BUT
THERE IS A CASH FLOW HERE. OKAY
INTERMEDIATE MILLION A IN TRADE.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
MOVING FORWARD OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SCHEDULES AT THIS
POINT I'M LAST COUPLE OF LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR- TWO YEARS
OR SO AND WE HAVE. A DELAYED
SOME OF THAT WORK- YOU TO THE
CARPET NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
ORDER. TO PROVIDE COMMUNITIES
AND STAKEHOLDERS WITH
ADDITIONAL TIME. TO COMMENT ON
OUR WORK. I TAKE MORE TIME TO
RESPOND TO THOSE COMMENTS- AND
ALSO REQUIRES US TO SORT OF. RE
SEQUENCE WHEN THE FEDERAL.
PARTNERS REVIEW OUR PARK WORK
SO THERE'S BEEN SOME IMPACTS TO
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL SCHEDULES AS
WELL. OUR TRACKING SYSTEMS
PROCUREMENT WHICH IS UP. OF
PROCUREMENT THAT WE STARTED
LAST YEAR TWENTY TWENTY AND
WERE ORIGINALLY SCHEDULED TO
CONCLUDE A TWENTY TWENTY
WITHOUT. PUSH BACK INTO THE
THIRD QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I THINK THERE'S SOME
BENEFITS OF DOING THAT AND THEY
WILL JUST HAVE MORE
CONSULTATION COMMUNICATION WITH
YOU ALL ABOUT THE RIGHT
APPROACH ON THE TRACKING
SYSTEMS. BUT IT AND IT'S AN
IMPACT TO THE PROGRAM STEMMING
LARGELY FROM THE COCA NINETEEN
CORRECT. AND LASTLY. BECAUSE
COURTHOUSES HAD- DELAYED OR
SOMETIMES CANCELLED THE YOU
KNOW WORK DAYS. DURING FULL
SHUTDOWNS UP SOME OF THE
PROCESSES IN FILINGS THAT WE DO
FOR ACQUISITIONS. ENDED UP
TAKING UP MORE TIMES AND THOSE
ARE TWO OR THREE DAY ITEMS THAT
SOMETIMES. TOOK SIX OR EIGHT
WEEKS AND WE HAD SOME IMPACTS
ACROSS THE BOARD AN ENTERPRISE.
WIDE PLEASE COPE. NEXT ONE. ALL
WERE VERY CLEAR IN DRAFT ABOUT
KIND OF WHERE WE SHOULD WHERE
WE ARE AND HOW WE ARE
COMPENSATING YOU DEALING WITH
SOME OF THESE IMPACTS BUT WE DO
SAY IN THIS DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN
THIS REVISED PLAN THAT OUR
SCHEDULES FOR COMPLETING OUR C.
P. R. CONSTRUCTION PACKAGES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ONE TWO
THREE ARE PUSHED BACK TO
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE FOR- WILL
BE CONCLUDED IN ABOUT THIRTEEN
MONTHS AT LEAST UP ACHIEVING
SUBSTANTIAL. COMPLETION OF
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE FOR- BY
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND AS
I SAID EARLIER WE PUSHED BACK
ON TRACK INSISTS CONTRACT AWARD
NOW TO THE THIRD QUARTER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT PICTURE
ON THE RIGHT THERE IS WHERE WE
STAND ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL UP
FOR. THREE YEARS NOW WELL JACK
AFTER. NINETY NINE MILES- OF
THE ELECTRIFIED SPEED. FACE
ONCE IN CENTRAL LARGE. COVERING
NUMBER SAID MAKERS FEEL A
STRETCH IN TWENTY ONE. WE WILL-
ENVIRONMENTALLY WILLIE'S BRING
TO OUR BOARD. OF THE
CERTIFICATIONS OF THE RODS THE
RECORDS OF DECISIONS. TAKE
CLEAR ABOUT AN ADDITIONAL
NINETY NINETY TWO MILES- THE
NEXT ONE IS THE BAKERSFIELD
PALMDALE STRETCHES IN. ORDER TO
THE BOTTOM OF THAT SCREEN. AND
THE BURBANK LA STRETCH WHICH IS
UP A LITTLE BIT FURTHER SOUTH-
AT THE END OF TWENTY ONE WHAT
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILES
CLEARED- AND THEN- THE LAST
THE- LAST. COUPLE HUNDRED WILL
BE DONE- IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WHEN WE FINISH THE EXTENSIONS
OR CERTIFY THE DOCUMENTS IN THE
BAY AREA. AND THE REMAINDER. OF
THE DOCUMENTS DOWN SO TELL.
NEXT SLIDE. WELL WE DO ALSO-
INDICATING THIS REVISED PLAN
THAT- JIM PAXSON RECONSTRUCTION
FOR SCHEDULES AND COSTS-
WHENEVER WE HAVE A SCHEDULE
PUSH BACK THIS USUALLY
ASSOCIATED COST IMPACT OUR
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE UP. AS
WHAT WE CALL KNOWN BECAUSE
WHICH WE IDENTIFY AS KNOWN- OF
CALLS THAT ARE BEFORE US IN AND
ACOSTA WE SEE IN FRONT OF US TO
COMPLETE THE WORK- THAT THREE
THIRTY ABOUT FIVE WHICH THAT
EXCEEDS OUR TESTING- ADOPTED
BUDGET BUYER REPORTED DOES NOT
EXCEED THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
WE HAVE TO THE PROGRAM BUT IT
DOES EXCEED OUR OPERATING
BUDGET AT THIS POINT SO WE
WOULD. PROPOSE A COMPACT FOR
BOARD TO ADJUSTED OPERATING
BUDGET SO IN ADDITION TO THE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE UP THREE
TO THIRTY MILLION- IN LIGHT OF
ALL THE RISKS WERE SAYING AND
THE FACT THAT SOME OF THOSE
COSTS IN THE FUTURE MIGHT MOVE
WE ARE LOOKING AT ADDING A
SIZEABLE CONTINGENCY FOR RESCUE
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS SO WE
MOVE OUR CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT
BUDGET FROM TWELVE POINT FOR UP
TO ABOUT THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT.
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S WHAT'S
REFLECTED HERE THAT COVERS BOTH
KNOWN COSTS WILL RECALL MY
CONTINGENCY. FOR REX NEXT WHAT.
BOB THIS GETS BACK TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. THIS REFER THE
THINGS THESE OF THE- REMAINING.
OF OR WHICH WE MUST BE ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK- A PART OF
THE PHASE ONE SYSTEM BETWEEN
SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES. AND
ANAHEIM AS I SAID EARLIER. WE
HAVE CLEARED ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILES A HUNDRED NINETY NINE
MILES. OF THAT FIVE HUNDRED
SEGMENT. IN TWENTY TWENTY YOU
CAN SEE IN THAT SECOND COLUMN
WE PUT OUT. FOR DRAFT DOCUMENTS
FOR THE BAKERSFIELD PALMDALE
STRETCH. BURBANK'S LA ASSEMBLY.
AND SAN FRANCISCO TO SAN JOSE.
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIODON THOSE WE ARE
NOW PREPARING RESPONSES TO
THOSE COMMENTS. AND WE ARE
PROJECTING THE DATE- WILL BRING
THIS BACK TO OUR BOARD TO
CERTIFY. THE RECORDS OF
DECISIONS ARE THE FIRST TO AND
THIS YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND THE REMAINDER IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO OUR DRAFT DOCUMENTS
WILL BE OUT LATER THIS YEAR-
FOR BOTH THE PALMDALE TO
BURBANK STRETCH THE LA. TO ANNA.
NEXTPART. ONE LAST FEBRUARY AND
EVEN BEFORE OUR PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE
INDICATED AFTER SOME WORK DONE
BY- DEUTSCHE BAHN WHICH IS A
REALLY TRAIN OPERATOR THAT WE
BROUGHT IN BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HAVE THEM LOOK AT
OPTIONS TO GET AN EARLY
OPPORTUNITY SEGMENT GOING IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE ASK THEM
TO DO SOME WORK ON THAT AND
THEN ADVISES TO. HOW WE CAN PUT
INTO PLACE WITH THE BENEFITS
WOULD BE OF DOING THAT AND SO
WE INDICATED IN OUR PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT THANK YOU TWENTY
NINETEEN AND AGAIN IN OUR
SPRING- FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY DRAFT TWENTY AT THAT WE
WERE INTERESTED IN GETTING A
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILE IN
ROOM SERVICE SEGMENT GOING
BEYOND JUST THE ORIGINAL
HUNDRED NINETY MILES AWAY NOW
IN CONSTRUCTION. THE REASON
WE'RE FOR THAT IS ACCORDING TO
THE ETF ANALYSIS AND WORK HOW
WE CAN REDUCE TRAVEL TIMES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BY BETWEEN
NINETY MINUTES A HUNDRED-MINUTES OBVERSES A NO BUILD
OPTION WHICH JUST LEAVE THE SAN
JOAQUIN SERVICE AS WE KNOW IT
TODAY IN THE VALLEY IT DOES
PROVIDE VALUABLE STATE ASSET
THAT MORE THAN DOUBLES THE
SERVICE THROUGH THAT CENTRAL
VALLEY MERCED THE BAKERSFIELD
STRETCH FROM SEVEN DAILY TRIPS
TO EIGHTEEN. BECAUSE IT
CONNECTS THREE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING CITIES IN THE STATE
MERCED BAKERSFIELD AND FRESNO
AND PRODUCES THE GREATEST
RIDERSHIP INCREASE DROPBOX'S
REVENUE FOR THE SMALLEST
INVESTMENT COMPARED TO SIMILAR
INVESTMENTS ON OTHER QUARTERS
OTHER QUARTERS ALSO PROVIDES
INTERNET CONNECTION THE PARTS
NORTH VIA THE SAN JOAQUIN
SERVICE INTO THE BAY AREA AND
SACRAMENTO AND BUS CONNECTIONS
WELL SOUTH INTO THE LA BASIN
AND ALSO AFFECTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WITH THE A SERVICE
EXPENSE A DEEPER INTO PERCENT
WE WILL CONNECT WITH THE A
SYSTEM BUT ALSO MOVES INTO THE
BAY AREA WILL HAVE. SERVICE
SACRAMENTO. YEAH OF HUNDRED SAN
ONE MILES. IS TO GENERATE.
CONSIDERABLE JOB WE TWO HUNDRED
THREE. THOUSAND JOB YEARS AND
FORTY BILLION. TO THANKS FOR.
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT- THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND CERTAINLY
THE AUTHORITY HAS RECOMMENDED
THAT WE MOVE BEYOND THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILES INTO A BETTER
OPERATING SEGMENT IS WE WANT TO
BRING TRAINS WERE THE PEOPLE
ARE IN THE HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILE SEGMENT ON THE SOUTHERN.
TERMINUS TODAY TERMINATES AT A
PLACE CALLED POPLAR AVENUE
WHICH IS IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
AGRICULTURAL AREA. AND WE ARE
PROPOSING TO EXPAND THAT
SERVICE TO THE DOWNTOWN
BAKERSFIELD STREET SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE BOB THE
TERMINATION POINT IN THE SOUTH
UNDER THE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
SEGMENT. VERSUS WHAT WE PROPOSE
THAT READ SEVENTY ONE MILES.
THANK WHY. ON THE NORTH IT'S A
SIMILAR STORY THE CURRENT
TERMINATION POINT IS UP ROUGHLY
THE MADERA- STATION AT NOW FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM WHICH IS
NEAR A SUBDIVISION POST TO A
GOLF COURSE AND- AGAIN WE
PROPOSED BY EXTENDING THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE AFTER
MERCED WE BRING THE TRAINED
PEOPLE ARE CAN WE BRING IT TO A
GREATER CONNECTION POINT WITH
OTHER SERVICES INCLUDING X. AND
SAMPARK TEENS AT THE MERCED
STAGE. NEXT ONE. THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE LAID OUT ON THE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE OF MILES WE WERE
ASKED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
WORK WITH THE PEER REVIEW
GROUP- TO HAVE A PEER REVIEW OF
OUR RIDERSHIP FORECASTS- AND
WHAT WE- HAVE. A DETERMINED AND
PUT FORTH AS THE BENEFITS OF
THAT PROGRAM WE WORK WITH THE
PEER REVIEW GROUP. AFTER THE
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS OR SO. TO REVIEW
OUR MODEL REVIEW HOW WE APPLIED
THE MODEL. REVIEW OUR
CONCLUSIONS FROM THE MODEL-
AND- THE- THE GROUP CONCLUDED
THAT WORK AT THE END OF THE
YEAR. AND- WE PRESENTED THAT TO
OUR BOARD. THE END OF DECEMBER
AND NOW INCLUDED IN OUR-
REVISED BUSINESS PLAN ON THE
NEXT FLIGHT WAS IN MORE DETAIL.
OF WHAT THEY CONCLUDED. THE
CORPORATE GROUP GROW. AGAIN
HELPED US DEFINE THE SCOPE OF
THE REVIEW AND TO HELP US
LOCATE OR- ADVISE YOU TO. DO
THIS KIND OF WORK THIRD PARTY
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH AND
ANALYTICS FIRM CALLED RESOURCE
SYSTEMS GROUP DID THIS WORK.
AND THEY CONCLUDED OUR REVIEW
OF OUR- ALSO THEY FOUND NO
FATAL FLAWS WITH THE WORK THAT
WE WEREN'T. I TO SHIP S. WERE
EXPECTED FOR WORK IN THE
EXPECTED RANGES FOR THE TRAVEL
TIME AND FREQUENCY AND
IMPORTANTLY THEY THEY CONCURRED
THAT THE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT.
OBTAINED HIGHEST FORECAST GAIN
RIDERSHIP AND DID SOME WORK
WHAT WAS INCREASE COST AND
AGAIN AFTER WE HAD DONE SOME
INTERNAL WORK WITH OUR EARLY
TRAIN OPERATOR THOSE ARE THE
CONCLUSIONS THAT WE REACH. AND
WE FEEL LIKE THAT WAS IT FOR
THE BY THE. ARTIST YOU GROUP
NEXT ONE. AGAIN THE STATE UP
FOR OR FROM THE VALUE OF THE
MERCED BAKERSFIELD ROOM
SERVICE- THOSE EXTENSIONS ARE
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEAR TODAY-
THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND. THAT WE
START TO ADVANCE SOME OF THE
DESIGN WHICH WILL INCLUDE
ENGINEERING. SO THAT WE CAN
PERFORM RIGHT OF WAY MAPPING
IDENTIFY UTILITY RELOCATIONS.
UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF THIRD
PARTY AGREEMENTS NEED TO GET
ESTABLISHED YEAH THAT WAS THAT
WAS THE PROJECT CORPORATE
FOOTPRINT GET THE- OF THE WHOLE
CONFIGURATION OF THE PROJECT
LINE. THIS WILL HELP US REFINE
OUR COST ESTIMATES AND WE'RE
WE'RE PREPARED THESE. THESE
EXPERT. BOB CORKER CONCERT ACT
GOING FORWARD. I DO THANK YOU
NOT I WANT TO SAY ONE THING
HERE THAT- WE'RE WE'RE REQUIRED
TO LAY OUT A VISION OF WHAT WE
CAN DO WITH THE DOLLARS BEHALF
IT'S PART OF WHAT WE ARE ASKED
TO DO IN THE BUSINESS PLAN AND
WHILE WE LAY THIS OUT IT IS
FAIR TO SAY AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE GOOD QUESTIONS
TO ASK ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN DO THIS- THAT YOU KNOW
FUNDING WILL BE SUFFICIENT TO
DO IT LIKE THAT IT MAKES SENSE.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
LARGELY CONCUR WITH SOME OF
WHAT WE SAW THE PEER REVIEW
GROUPS LETTER TO THE BOARD
THAT'S YES WE DO SOME OF THIS
WORK BUT WE DON'T RUN BEFORE WE
COULD WALK WE ARE WORKING
CAREFUL AND METHODICAL AND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON WHY THIS OPTION
IS THE BEST OTION IT WILL
REQUIRE US TO DO SOME MORE
WORK. TO BRING BACK IMPROVE
THAT CASE BY I WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT I HOPE
WE CAN FIND A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN AGREE ON HOW HOW AND WHERE
WE CAN GO FORWARD NOW AND WHAT
MADE TO WAIT A LITTLE BIT
LONGER SO I JUST WANTED TO
REACH OUT AND IN AGAIN SAY I
RECOGNIZE THE POINT IS MADE IN
THE PEER REVIEWED REVIEW.
LETTER DISCONTENT. FIVE WHAT'S
WHAT. OUR OUR OVERALL FUNDING-
CONDITION LOOK UPS. TO WHERE WE
IN OUR FEBRUARY DRAFT. BEGIN WE
MENTIONED- TO TWENTY WILL TOUGH
YOU ON. CAP AND TRADE IN TERMS
OF GETTING. UP BY ABOUT TWO
MINUTES EIGHT NINE DOLLARS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM BUT NOW IS
EXTENDS OUT TO. TWENTY THIRTY
WE THINK UP WE RECOVER. MOST IF
NOT ALL OF THAT MONEY. THROUGH
THOSE ALLOWANCES ULTIMATELY
BEING SOLD. OUR TOTAL FUNDING
RANGE FOR THE PROGRAM. REMAINS
BETWEEN ROUGHLY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
UP FROM CAP AND TRADE RESOURCES
PLUS. OF THE REMAINDER OF THE
BOND MONEY THAT'S DEDICATED TO
THIS PROJECT- AND THE FEDERAL
FUNDS WE HAVE. OUR COST
ESTIMATE AT THIS TIME TO
COMPLETE THE PROCESS THE
BAKERSFIELD MINE. IS IN THAT
RANGE BETWEEN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION. THE
BASE COST OF TWENTY TWO. AND
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
AND THAT MR ANNA SO YOU CAN
TALK TO SUPPORT DETAIL WE HAVE.
ALSO SUBMITTED A FUNDING PLAN
TO- SICK FROM THE LEGISLATURE
THE REMAINING. PROP ONE A. BOND
FUNDS WE CAN COMPLETE THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK IS CURRENTLY.
UNDERWAY IN CENTRAL. NATURALLY
WE ARE. ALREADY RUNNING A BIT
TO BEHIND OUR IN. SCHEDULE SO
THREE IT TO A PRIVATE SPEED
THINGS ALONG. YEAH ABU QUICKLY
THROUGH THIS. BOB THIS IS JUST
A SLIDE THAT- YOU KNOW I TALK
ABOUT CHALLENGES AND WE TALK
ABOUT- THE SCHEDULE AND COST
ISSUES BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
I THINK THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
WE ARE ADVANCING THIS PROJECT
AT A PACE THAT. ARE JUST HAS
NOT BEEN SEEN BEFORE- AND THIS
CHART IS DESIGNED AS SORT OF
REFLECT THAT. I STARTED ON THIS
PROJECT TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THAT'S THE FIRST COLUMN THERE.
OF HOW MANY CONSTRUCTION JOBS
WE HAD UNDER WAY HELP
INSTRUCTORS. WE HAD COMPLETED
OR HAS UNDER CONSTRUCTION WHERE
WE WERE ON ENVIRONMENTAL. AND
THE THIRD COLUMN IS THE MOST UP
TO DATE INFORMATION WE HAVE ON
THIS AT THIS POINT. AND THEN
YOU CAN SEE THAT WE'VE MADE
GREAT ADVANCEMENTS IN BOTH
JOBS. STRUCTURES COMPLETED OR
UNDERWAY WE'RE MOVING A MUCH
QUICKER PACE ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS. RIGHT
AWAY PARCELS OF. NOT FOR
MILLION. WORKERS FOUR HUNDRED.
WHICH WOULD START. IN YOU COULD
SEE GENERALLY BAD. ONE ELEMENT
OF SWIPE I THINK IS. TO POINT
TO. YES BACK WHILE WROTE DESIGN
COMPLETE. WHEN I GOT IN
DECEMBER EIGHT I WAS. WILL NEED
STEP HUNDRED FORTY. GO TO
CONSTRUCT. AND THAT WAS
INCORRECT WELL WE NEED TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY THE
REASON THAT WAS INCORRECT OURS
BECAUSE THE PROJECT WAS NOT
VERY FAR DESIGN FORTY SIX
PERCENT. AND TODAY IT'S 95%
DESIGN WHICH MEANS WE MAY HAVE
A MUCH BETTER HANDLE ON EXACTLY
WHAT'S WORSE WHAT WE HAVE TO BE
A PLACE TO WORK. THAT'S IN PART
WHY WE'RE MORE CONFIDENT ABOUT
OUR ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD.
NEXT LOCKED. BOB THIS IS JUST A
QUICK UP INTEGRATION OF THINGS
THAT WE HAVE THAT ARE COMING UP
THAT ARE- MILESTONES WE WILL
HIT- I WON'T GO INTO DETAIL ON
THESE BECAUSE OF TIME AGAIN
THESE ARE THINGS I'VE MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT'S OUR MILESTONES
THE PROGRAM WILL HIT THE NEXT
TWELVE TO FIFTEEN MONTHS. NEXT
ONE. THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
WE HAVE THAT I JUST WANNA PICK
REPORT ON BECAUSE IT'S MOVE
VERY SLOWLY FOR SOME TIME. BUT
IS NOW PICKING UP PACE. WE ARE
REQUIRED TO MATCH ALL THE
FEDERAL FUNDS WOULD BE GIVEN ON
THIS PROJECT TO DATE WE SPENT
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION. WE HAVE
NOW SENT THE STATE MATCH
INVOICES. FOR THAT TOTAL BACK
TO THE OPERATOR. OUR FEDERAL
PARTNER THEY HAVE APPROVED ONE
POINT SIX BILLION OF THOSE
INVOICES AND THEY ARE
CONTINUING TO REVIEW. THE LAST
NINE HUNDRED MILLION BUT ALSO
ALL TWO POINT FIVE INVOICES
HAVE BEEN SENT BACK. AND
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE
REVIEW PROCESS. NEXT ONE. I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I JUST
DIDN'T MENTION THAT. OBVIOUSLY
WE SEE POTENTIAL FOR. GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND A NEW AND
IMPORTANT PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR FEDERAL
PARTNER ON THIS PROJECT THEN
CERTAINLY DIFFICULT OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS BUT-
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY NOW TO
RESTORE OUR FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP
GET A MORE COLLABORATIVE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THIS
PROJECT. WE ARE SEEKING WITH
THE BUYING TEAM NOW THE
SUPPLEMENT MEDICATION. BOB
WORKING TO MAINTAIN ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
PROJECT BUT TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION POST THANK- AND
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
FIGHTING. GROUPS ON AND H. I'M
OBVIOUSLY THE NEW
pADMINISTRATION AND CONGRESS
WILL ALSO BE TALKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING THIS
YEAR AND WE'RE OUT AGAIN. OF
HOPEFUL THAT THAT WILL INCLUDE
THE FUNDING FOR PASSENGER RAIL
OF ALL KINDS INCLUDING. HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU ARE NEXT ANALYSTS IS-
MISTER THOMPSON. STRUCTURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY. AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
ALL OF THE PEER REVIEW GROUP
WAS CREATED BY AB THREE OH
THREE FOUR AND OUR JOB IS TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
COMMENTS ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
REPORTS AND PROPOSALS THAT I
HOPE WE CAN ADD TO THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY. AS BRIAN
MENTIONED OUR LETTER COMMENTING
ON THE DRAFT REPLIES TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN WAS ON THE
SEVENTH OF MARCH AND IT FORMS
THE MORE DETAILED BACKGROUND OF
THE REMARKS THAT I'M GOING TO
SUMMARIZE TODAY. WHAT BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT THERE IS SOME
PROGRESS OR POSITIVE NEWS TO
REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE OF
FIRST OF ALL. RIGHT AWAY AND
THIRD PARTY AGREEMENTS ARE
COMING UNDER CONTROL AND THAT
IS CONTRIBUTING TO GETTING THE
EXISTING CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM
UNDER BETTER CONTROL. THAN WHY
WOULD ADD THAT THE EXISTING
CONTRACTS HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
OVERRUNS AND YOUR BUDGET CHEN
SCHEDULE. DUE TO HASTE IN
GETTING THEM STARTED. WE
BELIEVE FUTURE CONTRACTING WILL
BENEFIT FROM THE LESSONS THAT
THEY LEARNED. THE BETWEEN STATE
STAFF AND CONTRACTORS BEING
IMPROVED. THE STAGE GATE
MANAGEMENT APPROACH THAT THE
AUTHORITY DESCRIBES WILL ENSURE
THAT CONTRACTS WILL PROCEED IN
THE RIGHT SEQUENCE REDUCING
DELAYS AND COSTLY CHANGE ORDERS.
THE BY THE MINISTRATION AS WELL
AND MENTIONED WE BELIEVE THIS
WILL LIKELY TO GIVE REASONABLE
CONSIDERATION TO THE REQUEST TO
RELAX THE AREA DEADLINE AND TO
RE OBLIGATE THE NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TEN FUNDING. MORE
BROADLY THERE IS MORE REALISM
AND WHAT THE AUTHORITY SAYS IT
CAN AND CANNOT DO. THERE'S GOOD
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN
COMPLETE WITH THE EXISTING
FUNDING THE OBLIGATION UNDER
THE ERROR AGREEMENT WHICH IS A
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN MILE
CENTRAL VALLEY SECTION WILL
TRACK AND REMAINING
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK. AND THEY
COULD PROBABLY ADD
ELECTRIFICATION OF THAT SECTION
PURCHASE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF IN
ROOM ROLLING STOCK AND CONDUCT
MORE DETAILED ENGINEERING
ANALYSIS OF ADDED LINKS TO
RUSSIA IN BAKERSFIELD AND THE
MORE DIFFICULT WORK TUNNELING
OUTSIDE THE. CVS BOUGHT. YOU TO
COME THE- LINKS FROM MADERA
MERCED AND FROM POPLAR AVENUE
IN THE BAKERSFIELD IS MORE OF A
CHALLENGE FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS. EJECTED COST TO
COMPLETE THE AUTHORITIES WORDS
ARE VERY CLOSE TO THE MAXIMUM
POTENTIAL FUNDING NOW AVAILABLE
IN THIS IS BEFORE A REALISTIC
ALLOWANCE FROM RUNS ON WORK
FROM WHICH THE ENGINEERING IS
FAR FROM FULLY DETAILED.
THERE'S A MYTHICAL POSSIBILITY
THAT ADDED FUNDING BEYOND
EXISTING SOURCES MAY BE
REQUIRED ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE
PROJECT HAS NOT YET EXPERIENCED
ELECTRIFICATION SIGNALLING OR
ROLLING STOCK PROCUREMENT. THE
PROPOSAL TO OPERATE THE INTERIM
SYSTEM BETWEEN MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD IS BASED ON A
COMPLEX SET OF AGREEMENTS AND
ACTIONS AMONG HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY SAN JOAQUIN JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY AND AT LEAST.
THE CURRENT IMHO YOU DESCRIBES
THESE AGREEMENTS BUT ACTUAL
COMMITMENTS AND FUNDING TO BACK
THEM UP ARE NOT IN PLACE- TO
DELIVER THE PROPOSAL CALLS FOR
LEASING THE LAND TO AN
OPERATING SORRY THAT WOULD BE.
TO PAY FOR USE OF THE LINE IN
ROLLING STOCK PURCHASE BY THE
AUTHORITY. BECAUSE THE STATE'S.
THE JOAQUIN DRAWN AUTHORITY
THIS MEANS THAT THE STATE WILL
ULTIMATELY BE ON THE HOOK FOR
WHATEVER HAPPENS TO THE
OPERATING DEFICIT ON THE LINE.
MOREOVER YOU AGREEMENT MAY BE
SUBJECT TO LEGAL CHALLENGES
OVER THE TERMS OF PROPOSITION
ONE NAY CERTAINLY. THERE HAVE
BEEN LEGAL CHALLENGES AT EVERY
STEP IN THIS PROJECT. IN ANY
EVENT- IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
AUTHORITY WILL NEED TO ADDED
FUNDING BEYOND EXISTING SOURCES
IF IT IS TO GO BEYOND THE
MERCED THE BAKERSFIELD SECTION.
WITH THIS IN MIND OUR REPORT
EMPHASIZES A NUMBER OF POINTS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER FIRST. ASSUMING
THAT BY MID MINISTRATIONS
APPROVES A RELAXATION OF THE
EARLY DEADLINE THERE WILL NO
LONGER BE ANY MAJOR TIME
PRESSURES THERE IS TIME TO FILL.
ALTHOUGH THE AUTHORITY DOES
APPEAR TO BE INCREASING ITS
CONTROL OVER THE CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAM THE LEGISLATURE COULD
BE MORE CONFIDENT IF THAT
CONTROL AS DEMONSTRATED OVER A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS DIRECTED THAT A
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING
CHANGES TO THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK. MUST BE
DEVELOPED BY JULY FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS REPORT
SHOULD CLARIFY THE GOVERNOR'S
VIEW OF THE WORLD OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN THE OVERALL STATE
SYSTEM AND HIS IDEAS FOR
FUNDING. THIS COULD BE AN
IMPORTANT BASIS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION. I
WANT TO ADD THAT THIS WELL THAT
THE PROPOSAL'S FOR FURTHER WORK
IMPLY AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
BUILD THE SYSTEM WILL CONTROL
EAGLE MONEY IS AVAILABLE IF
THAT AGREEMENT IS MINUS PLACE
THE- NUMBER OF. YOU CHOOSE A
PLAN SHOULD BE LEVERAGED. NEXT
THE EXISTING MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING NEEDS TO BE
TRANSLATED INTO A DETAILED
AGREEMENT WITH FIRM MANAGEMENT
UNFUNDED COMMITMENTS FROM THE
STATE SEN MCCAIN JOINT COVERAGE
OF THIRTY AN ACE. THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF THE PROPOSED
OPERATION IS ENTIRELY DEPENDENT
ON THE ACTORS IN FUNDING THAT
ARE OUT OF THE CONTROL OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. I
SHOULD ADD HOWEVER THAT 75% OF
THE PROPOSED RIDERSHIP OF THIS
INTERIM SYSTEM IS NOT HI SPEED
BRIDGES ON THE LINK BETWEEN
SACRAMENTO AND STOCKTON AND
WILL BE A SYSTEM. SO IT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT PART OF THE
SYSTEM IS INVESTED AND OPERATED
EXACTLY THE WAY IT SHOULD.
OVERRIDING ALL OF THIS IS THE
SIMPLE FACT THAT EXISTING
FUNDING SOURCES MAY WELL NOT BE
ADEQUATE EVEN THIS INITIALLY
ADDED LINKS IN THE INNER
PROPOSAL. AND THEY WILL
CERTAINLY NOT PERMIT ADDING
LINKS OUTSIDE. SAID IT
BAKERSFIELD DO FEDERAL FUNDING
AND RECONSIDERATION OF ERA AND
THE FISCAL TWENTY TEN MONEY IS
A POSSIBILITY THAT MAY EMERGE
MORE CLEARLY SIX MONTHS OR SO
AND IT'S REASONABLE TO DEFER
SCOPE IN STATE FUNDING
DECISIONS UNTIL WE KNOW THE
ANSWERS. BASED ON PAST FEDERAL
PROGRAMS INSTRUCTOR THOUGH
FEDERAL MONEY ALONE THEY WILL
NOT SOLVE THE WHOLE PROBLEM
ANYWAY SO ADDED STATE FUNDING
IS A CLEAR POSSIBILITY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE AWARE OF.
IN ANY CASE I WANT TO STRESS A
POINT WE HAVE MADE BEFORE THAT
MEANING OF THE PAST MANAGEMENT
PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN CAUSED BY
FUNDING ISSUES AND IT WILL
NEVER BE POSSIBLE IN THE FUTURE
TO MANAGE THE PROJECT
EFFECTIVELY WITHOUT ADEQUATE
AND STABLE FUNDING. WHILE THESE
ISSUES ARE BEING RESOLVED WE
BELIEVE THE AUTHORITY SHOULD
DEFER MAKING BINDING CONTRACT
COMMITMENTS FELT SLIGHT ISSUE
YES REQUIRED. THE WAY VANCE
ENGINEERING IN THE LAND SONOMA
MAJOR CIVIL WORKS OUTSIDE THE
CVS. OF COURSE C<c.cyan>. GIVEN THE</c>
IMPORTANCE OF THE PROJECT WE
BELIEVE THAT WE SAID BEFORE
THAT IMPROVED OVERSIGHT BY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE A GOOD
IDEA. THE OVERSIGHT FUNCTION
SHOULD HAVE ADEQUATE STAFFING.
NEW WOULD BE NEEDED TO OVERSEE
THE PROJECT PROGRESS OVER
APPEARING IN YEARS NOT JUST ONE
BUDGET CYCLE. THANKS FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. I ALWAYS. ENJOY
HEARING BEFORE YOU AND I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO TRY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THOMPSON OUR FINAL- UP- SPEAK
ON THIS PANEL IS HELEN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HELEN CRISTINA THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
ME TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
MORNING'S HEARING I WANT TO
FOCUS MY BRIEF REMARKS ON A KEY
DECISION FACING THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH IS HOW TO APPROACH AN
UPCOMING REQUEST FOR THE
APPROPRIATION OF ALMOST ALL OF
THE REMAINING PROPOSITION ONE A
FUN. THIS UPCOMING OPERATION
REQUEST PRESENTS AND NATURAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO EVALUATE THE PROPOSED
DIRECTION OF THE PROJECT AND
ENSURE THAT IT OUTLINES WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. WE KNOW
WHETHER SUCH NATURAL
OPPORTUNITY MAY NOT EMERGE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THERE ARE TWO KEY
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THAT
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THIS
APPROPRIATIONS REQUEST. FIRST
BUT I THINK YOU'LL WANT TO
CONSIDER ITS LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE THAT IT WILL FUNDING
BE SUFFICIENT TO SUPPORT THAT
WERE SENT TO BAKERSFIELD
SEGMENT. SO I WAS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THE AUTHORITY
EXPECTED EXISTING FUNDING WILL
BE ROUGHLY SUFFICIENT TO
COMPLETE THE REVISED SCOPE OF
PERCENT TO BAKERSFIELD AND THIS
IS A SINGLE TRACK WITH PRETTY
BASIC STATION PLATFORMS.
HOWEVER HISTORICALLY PROJECT
COSTS HAVE INCREASED OVER TIME
WE THINK THAT THERE'S
DEFINITELY RISK THAT THIS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN OR THAT
SOMEBODY EXPECTED FUNDING MIGHT
NOT MATERIALIZE SO THIS MEANS
THAT EXISTING FUNDING MIGHT NOT
BE SUFFICIENT TO COMPETE EVEN
NEVER. SENT TO BAKERSFIELD
SEGMENT. SECOND THE
LEGISLATURE- WANT TO CONVEY
COMMITTEE TO FULL FUNDING
PROJECT. IS ITS LEVEL OF. TO
MEETING A FUNDING GAP IF ANY
THAT COULD. YOU CAN. THEM TODAY.
THANK MY- AS WELL AS ITS
COMMITMENT TO FUNDING. SECOND
SUCH AS THE BALLOT ABOUT LINE
AND PHASE ONE. WHICH CERTAINLY
REFER NEW THING SOURCES. IF THE
LEGISLATURE COMMITTED TO. WERE
SET TO BAKER. EVA IF THE
FUNDING EMERGED AND IS ALSO
COMMITTED TO FINDING FUTURE
PROJECT SEGMENTS AND WE THINK
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY'S
PROPOSED APPROACH. SEEMS PRETTY
REASONABLE- IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE
TO REFINANCE AT THIS EXPECTED
TO BE REQUESTED BY THE
AUTHORITY. HOWEVER IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T WANT TO
MAKE A COMMITMENT TO FINDING
RESENTED BAKERSFIELD AND FUTURE
SEGMENTS AT THIS TIME WE
SUGGEST IT MAY WANT TO TAKE
ANOTHER APPROACH THAT WOULD
PROVIDE- MORE FLEXIBILITY AND
ALSO. MAXIMIZE STANDALONE VALUE
OF WHATEVER INFRASTRUCTURE IS
COMPLETED. SO IN THIS CASE
THERE ARE TWO MAIN OPTIONS
FIRST ALLEGED YOUR IF ITHAD A
SPECIFIC APPROACH IN MIND THAT
WOULD LIKE TO PURSUE. FOR
EXAMPLE KNOWING THE PROJECT
SCOPE TO WHAT'S REQUIRED BY THE
FEDERAL GRANT AGREEMENT AND
THAT WOULD BE TOO BIG REALLY
CONSTRUCTION OF A USABLE
SEGMENTS- AND THAT ONE NINETEEN
MILES NOT NECESSARILY
ELECTRIFICATION. IT COULD NOT
STATUTORY LANGUAGE DIRECTING
THE AUTHORITY ACCORDINGLY.
SECOND IF THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
APPROACH THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COMMITTEE NOW IT COULD TAKE
ACTIONS. TO PRESERVE ITS
ACCESSIBILITY. WOULD LIKELY
DELAY ACTION ON. OR ALL OF THE
PROPOSED APPROPRIATION REQUEST.
I'M IN THIS WOULD PRESERVE
NATURALLY. MAKING POINT PEOPLE.
WE THINK IT WOULD ALSO LIKE
INCLUDE ADOPTING STATUS
LANGUAGE. THE F. FROM ENTERING
CONTRACTS THAT WOULD COMMIT THE
STATE TO APPROACH SUCH AS
ELECTRIFICATION. SO THAT FOR
EXAMPLE THAT CATEGORY LIKE
WHICH COULD PREVENT THE
AUTHORITY FROM THE SAME LETTER
BY TRAINS. AT THIS TIME OR AND
COMMITTING THE STATE'S YOU.
CONSTRUCTING WATER BY CAPTAIN
SYSTEMS. ARE ALSO HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU A MISS
CHRISTINE I APOLOGIZE FOR
MISPRONOUNCING YOUR NAME
EARLIER- THAT BRINGS US TO THE
CONCLUSION OF- OF- THIS. HANDLE
AND I AM GOING TO- A PASS ON
ASKING- AND INITIAL QUESTION
AND ASK MISS BRIDGEMAN IF SHE
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENCE OF
CLASSES AND TO MEMBERS PLEASE
JUST TO INDICATE IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION I'LL TRY TO. KEEP AN
EYE ON IT. INCLUDE EVERYONE I
JUST TO BE CLEAR WE'RE GOING TO
ASK ONE QUESTION AND THEN PASS
IT TO SOMEBODY ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE CORRECTED I ASK YOU
TO MAKE YOUR QUESTIONS AS
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE AND-
PANELISTS- KEEP YOUR- RESPONSES
AS- CONCISE AS POSSIBLE. I HATE
MY FIRST QUESTION IS FOR MR
KELLY I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR
HIS PRESENTATION- SO. AT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS OF THOUGHT AS
TO- COMPLETING THIS PROJECT AND
THEN DEMONSTRATING THAT IT
SHOULD BE- CONTINUED THROUGH TO
LOS ANGELES AND BAY AREA SAN
DIEGO- ONE IDEA IS THAT THIS
SECTION- EITHER CONFIGURATION
OF SECTION WILL GENERATE SO
MUCH RIDERSHIP THAT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WILL. WILL DEMAND
THAT THEY NOW HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND THE OTHER
THOUGHT IS THAT ONCE THEY SEE A
FAST TRAIN RUNNING IT
UNDERSTAND IT CAN BE BUILT.
THEN THAT WOULD KIND OF DO THE
SAME THING SO MY QUESTION IS
WHY YOU BELIEVE. THAT. THIS
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE MILE
SECTION WOULD HAVE ENOUGH
RIDERSHIP. TO DEMONSTRATE THE
VIABILITY OF THIS PROJECT I
MEAN CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT
HIGH SPEED RAIL CAN BE BUILT
THIS IS NOT NEW TECHNOLOGY THIS
IS FORTY AT LEAST FORTY YEAR
OLD TECHNOLOGY THAT WE SEE USED
AROUND THE WORLD SO IT'S NOT
THAT IT'S A NEW THING THAT. IS
GONNA BLOW PEOPLE'S MINDS RIGHT
SO WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT A
SINGLE TRACK SYSTEM THROUGH
THESE AREAS IS GOING TO HAVE SO
MUCH RIDERSHIP. THAT. IT WILL
CONVINCE US TO FUND THE REST.
AS OPPOSED. OTHER INVESTMENTS
THAT WE KNOW WILL WORK REYES
RIDERSHIP. WHY DON'T I GUESS
I'M PERSON I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THOSE ARE BUT LET ME JUST
SAY. THE APPROACH THAT WE'RE
TAKING IS NOT IT IS REALLY. IN
MY VIEW A PRAGMATIC APPROACH
BASED ON WHERE WE ARE ON THE
PROJECT AT THIS TIME. AND THE
AMOUNT OF. RESOURCES WE HAVE.
TO BRING IT FORWARD TO DEVELOP
SOMETHING THAT IS OF VALUE. AND
USABLE AND CAN DEMONSTRATE WHAT
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL CAN
DO. WHICH I DON'T THINK WHICH I
KNOW IS AVAILABLE AROUND THE
WORLD BUT IS NOT AVAILABLE
ANYWHERE IN AMERICA. AND IS NOT
SOMETHING CALIFORNIANS CAN
EXPERIENCE HERE AT HOME. AND SO
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE SAID
LOOK. AT THIS MONEY TO BUILD A
HUNDRED NINETY MILE STRETCH INTHE VALLEY. THE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN TERMINATION
TERMINATION POINT OF THAT ARE
NOT AN IDEAL OPERATING RUN. IF
WE EXTEND FURTHER INTO THE
CITIES AND THE WAY WE GET TO AN
OPERATING RUN. THAT BOTH ARE
ADVISORS BURKE WHO RUN HIGH
SPEED RAIL. TODAY AND A PEER
REVIEW GROUP HAVE CONFIRMED- A
REASONABLE ASSUMPTION IS IT
WILL PROVIDE ENHANCED RIDERSHIP
MORE THAN DOUBLING. THE
RIDERSHIP IN THE VALLEY ON
TODAY'S SERVICE VERSUS A NO
BUILD OPTION JUST LEAVING
TODAY'SDIESEL SERVICE THAT
SHARES FREIGHT TRAFFIC. WE WANT
TO USE THE ASSETS THAT WE NOW
HAVE UNDER CONSTRUCTION. TO
PROVIDE A VALUABLE INTERIM
SERVICE WHILE WE COMPLETE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK ACROSS THE
STATE FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO LA
IN ANAHEIM- IN ADVANCE THOSE
SEGMENTS. TOWARD CONSTRUCTION
WHEN MONEY BECOMES AVAILABLE.
SO FOR US. PUZZLE IS. A MORE.
EARLY PRAGMATIC WAY SAY HERE'S
THE BUDGET WE KNOW WE HAVE WHAT
WE THINK WE CAN DO WITH THAT IS
IT A VALUE TO CALIFORNIANS A
PARTICULARLY A PLACE LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY DOES NOT HAVE A
TON OF TRANSIT OPTIONS AND IS
IN A GOOD PLACE TO START-DEMONSTRATING WHAT THIS CAN DO
AS WE EXPAND OUT OF THE BALLOT
AND LOOK WE STARTED IN THE
VALLEY WE'RE INVESTING BILLIONS
IN THE VALLEY. AND TO GET THAT
WORK DONE AND MAKE SOMETHING OF
VALUE IN OPERATIONAL THERE BUT
WE THINK WE NEED TO EXTEND INTO
THE CITIES OF THE VALLEY AND BY
DOING THAT WE CAN GET
OPERATIONS RUN GOING AND THEN
WE CONSIDERED HOW TO EXPAND.
THANK YOU OF MR PATTERSON IS
NEXT UP FOLLOWED BY MISS NGUYEN
WHO IS SUCH A- GOING TO BE-
REMOTE- WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT DOES SOMETHING OF VALUE-
LET ME JUST SAY THAT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN THE GUINEA
PIG IN. ALL OF THIS. THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE EIGHT YEARS AND HAVE
SEEN REPEATED BUSINESS PLANS.
AND THEY ALL HAVE ONE THING IN
COMMON THEY COST MUCH MUCH MORE
AND BUILD. MUCH MUCH LESS.
FRESNO IN PARTICULAR IS WE'RE
GETTING RIPPED UP OUR LANDSCAPE
OUR FARMLAND OR CITYSCAPES
THERE'S ACCESS PROPERTY TURNING
IN. THE BLIGHT WE HAVE BEEN
PROMISED SOMETHING OF VALUE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT WHEN THE PLAN
CAME FORWARD. THAT IT WOULD
HAVE A ONE TRACK. ON PAGE SIXTY
pNINE ON PAGE SEVENTY ON PAGE
NINETY ONE THE AUTHORITY
EMPHASIZES AND RE EMPHASIZES
THIS SINGLE TRACK APPROACH.
WHEN WE LOOK AT IT THROUGH THE
EYES OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. WE
SEE. THAT THIS WILL BE A ONE
TRACK. EMPTY TRAINS NO STATIONS
AND I GUESS NO PASSENGERS IN IN
TEST MODE. OR MAYBE FIVE YEARS
OR PERHAPS. LONGER AND SO OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT IS THAT WE HAVE.
BANTUS ABATING AND HAVE MADE A
LOT OF LOCAL COMMITMENTS AND
YET WE'RE STILL RIPPED UP AND
WE NOW EXPECT A SINGLE TRACK-
THAT- I THINK CAN HAVE A HARD
TIME DEMONSTRATING THEIR VALUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU CAN. GET
THAT MIGHT GET TO THE QUESTION.
SO CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN WHAT
POSSIBLE VALUE. IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA FOR A- FOR A SINGLE
TRACK. NO PASSENGERS. NO
STATIONS. AB WHY CAN'T CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA SEE THIS AS A
BETRAYAL. AND SEE IT AS NOT
ONLY JUST. RIPPING US UP BUT
RIPPING US OFF. WELL I GUESS MY
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION WOULD
BE THAT- WE CLEARLY DON'T SEE
IT THE SAME WAY AND AUG THE
OPTION ON THE SINGLE TRACK
VERSUS THE DOUBLE TRACK ONE-
WILL STILL HAVE SUBSTANTIALLY
MORE PASSENGERS THAN THE-
CURRENT NO BUILD OPTION AND
JUST LEAVING TODAY'S DIESEL
POWERED PASSENGER TRAIN SERVICE
IN THE BALLOT. BUT LIKE TO
FIGHT HIGH SPEED RAIL ON ONE OR
TWO TRACKS WILL STILL HAVE THE
OPERATIONAL BENEFITS AND MEET
THE OPERATIONAL- THE
OPERATIONAL COMMITMENTS AND
OBJECTIVES THAT WE SET ABOUT
THE DOUBLE TRACK THE ISSUE IS
NOT DO WE EVER DO THE DOUBLE
TRACK IT'S WHEN DO WE- AND-
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING HERE IS AS
A WAY TO. CONSIDER DOING THIS
IN A MORE METHODICAL APPROACH
AND STAY WITHIN BUDGET.
LIMITATIONS THAT WE CAN DO THIS
ONE TRACK AT A TIME WITHOUT
SACRIFICING OPERATIONAL
BENEFITS. AND THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE PROPOSING. OUR BUSINESS
PLAN CONTAINS ROUGHLY TWO
HUNDRED TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
INVEST IN STATIONS AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT ARE PART.
OF BUILDING THE BAKERSFIELD
MERCED STRETCH FOUR STATIONS IN
PARTICULAR THAT UP WILL MOST
CERTAINLY. BE DEVELOPED IN A
WAY TO MAKE SURE PASSENGERS
GIVE ACCESS AND GET ON AND OFF
THE TRAIN SAFELY AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES ON HOW TO DEVELOP.
AROUND THE STAGE AND THAT'S
WORK WE HAVE UNDERWAY WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE BALLOT ON.
SO FOR US IT'S MORE LIKE. THERE
ARE THINGS WE WANT TO CONSIDER
WE WANT THE BIDDERS THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS THINGS OUT TO
BID. TODAY LIKE THE BIDDERS TO
PROPOSE IT AS A COUPLE OF
OPTIONS WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE
IF YOU DO ONE TRACK FIRST AND
THE SECOND TRACK. LATER WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE IF YOU DO
ONLY TWO TRACKS. UP AND WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE YOU COULD DO
ONE TRACK AND SO. ARE OUR BEST
ESTIMATE ON THIS IS THAT- THE
OPERATIONAL BENEFITS. ARE-
PERSONALLY THE SAME. OR THE
INTERIM SERVICE MEMBERS SAID TO
BAKERSFIELD ONE TRACKER TO IT
DOES INCLUDE. PASSING AREAS AT-
MAINTENANCE FACILITIES AND AT
STATIONS- WHETHER BE A SECOND
TRACK AND THERE'S ALSO AN
OPTION TO BUILD. ADDITIONAL
SITES BUT WE'D LIKE TO BE
INFORMED BY THE BIDS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW BEST TO PROCEED. BUT
THE IDEA AS A WAY TO GET THE
OPERATING SEGMENT IN PLACE.
BRINGING DELIVERY AND VALUE TO
THE RIDERS CENTRAL VALLEY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE SAID.
IN THE EARLIER APPROACH. THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WIN FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD AND RUFUS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THIS THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS FOR L. A. O.
IF WE ARE STARTING. UN SO THE
ACTUALLY THE PLAN SET BEFORE US
IS TO BILL FOR MORE STEP TO
BAKERSFIELD SINGLE TRACK WHICH
WILL COST TWENTY TWO POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. YET THE HIGH
SPEED RAILS ESTIMATE REVENUE IS
TWENTY ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS LEAVING A BILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT FOR THE PROJECT
AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS JUST
WITHIN THAT TRACK. NOW QUESTION
FOR THE L. A. O. IS. IT WHERE
BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT NOW IN
THE HOLE JUST FOR THIS PART. DO
YOU SEE IT BEING TOO RISKY FOR
THE LET'S SAY TO THAT THE STORY
MOVE FORWARD ON A PLAN THAT.
WE'RE IN A DEFICIT ALREADY.
GIVEN THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
FINISH THE HIGH SEED RAIL IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND WE'RE NOT EVEN. TALKING
ABOUT. A PORTION OF STUDY IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WHERE I
REPRESENT. AT ALL WE'RE STILL.
AT THE BEGINNING. CAN YOU KIND
OF JUST GIVE US. YOUR WHAT
YOU'VE SEEN IN YOUR
PROFESSIONAL OPINION. IS IT TOO
RISKY OR NOT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO DID YOU
ALREADY HAVE BEEN. MADE AS WELL
AS A RANGE OF. I THINK I MEAN
TO BE INVOLVED WELL AND SO IT
TURNS OUT THAT. ABOUT BUT IF
YOU THOSE POINTS BECAUSE MY
CHILDREN. TO M. NOT BE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING AND THE
CERTIFICATE COULD YOU ON FOR A
SECOND WE'RE NOT. AN ACTIVITY
YEAH. I DON'T. AND RICHARD TO
CAN SLOW DOWN SURE GEN WHERE IT
WOULD GOT A REQUEST THE YOU
SLOW DOWN A LITTLE BIT BUT I'M
NOT HAVE TO ASK TO START OVER
WHEN WE'RE READY. WELL IF YOU
COULD TURN YOUR- HELPFUL WITH
THE THAT'LL AND FOR YOUR AUTO.
LET'S GIVE THAT A TRY THANK YOU
ABOUT THAT. EACH SO- SO
ESSENTIALLY IT'S ALREADY PRE
BOTH RAIN FOR THE COST AS WELL
AS THE FUNDING AS WELL AS POINT
ESTIMATES MAKING WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
THAT IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
POINT ESTIMATES IT APPEARS
THERE'S A FUNDING GAP- THERE'S
CERTAINLY SOME UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT THE FUNDING
WILL BE- BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT FOR EXAMPLE CAP AND TRADE
WILL BRING AND THERE'S ALSO
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
THE COSTS ARE GOING TO LOOK
LIKE PARTICULARLY WITH THOSE
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
EXTENSION. ON THEIR END EARLY
DESIGN PHASES AND SO THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT EXACTLY THOSE COSTS WILL
BE BUT I THINK AS YOU NOTED-
EVEN WITH THEIR ESTIMATES- IT'S
UNCLEAR IF THERE'S SUFFICIENT
FUNDING AT THIS POINT IN TERMS
OF THAT THE QUESTION OF RISK IT
REALLY IS I THINK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER HOW
RISK AVERSE LEGISLATURE IS
RIGHT ACCURATE MORE RISK AVERSE
MANDATE YOU PROBABLY WOULD WANT
ONE- YOU KNOW. FIRST CONNECTS
WITH SMALLER SCOPE FOR EXAMPLE
SO MAYBE WE CAN GET TO DURING
THE FEDERAL AND THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT- FOR A GRANT
AGREEMENT AND THAT'S JUST THAT
INITIAL ONE NINETEEN MILES NOT
ELECTRIFIED YOU CAN DO THAT TO
SEE WHERE THAT GOES ON YOU CAN
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
AND MAKE SURE ALL THE CONTACTS
REALLY JUST JUST KIND OF COMING
INTO THAT I'M SORRY YOUR
GOVERNMENT HERE MORE RISK
AVERSE THAT MIGHT BE THE
APPROACH THAT YOU WOULD WANT TO
TAKE. IF YOU ARE WILLING TO
TAKE ON MORE RISK THAT YOU'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE TO BE SHOULD
FUNDING- AND THAT AND THAT
EDUCATIONAL FUNDING WILL NEED
TO BE IDENTIFIED EVEN TO
COMPLETE RESPECTIVE BAKERSFIELD
AND CERTAINLY TO COMPLETE
ADDITIONAL WORK BEYOND
PERSPECTIVE BAKERSFIELD IF YOU
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO TOLERATE
MORE ABOUT RISK- COURT ABOUT
RISK- YOU TAKE THAT THE THIS
PARTIES YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE
MORE ABOUT RIGHT THANK YOU
MIGHT BE MIGHT BE COMFORTABLE
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
APPROACHED. I THINK IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON ON THAT RISK
TOLERANCE AND BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE HAD AGAIN TO FULLY
FUNDING THAT PROJECT BECAUSE I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WOULD BE PERHAPS PROBLEMATIC IT
TO END UP WITH JUST ONE HUNDRED
NINETY MILES. BETTER
ELECTRIFIED AND NO DESIRE SPEND
A DAY. MONEY BECAUSE- THAT KIND
OF SMALL. A PROBLEM DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE. TO RUN. ELECTRIFIED
TRAINS ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT MILES.
SHALL MEDINA. RIGHT AND SO. YOU
IF YOU'RE GONNA. NOT GONNA WANT
TO A- SAID. BUT YOU'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO MAKE THAT YOU. TO SAY
THAT YOU CAN CONNECT IN TERMS
OF SERVICE. I DON'T KNOW ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION BUT IT'S REALLY.
ABOUT YOUR RISK TOLERANCE. ADD
TO THAT ALL YOU CAN HEDGE YOUR
RISKS THIS WAS THE POINT THAT
WE WERE MAKING JUST WAIT. TILL
AT LEAST THE SUMMER AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE FEDERAL
MONEY AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
FURTHER ENGINEERING WORK BUT
THE AUTHORITIES PROPOSING TO DO
ON THOSE TWO LINKS. AFTER WHICH
THE PICTURE OF WHAT THEY CAN
WHETHER THEY CAN PAY FOR THAT
WITHIN THE JUST THING OR THE
NEW SOURCES. IS TRUE OR NOT- WE
BELIEVE AND SAID THAT RIGHT NOW
IT IS UNCERTAIN FOR SURE
WHETHER. THE EXISTING SOURCES
WILL PAY FOR THOSE SWINGS THAT
SEEMS TO BE CLEAR. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT QUESTION COMES FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD ALSO
REMOTELY. THANK YOU CHAPLAIN MY
COUNTY HERE OKAY. PLEASE
PROCEED RIGHT THANK YOU- I
APPRECIATE B. OVERVIEW TODAY-
FOR ALL THE PRESENTATIONS I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORITIES- CHANCE TO BE ABLE
TO MEET WITH ME AHEAD OF THIS
TO REALLY DIVE A LOT DEEPER
INTO SOME OF MY CONSTITUENTS IS
PERSPECTIVES ON THIS PROJECT- I
HAD TWO QUESTIONS TODAY ONE-
WHAT IS THE EITHER AGENCY OR
ANYBODY ELSE FROM GOVERNMENT
DOING TO PROACTIVELY REACH OUT
TO FEDERAL REPRESENTATIVES AND
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION I DON'T
WANT TO WAIT UNTIL THE SUMMER I
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ON THEIR OWN TIME LINE BUT WHAT
ARE WE DOING RIGHT NOW TO
REALLY TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HAVING. THOSE RESOURCES
OR THE PROSPECT OF THOSE
RESOURCES COMING TO HELP
MITIGATE SOME OF THE STATE'S-
IT- REQUIREMENTS- TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP US ON TRACK AND THEN
SECONDLY FROM SOME OF THE- BOTH
MEDIA REPORTS AND OTHER- OTHER
INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
CIRCULATING OUT THERE I'VE GOT
SOME DEEP CONCERN ABOUT THAT
CONTRACTORS THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
NOT BENG ON TIME NOT MEETING
THEIR GOALS HAVING ADDITIONAL
CHANGE ORDERS- AND- AND NOT
STICKING TO WHAT WHAT OUR
AGREEMENT IS SO WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO PROTECT TAXPAYERS
INTERESTS FOR THE AGREEMENTS
THAT WERE SET IN PLACE TO MAKE
SURE- THAT WE ARE NOT JUST
STUCK WITH THE- AND-
POTENTIALLY UNSCRUPULOUS-
PARTNER IN THIS- JUST CONTINUES
TO BE ABLE TO. LEAVE THESE
MONIES AND THEN COMES BACK AND
ASK US FOR MORE- SO THOSE ARE
THE TWO QUESTIONS I HAVE- I
WOULD ALSO I DON'T EAT
RESPONSIBLY IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME BUT I AM VERY INTERESTED-
TO SOME MEMBER AND WHEN'S POINT
OF VIEW REPRESENTING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO REACH AND-
REALLY EXPRESS THAT I WANT TO
SEE A LOT MORE HAPPENED FOR
FEES TO IN OTHER SEGMENTS AS
WELL THAT ARE GOING TO
GUARANTEED- STUDIO RIDERSHIP
HAPPENING IN A REASONABLE TIME
FRAME I KNOW THAT MIGHT BE VERY
COSTLY I KNOW THAT THAT IS
GOING TO COME WITH ITS OWN SET
OF HURDLES- BUT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT DOWN HERE TO BE ABLE
TO- WANT TO SUPPORT THIS AS WE
DID BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND-
EIGHTEEN. UNLESS WE ARE.
SIMULTANEOUSLY ONE ISSUE A
FAMILY WORKS. WE'RE S. WE'RE
AT- I'VE AND TO AVOID SPEECHES
AND NOW YOU VIOLATED MY OTHER
TO WHICH WAS STAYING ONE DAY
ONE QUICK THE- I- I MISTER
ROGERS. YOU I'M TRYING TO HOLD
TO THE SAME RULES. SO IF IT'S
ALL WITH YOU I'M GONNA- ALLOW
THE PANELISTS TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS- BUT FOR THE REST OF
YOU LET'S TRY PLEASE TO IS HERE
TO THE ONE. QUESTION RULE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO THE EXTENT
THAT QUESTION THOSE QUESTIONS
ARE DIRECTED TO ME- LET ME BOB.
FIRST DAY ON THE FEDERAL SIDE-
WORK IT'S HARD TO. OVERSTATE
THE DIFFERENCE IN RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION. AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND THE CURRENT ONE AND
THIS AND- IN THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION THERE WAS NO
DIALOGUE- ACTIONS WERE HOSTILE.
AND ATTEMPTS TO TAKE MONEY FROM
THE PROJECT. HEARD US. AND IT
AND IT AND IT SLOWED SOME OF
OUR WORK. OKAY THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION HAS COME AND-
THAT WE ARE IN NEAR CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION. ABOUT EXACTLY
WHERE THE PROJECT IS. WHERE IT
IS WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO GO ON
THIS. AND WE ARE SEEKING THEIR
INPUT. ON HOW WE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS PROJECT. SO I
WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
COMMUNICATING IN A VERY HIGH
LEVEL. AND A VERY CONSTANT
LEVEL ON THINGS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. BUT UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THEY ATTEMPTED
TO TAKE UP ROUGHLY A BILLION
DOLLARS AWAY. FROM THE PROJECT
FOR FEDERAL MONEY THAT WAS
GRANTE TO THIS PROJECT. WE
WENT TO COURT TO SUE. TO STOP
THAT ACTION. AND WE ARE NOW
WORKING WITH THE BY NEED
MINISTRATION ON HOW WE SETTLE.
THAT ACTION TO. KEEP THE
FEDERAL HERE. CERTAINLY WE ARE
ALSO ADVOCATES WERE ALL OF OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AND THE BY THE
MINISTRATION. ON MAKING SURE
THAT THE BILL BACK BETTER
PROPOSAL IS THAT COMES FORTH
LATER THIS SPRING. THAT
INCLUDES. YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP FOR
PASSENGER RAIL AND
PARTICULARLY. FOR CLEAN
PASSENGER RAIL. AND SO WE THINK
THAT THOSE ARE ELEMENTS THAT
THEY SUPPORT. WE ARE EXPECTING
THAT- WE WILL SEE OPPORTUNITY
WHEN THAT PROGRAM COMES FORWARD
WE EXPECT TO SEE IT MAYBE LATER
THIS MONTH. AND WE THINK WE
HAVE A REAL SHOT TO ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S NOT JUST THIS
PROJECT BUT- ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO BUILD
CLEAN TRANSIT. WHICH ARE
PROBABLY LEADING THE NATION-
AND SO WE SEE GREAT OPPORTUNITY
WE ARE IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION. WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. ON THE SECOND
QUESTION. ALL THE GUYS TAKE UP
MORE TIME AND MAYBE UP A LONGER
CONVERSATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD WHICH I'M HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU AND I APPRECIATED. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT IT IN ADVANCE OF THIS.
BUT IN TERMS OF. CONTRACTORS IN
CHANGE ORDERS I MEAN I WILL SAY
THIS AND I JUST TESTIFIED. TO
THIS. MISS COMMITTEE BEFORE-
CLEARLY WHEN WE GOT INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION ON THIS PROJECT-
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN. FOURTEEN I WOULD
CONSTRUCTION FIRST GOT UNDER
WAY THE PROJECT WAS NOT.
DEVELOPED ENOUGH IN TERMS OF
THE DID NOT DESIGN BEING DONE.
RIGHT AWAY WAS NOT. A PART OF A
LONG BEFORE A CONSTRUCTION
COMMENCED CONSTRUCTION DID
COMMENCE. WHAT DO A LOT OF
FACTORS AT THAT TIME INCLUDING
UP UP PRESS TO SPEND FEDERAL
MONEY BY A DEADLINE- IN THE
UPSIDE OF THAT IS THAT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WORK. AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
JOBS WERE CREATED THE DOWNSIDE
WAS A LOT OF WORK WAS DONE AT
RISK. AND NOT SEQUENCING THE
WORK. AS YOU TYPICALLY WOULD-
IT LED TO THAT SCPE CHANGES.
OTHER CHANGES IN THE PROJECT
THAT. WE HAVE TO NOW- FULFILL
WE HAVE TO FINISH ABOUT WHAT
THOSE CODE CHANGES LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE TO NOW THE PROJECT AS I
SAID. YESTERDAY IN MY
PRESENTATION WHEN I STARTED
HERE IS ABOUT 45% DESIGN. IT'S
HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND WHAT RIGHT
AWAY YOU NEED YEAH. EXACTLY
WHERE IT'S GONNA GO IF YOU'RE
ONLY THAT PART DESIGNED TO DATE
WHERE 95% WILL BE A 100%
DESIGNED BY APRIL. AND THAT
MEANS NOW WE HAVE A HANDLE ON
EXACTLY WHAT RIGHT AWAY WE DO
NEED. AND WE'RE DANCING THE
BALL WE HAVE ABOUT 80% OF IT IN
HAND. AND WE WILL MOVE FORWARD
LET'S GET THE REST OF IT IN THE
NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS. OR SO-
IT'S SO. JANE ORDERS ARE NOW OF.
SORT OF ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THAT WERE LEFT UNANSWERED WHEN
THE PROJECT WAS NOT FULLY
DESIGN AND NOW YOU'RE GETTING
THE FULL DESIGN AND YOU HAVE TO
EXECUTE CHANGE ORDERS TO FINISH
THAT WORK AND SO THAT'S GOING
TO BE WITH US THROUGH THIS
HUNDRED NINETY MILE STRETCH
HOWEVER OUR BUDGET ESTIMATES
ACCOUNT FOR THAT. IN OUR BUDGET
ESTIMATE NOW THAT IS FULLY
DESIGN- WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THOSE RISKS ARE AND WHAT THAT'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE AND THAT'S WHAT
WE ARE NOW MOVING FORWARD TO
WHICH- END UP ALL OF THESE
THINGS YOU KNOW CONTRACTORS
GENERALLY CLAIM TOO MUCH AND WE
COME IN WITH A DIFFERENT NUMBER
AND OFTEN THESE THINGS GET THE
BILL SHE ADDED. AND- YEAH
NOBODY'S PARTICULARLY HAPPY BUT
WE HAVE TO DO THAT BUT TO GET
THIS WORK DONE AND I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE AS AN
ORGANIZATION HAVE TO DO IS
UNDERSTAND THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THAT BAD START. A LOT OF
THINGS DIDN'T GO AS IT SHOULD
HAVE AND AS WE GO FORWARD FOR
HOW WE WILL DO CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS. GOING FORWARD WE
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING OUTLINED
THIS IN CHAPTER SIX OF OUR
BUSINESS PLAN A VERY METHODICAL
AND DISCIPLINED STAGE GATE
PROCESS SO THAT WE DON'T DO
CONTRACTS OUT OF SEQUENCE WE DO
THEM IN SEQUENCE AT THE I THINK
THAT'LL HELP US AVOID. A
PROBLEM. THANK YOU MS THREE.
FOLLOWED BY. THE SMITH. AND MR
FONG. THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
THAT ARE OF YES THANK YOU- FOR
THE PRESENTATIONS ON THIS TOPIC
I KNOW A LOT OF US HAVE BEEN
VERY ENGAGED IN HIGH SPEED
RAIL- AND YOU KNOW I REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT IT MAY BE
PREMATURE TO BE HAVING A
DISCUSSION ABOUT ALLOCATING THE
REMAINING BOND FUNDS RIGHT NOW
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT LEVEL OF
FUNDING OR FEDERAL MATCHES THAT
WE CAN EXPECT FROM WASHINGTON
TODAY- I HOPE THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DO PROGRESS- AND
GIVE US A BETTER SENSE. OF HOW
MUCH THEY'RE WILLING TO SUPPORT
THIS PROJECT- BUT YOU KNOW I
WORRY THAT INSUFFICIENT FUNDING
COULD LEAVE US WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT DOESN'T
ACCOMPLISH THE VISION OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND DOESN'T BENEFIT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- AND SO
THAT'S THAT I AM STILL
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AND I
THINK WE NEED FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THAT- IN WITH
THOSE CONCERNS I THINK ARE
THERE ALTERNATIVES YOU KNOW FOR
FROM THE CURRENT PLAN OF- AS
YOUR- MEMBER NUMBER SAID TO
BAKERSFIELD LINE AND I KNOW. OF
YEARS A COUPLE YEARS AGO AND
BUDGETS OF THREE I REQUESTED- A
STUDY OF POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES
TO THAT- PLAN AND I JUST WANNA
KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON AN
ALTERNATIVE TO- WERE SAID TO
BAKERSFIELD GIVEN THAT WE MAY
HAVE INSUFFICIENT FUNDING TO
COMPLETE OF. THE FULL VERSION
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL- THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I THINK I
WOULD ANSWERED THIS WAY WE- MY
BOARD DIRECTED OUR STAFF BACK
IN I THINK IT WAS TWENTY
NINETEEN ORIGINALLY. TO CONDUCT
A SIDE BY SIDE. ROB REVIEW AND
ANALYSIS OF WOULD BE MONIES WE
WERE THEN IDENTIFYING AS THE
INCREMENTAL ABOUT BETWEEN WHAT
IT TAKES TO COMPLETE OUR
FEDERAL FUNDING GRANT
REQUIREMENTS WHICH ARE THE
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES OF TRACK.
AND ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
DONE STATEWIDE IN ADDITION.
COMPLETING ALL OF THE BOOK AND
PROJECTS THAT WE NOW INVESTED
THAT INCLUDE HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN LA- FOR THE- I'LL
UNION STATION AND PROGRES
CROSSINGS AND IN THE BAY AREA
ELECTRIFICATION OF CALTRAIN. I
INTEGRATE CROSSING IN THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY- WE ARE. WE ARE
MOVING WE ARE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THAT AND WE AND WE ASK FOR
A SIDE BY SIDE STUDY ON THE
INCREMENTAL AMOUNT WHAT IS THE
BEST WAY TO ADDRESS THAT TO GET
MEANINGFUL BENEFIT FROM A
RIDERSHIP OF PERSPECTIVE M.
WHAT THAT SIDE BY SIDE
CONCLUDED WAS THAT EXTENDED
USING THOSE INCREMENTAL FUNDS
TO EXTEND TO BE ON THE ONE
NINETEEN TO THE CITIES OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY MERCED BAKER'S.
GOT US THE MOST RIDERSHIP
BENEFIT FOR THE LIMITED
INVESTMENT FUNDS COMPARED TO
TRYING TO USE THOSE FUNDS TO DO
SEVEN DOLLAR CORRIDR SPECIFIC
WORK IN OTHER PLACES WHILE
OTHER PLACES HAVE MORE
RIDERSHIP THEY ALSO HAVE THE I
THINK ROBUST TRANSIT OPERATIONS
AND THE INCREMENTAL BENEFIT OF
OUR MONEY IN THOSE DIDN'T
PRODUCE AS MUCH BENEFIT AS WELL
AS WHAT WE CAN PRODUCE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT MUCH THERE NOW AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THE SIDE BY SIDE
ANALYSIS SHOWED IT ALSO SHOWS.
TO GET TOTAL BENEFITS. OF WHAT
ONE NEEDED ON THE- CORRIDORS IN
THIS IN THE BAY AREA. THE MATCH
REQUIREMENT FOR OTHER FUNDS TO
COME INTO OUR- DELIVER. UP
ADDITIONAL- OPERATIONAL
BENEFITS WAS MUCH HIGHER THAN
WHAT WE SAW. IN THE BALLOT IN
SO. WITH THAT CONCLUSION AND
THAT WAS A STUDY WE PUBLISHED I
THINK IN NINETEEN ORIGINALLY
AND TALKED A LOT ABOUT IT
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY BUT WE
TALKED ABOUT AN AWFUL LOT OF
OUR BOARD WE TALKED ABOUT OF
THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR. LAST
SIX MONTHS WE SUBJECTED THAT
STUDY TO ADDITIONAL REVIEW SO
IN THAT STUDY WE LOOKED AT
ALTERNATIVES. WE GOT ADVICE ON
THE BEST WAY TO GO WITH THE
LIMITED FUNDS WE HAD AND THAT
CONCLUSION WAS GETTING
OPERATIONAL SEGMENT GOING
BETWEEN THE CITIES OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY GIVEN. THAT
YOU'RE SPENDING BILLIONS ON
ASSETS THERE TODAY AND SO THAT
IS WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION WE
MADE TO OUR BOARD THE
RECOMMENDATION WE ARE MAKING TO
THIS BODY AND YOUR LIGHT OF THE
REVIEW THAT WAS DONE. IN RECENT
MONTHS IT'S STILL THE
RECOMMENDATION. THAT WE ARE
MAKING THAT SET. LOOK WE ARE
FOR. BACK INVESTMENTS IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION UP AND DOWN THE
STATE AND WE KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF REVENUE OPTIONS TO DO
THAT SB ONE. WAS ONE NEW
FEDERAL MONEY WILL BE ANOTHER-
THERE'S OUT. OF OPTIONS AND A
LOT OF FUNDING REVENUE THAT'S
GOING INTO PROJECTS THAT WE DO
NOT GET. IN SO- WE THINK THIS
IS THE BEST USED TO GET OURS
GOING WE THINK. IT'S GOOD TO
FIND OTHER PROJECTS WITH A
BROADER SENSE OF RESOURCES THAT
WE CAN EXPAND ALL CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ITEMS THE
OPTIONS. BUT IN THE STATE I
GUESS THE LAST THING I WOULD
JUST SAY IT'S I THINK A RISK.
THAT SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON AS
WELL IF YOU JUST. WANT TO DO
THE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES- ED
AND NOT ALLOW US TO CONSIDER
HOW TO USE THE REMAINING OF OUR
BUDGET TO GET MORE OPERATING
BENEFIT. YOU WILL SPEND
SOMEWHERE IN THE AREA BETWEEN
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. TO BUILD A HUNDRED
NINETY MILE TRACK. CONTINUE TO
RUN DIESEL SERVICES ON THAT.
SCORE GO EIGHTEEN TRIPS A DAY
LEAVE IT BACK TO SEVEN OR
EIGHT. OF THEM CONTINUE TO
SHARE FREIGHT CORRIDORS. GET
INTO MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD.
AND NOT SEE A SIZEABLE INCREASE
IN RIDERSHIP IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND WE THINK THERE'S A
BETTER WAY. WE THINK EXPANDING
BEYOND THAT. WHAT TOWARD WHAT
OUR BUDGET LIMITATIONS ARE. CAN
GET BETTER BENEFIT IN
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED TRAINS
GOING. IN CALIFORNIA SOONER.
THAT WE THINK. THE EXPENDITURE
OF OUR ADDITIONAL BUDGET
DOLLARS. IS WORTH WHILE TO
ACHIEVE THAT. BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU'RE SPENDING FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND HAVE NOT ACHIEVED
MUCH. AND WE DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT. AND SO FOR US THAT'S A
PERSPECTIVE DIFFERENCE AND
THAT'S A CHANGE DIFFERENCE I.
JUST WANT TO REPEAT SOMETHING I
SAID EARLIER THERE'S NO
QUESTION. THAT WE NEED TO DO
THIS METHODICALLY. THAT YOU
NEED MORE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
IT WILL WORK AS DO WE- AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
COMMENCE THE ANALYSIS THE WORK
WE NEED. TO CONTINUE TO BRING
THIS BACK WE ARE NOT ASKING.
THE LEGISLATURE TO GIVE US ALL
TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
TODAY WE'RE ASKING. FOR THE
BOND DOLLARS THAT ARE DEDICATED
TO THIS PROJECT TO COMPLETE OUR
CONSTRUCTION. ON THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN WHEREAS WHICH WOULD
VANCE. UP SOME WORK. OUT OF SO
THAT WE CAN- MAP RIGHT AWAY GET
COST REFINEMENT DONE FOR MERCED.
THE BAKERSFIELD. AND WE'RE ASK
TO. LATE TRACKING VALUE THE
MOST YOU CAN AND EFFICIENT WAY
TO. THAT THIS MAY OUR OP
OBJECTIVES- JANET WELL WE DO
THINK THAT SHOULD BE ELECTRIFY.
I BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE
TOWARD THAT FUTURE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I MEAN THT'S
WHERE WE ARE THAT'S THE
COMPARISON WE'VE DONE. AND THAT
WE KNOW THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO.
THANK YOU. NEXT UP WE HAVE
MISTER SMITH FOLLOWED BY MR
FONG AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF
MY QUESTION IS FOR MR
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. AND YOUR BUSINESS
PLAN YOU SAY THAT YOU ONLY NEED
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. TO COVER ALL THE
FUTURE COST INCREASES FOR THE
EXISTING A HUNDRED NINETY MILES.
WHAT IS THE TOTAL VALUE OF THE
CHANGE ORDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED BY THE CONTRACTORS.
THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
AUTHORITY. BUT HAVE NOT BEEN
PROCESSED YET. IS A GREATER
THAN THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION. IS A GREATER THAN FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. OR IS IT CLOSE
TO A BILLION DOLLARS IN OVER
COST. THANK YOU. WELL A COUPLE
THINGS WE ARE WE VALUE WAIT
CHANGE ORDERS AS THEY COME IN
SO I DON'T HAVE A NUMBER FOR
YOU ON HOW MUCH OF COMING AND
WE'RE WE ARE PLACING THAT VALUE
RIGHT NOW I WILL TELL YOU THAT
OUR ESTIMATE AT THE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION THAT WE
PUT IN THE BILL IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. LOCAL AN
ESTIMATE OF WORK A CHANGE
ORDERS THAT WE KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE TO EXECUTE THAT ARE ABOVE
OUR ADOPTED BUDGET TO DATE AND
WHAT PARTS OF OUR DOCTORS
BUDGET MIGHT BE AVAILABLE FOR
THOSE CHANGE ORDERS SO THAT'S
WHY WE CALL THAT THE KNOWN
COSTS INCREASE IN ADDITION WE
ARE ADVOCATING PUTTING A
BILLION DOLLARS IN A RISK
CONTINGENCY BECAUSE WE KNOW
THEY'LL STILL HAVE TO BE
COMMERCIALLY NEGOTIATED. WHICH
MEANS WHILE WE PUT OUT AN
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE COST WE
ALSO KNOW WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH
A COMMERCIAL CONVERSATION IN
SETTLEMENT ON SOME OF THOSE
THINGS THAT MUST GET DONE TO
COMPLETE THE WORK AND I DON'T
HAVE A NUMBER FOR YOU TO
EXACTLY WHERE THAT WILL GO BUT
WE HAVE A WE ARE PROPOSING TO
ADOPT THE BUDGET THAT WILL
HANDLE. THE THREE THIRTY AND
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT THE OTHER
THING ABOUT THE RISK
CONTINGENCY IS THAT IT'S NOT
JUST DESIGNED FOR THIS CHANGE
ORDERS BUT OTHER RISKS IN LIFE
LIKE WE ARE GOING THROUGH WITH
THE COVERT NINETEEN EXPERIENCE
I SAID IN MY PRESENTATION THAT
IT DID AFFECT OUR- OUR
TIMELINES IT HAS AFFECTED OUR
SCHEDULE WHENEVER YOU AFFECTS.
SCHEDULE WITH THAT MONEY. AND
WANT TO BE MINDFUL THAT ONE OF
THE- ABOUT THAT. AND SO AGAIN
NOT ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL MONEY
FROM THE LEGISLATURE TO HANDLE
THIS. BUT USING OUR CURRENT
BUDGET. TO ADOPT A BROADER BASE
LINE THAT THAT ACCOUNTS FOR
MORE RESEARCH. AND COVERS WHAT
WE KNOW OUR COSTS THAT WILL
COME. TO A COMPLETE THE WORK IN
ABOUT. SO THE ONE POINT THREE
TOTAL IS DESIGN- TO BE
SUFFICIENT TO COVER ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. AND COMPLETE OUR
WORK. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
MY QUESTION IS TO THE L. A. L-
IT IS CERTAINLY HAVE VERY CLEAR
THAT THERE IS A BIPARTISAN
CONCERN OF THE INADEQUACY OF
THE FUNDING- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY HIGHLIGHTED A
POTENTIAL ONE BILLION DOLLAR
GAP- IN THE FIRST SEGMENT- THE
AUTHORITY DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE
PRESENTED A CREDIBLE PLAN TO
FILL THE SIXTY TO EIGHTY.
MILLION DOLLAR GAP FOR THE
WHOLE PROJECT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND ASK YOU TO GO
INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL-
ON PAGE SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
OF YOUR ANALYSIS OF THE PLAN
YOU ARE YOU HIGHLIGHT. NEAR
TERM CHALLENGES AND LONG TERM
FUNDING CHALLENGES-
SPECIFICALLY- ACTUAL COSTS FOR
THE MERCED BIG SHOW SEGMENT TO
BE HIRED ANTICIPATED UNCLEAR
EXPECT FUNDING- FORMER SAID THE
BIGGEST FAILED TO MATERIALIZE
AND CLEAR TIMING AS FUNDING-
THAT WOULD ALIGN WITH THE
PROJECT NEEDS TO AND THEN- I
SPECIFICALLY ACTUAL PROJECT
COSTS BEING HIGHER THAN CURRENT
ESTIMATES EACH YEAR. OR YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES WROTE- IF H. S.
R. A. APPLY THIS REVISED
APPROACH TO THE FULL PHASE ONE
OF THE PROJECT WOULD EXPECT
THAT THE ESTIMATED BASELINE
BUDGET WOULD BE HIGHER. THAN
THE CURRENT EIGHTY POINT THREE
BILLION ESTIMATE POTENTIALLY BY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND THERE'S
NO FUNDING PLAN BEYOND MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD AND YOU CONCLUDE
BY SAYING IF PROJECT COSTS ARE
ALSO HIGHER THAN ANTICIPATED
THIS FUNDING GAP WOULD BE EVEN
GREATER. SO COULD YOU GO INTO
SOME MORE SPECIFICS ON TERMS OF
THE CONCERNS ABOUT. THE FUNDING
AND WHY THERE ARE THESE NEAR
TERM FUNDING CHALLENGES AS WELL
AS THE CONCERNS AS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF. VALUE
WAITING IN THE LONG TERM
FUNDING CHALLENGES. SURE THANK
YOU- I THINK YOU'RE REFERENCING
SO OF THE WORKING WE DID WHAT.
YEAR A VALUE THAT PREVIOUS
DRAFT OF THE TWO TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN THAT WAS IN THE
LAST YEAR. I IN THAT- ANALYSIS
WE RAISED A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
POTENTIAL ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
REGARDING WITH THE SCHEDULE AS
WELL AS WITH REGARD TO THAT
COST AND FUNDING AVAILABLE. I'M
AND I THINK IN THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY WE FOCUS A
LOT JUST ON THIS MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD IS THERE GONNA BE
ENOUGH MONEY FOR CENTER
BAKERSFIELD- AND AGAIN IT'S AS
I MENTIONED- THERE'S NOT
CERTAINTY THAT THERE WILL BE
THERE. BUT I THINK EVEN BEYOND
THAT THERE'S CERTAINLY A
FUNDING GAP IF YOU WANT TO GO
BEYOND PERCENT TO BAKERSFIELD.
ON TO COMPLETE NINE BALLY AND
THEN AGAIN TO COMPLETE PHASE
ONE SO THAT THE EIGHTY POINT
THREE BILLION THAT YOU WERE
REFERENCING WITH THE NUMBER-
LAST YEAR. AND THAT WAS RELATED
TO YOU KNOW THE ESTIMATE THAT
TIME FOR COMPLETING PHASE ONE
BUT THAT ESTIMATE REALLY DIDN'T
EVALUATE FULLY RE EVALUATE THE
COST OF THE ENTIRE. OF THE
ENTIRE FEES ONE SO WE THINK.
YOU KNOW IF THE AUTHORITY. DO
WE ABOUT. CHRISTOPHER THE
GROUND THAT WHAT THAT COST BE
IT WOULD LIKELY SEEING. HOW
THAN AND I KNOW IT FOR THINGS
LIKE. YOU KNOW THIS- THAT
ASSUMING THAT NOW REALLY IS A
SCHEDULE THAT. WERE PLANNED ON
FULL FINDING OF THE ENTIRE
PHASE ONE WHICH- WHICH- IS NOT
IS NOT THE CASE SO- AND AS-
BRAND HI CAL REFEREE. YOU KNOW
WHEN THEY'RE DELAY THAT
TRANSLATES INTO INCREASED COSTS
USUALLY IN CONSTRUCTION WORLD.
SO CERTAINLY WE THINK THOSE
COSTS WOULD LIKELY BE HIGHER IF
THEY WERE IF THE WHOLE PROJECT
COST WITHOUT WERE REEVALUATED.
AND THERE WOULD BE A FUNDING
GAP TO DO PHASE ONE- CERTAINLY
IN THE IN THE TENS OF BILLIONS
IF NOT MORE SO- THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING GOT TO DO
THAT- THAT'S- REALLY. YOU KNOW
I THINK I CRITICAL QUESTION FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IS.
YES WELL AS THE CONNECTED
FINDING AGAIN NOT JUST RESET
THE BAKERSFIELD IF THE FUNDING
DOESN'T MATERIALIZE FOR THAT
THERE COULD BE. A GAP THERE AND
THE MILLIONS FOR EXAMPLE BYE.
BYE BUT FOR COMMUTING TO
FINDING VALUE VALLEY AND
EVENTUALLY PHASE WINE AND IN
THAT CASE THERE'S AND THERE'S A
MUCH LARGER FUNDING GAP AND
THAT'S- PROBABLY UNLIKELY TO BE
FULLY FILLED BY BY FEDERAL
DOLLARS ON. AND SO THERE
PROBABLY WOULD NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL STATE DOLLARS AND SO
I THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANNA CONSIDER. ITS TOLERANCE
FOR COMMITTING ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS TO THAT- SO I DON'T
KNOW. IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU WERE INTERESTED IN
THERE BUT BUT THAT WAS. THAT
WAS RETURNED TO OUR. MAIN
POINTS. AT THAT TIME. THANK YOU-
WE HAVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
FOLLOWED BY MEMBERS LIAM
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WHEN LOOKING AT
THE TWENTY TWENTY COLVIN IMPACT
TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL I'M
LOOKING AT THE DIFFERENT ITEMS%
YOU HAVE MY QUESTION IS WITH
CODE WE- WE- SAW THAT WE HAD A
LOT OF THESE PEOPLE THAT WOULD
NORMALLY BE COMMUTERS. WERE
STAYING AT HOME TO WORKING WAS
THAT TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
IN REGARDS TO THE REVENUE- ON
RIDERSHIP GOING FORWARD SINCE A
LOT OF THESE OF WORKFORCE WILL
BE STAYING AT HOME AND WILL NOT
BE TAKING THE TRAIN. THANK YOU.
OPERATIONAL SEGMENT DOESN'T
BEGIN UNTIL. TWENTY TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THIRTY FISCAL YEAR- AND
WE CERTAINLY HOPE WILL PASS
THE- CALL THE IMPACT OF THAT I
THINK. EVERY SURVEY I'VE SEEN
ON THE QUESTION OF WHETHER.
THERE'S AN EXPECTATION AFTER
VACCINES ARE FULLY KICKED IN
AND- WE'RE BEYOND THIS- THIS
CALL WITH. A PERIOD. THAT THAT
THERE IS AN EXPECTATION THAT
RIDERSHIP WILL RETURN. TO
TRANSIT OPERATIONS- GOING
FORWARD INSTANCE ARE OPERATING
TIMELINE IS BUT SO FAR OUT I
DON'T. WE DON'T FEEL LIKE
THERE'S- MUCH TO CHANGE IN
TERMS OF THE RIDERSHIP
ESTIMATES BECAUSE POINT BUT
IT'S SOMETHING TO MONITOR AND
CONTINUE TO. UP SEE WHAT HOW
THINGS COME BACK FROM COVERED
AGAIN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- BUT
NINE YEARS OUT FROM TODAY SO
WHAT BY THAT TIME WE CERTAINLY
THINK. THAT THERE WILL BE- A
FULL SORT OF RECOVERY FROM
THIS. PARTICULAR PANDEMIC IN
THAT RIDERSHIP WILL LIKELY
RETURN. CLICK ON THAT PLEASE- I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WITH THE
WORK FOR STAYING AT HOME THIS
IS JUST A NEW WAY OF WORKING
IT'S NOT SO MUCH OF THE
VACCINATION IS GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND SO THAT REALLY
IS MY QUESTION THAT I THINK A
LOT OF- A LOT OF US ARE GOING
TO STAY AT HOME WORK AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO NEED THIS TYPE OF
TRANSPORTATION- SO. I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED IN AND YOU'RE TALKING
THAT THEY REALLY WANT TO BE
INTO CONSIDERATION- FOR ABOUT
NINE YEARS SO- I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AT THE CONCERT
CHAIR I JUST WANNA I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR PEER REVIEW GROUP
SPEAKER BUT JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE ALSO MY CONTACTS MY
QUESTION IS THAT I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
FACT YOU KNOW ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED YEARS AGO MY ANCESTORS
PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE ME CAME
TO AMERICA TO BUILD A RAILROAD
THAT TRANSFORM THE COUNTRY A
RAILROAD SYSTEM THAT WE LARGELY
STILL RELY ON TODAY WITH ARE
VERY SLOW DIESEL POWERED.
TRAINS AND WE STATE POWER ALONG
A SO MY QUESTION TO ENSURE THAT
THIS VISION IS ACTUALIZED AND
CONTINUES TO BE A HALLMARK OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
HOPEFULLY CENTURIES THE CALM
IS- IN IN YOUR PRESENTATION YOU
TALKED ABOUT PROPOSING
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR THE
PROJECT COULD YOU ELABORATE ON
SOME OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
ABOUT SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
OPTIONS. TO KEEP OUR THIS
PROJECT GOING. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION HONESTLY
BECAUSE I THINK IT MAY BE THE
MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION SOMEONE
HAS ASKED ALL. THE PROBLEM THAT
THE PROJECT HAS HAD FROM THE
BEGINNING INSTEAD IT IS NOT AN
ACT OF THE LEGISLATURE AND IT
IS NOT A PROGRAM OF THE
GOVERNOR AND HELP WAS
ESTABLISHED. IN A PROPOSITION
ALL AND THAT PROPOSITION DID
NOT ESTABLISH AN ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT IN FACT
IT WAS. NEVER FUNDED ALL FULLY.
AND THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
PROJECT HAS STRUGGLED EVER
SINCE WITH THE ISSUE OF WHAT
CAN WE PAY FOR AND WHAT CAN WE
BUILT. AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
EVERY BUSINESS PLAN IS THAT THE
SCOPE HAS BEEN REDUCED FROM ONE
PLAN TO THE NEXT PARTLY BECAUSE
COSTS ARE GOING UP IN PART
BECAUSE- IT HAS BECOME THEY THE
SOURCES THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO
MATERIALIZE DID NOT. AND AS WE
I SAID IN OUR STATEMENT WE'VE
SAID IN OUR LETTERS BEFORE.
THIS PROJECT CAN NEVER BE
MANAGED ADEQUATELY AND STABLY
WITHOUT ADEQUATE AND STABLE
FUNDING. TO PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE- WE STARTED ON THIS
PROJECT IN THE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT OR SO IN THAT SAME PERIOD
OF TIME THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
HAS BUILT SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
MILES OF HIGH SPEED RAIL. NOW
I'M NOT ARGUING WE SHOULD ADOPT
THEIR APPROACH BUT I DO WANT TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT. THAT WITH
ADEQUATE FUNDING. RESOURCES AND
ADEQUATE PLANNING AND ADEQUATE
LOCATION. THINGS CAN GET DONE.
ALL I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
OF THOSE AND- YEAH I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE AN AGREED VISION
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR ASKED WHAT SHOULD
ULTIMATELY GET DONE. AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE A STABLE
AND ADEQUATE FUNDING PLAN TO
GET THAT DONE. ALL UP THERE ARE
PLENTY OF WAYS THAT THE STATE
SHARE COULD BE FINANCED IF WE
WANTED TO THIS IS ACTUALLY NOT
THAT DIFFICULT WE DISCUSSED
THIS BEFORE- EDITIONS TO THE
GAS TAX SUGAR TAX ADDITIONS TO
VARIOUS VEHICLE TAXES OF ONE
KIND OR THE OTHER. THERE ARE
PLENTY OF WAYS. COULD BE
FINANCED IF THE VISION IS
AGREED AND IF IT IS ADOPTED. SO
I CAME INTO THE KEY ISSUE
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE WHAT WE
WANT TO DO. AND WHAT ARE WE
WILLING TO PAY FOR. A AND I
THINK- YOU HANDLE AS WE SAID
THE CHANCE BECAUSE THE A
PROJECT- IS IN A KIND OF A
CONSOLIDATION POSITION RIGHT
NOW. YOU HAVE A CHANCE THE WITH
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR
TO SEE WHAT THE PICTURE OF
FEDERAL FUNDING WILL BE. MORE
OF A CHANCE TO SEE MUCH BETTER
WHAT THE COST OF THE LINKS AND
THEN EVENTUALLY THE COMPLETION
OF THE SYSTEM WILL BE. AND YOU
HAVE A CHEN TO SPEAK TO SEE THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
ENTERTAINMENT SYSTEM. TO BE
OPERATED YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO
SEE THAT JAIL. M. M. IN A
RECOMMENDATION IS THIS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO FOCUS ON THAT.
BUT WE DO WANT YOU TO BE AWARE
THAT IT IS THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANCE OF THAT NEW
MONEY OF SOME KIND WILL BE
REQUIRED EVEN TO COMPLETE THE
OF BAKERSFIELD TO UP PERCENT
SELECTION. AND AS OF THE L. A.
O. PERSON HELEN KIRSTEN SAID IT
CERTAINLY WILL BE REQUIRED IN
ORDER. TO GO OUTSIDE THAT AREA.
THANK YOU ARE A APPARENTLY OUR
LAST SPEAKER OUR LAST
QUESTIONER- ROUND ONE IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM IF
ANY OF YOU WHO HAVE NOT ASK
QUESTIONS WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED TO THE LIST LET ME KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY
QUESTION FOR MR KELLY. I LOOK
THROUGH THE DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN
AND SOME OF THE ITEMS CONTAINED
IN IT. AND I DON'T SEE ANY-
ANYTHING ALLOCATING FUNDS TO
LITIGATION OR LITIGATION RISK
WHICH IS CURIOUS TO ME. BECAUSE
IT OCCURS TO ME THAT. THERE
MAYBE MAYBE THERE ARE THERE
COULD BE LAWSUITS BROUGHT
AGAINST THIS PROJECT- MAKING
THE ARGUMENT THAT BECAUSE THE
SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE PROJECT
HAS BEEN CHANGED MATERIALLY.
FROM WHAT THE VOTERS PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT IN THE PROP
ONE A BOND- PROP ONE INITIATIVE
TO AUTHORIZE THE BONDS. THAT
ARE CHANGING THE SCOPE OF THIS
TO BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED- D.
ELECTRIFYING IT. MAKING IT
SINGLE TRACK AT CETERA- DOES
NOT. COMPORT WITH THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS WHEN THEY PASSED THE
ORIGINAL BOND WHEN THEY WERE
TOLD. BY THE WAY THAT THIS
WOULD BE A CONNECTING TRAIN
BETWEEN THE BAY AREA AND LOS
ANGELES. WHICH IS NOT. AND THAT
IT WOULD. MAKE THAT TRIP IN TWO
AND A HALF HOURS OR LESS WHICH
IT WON'T. SO I'VE ASKED THIS
BEFORE MISTER KELLY AND I'M
HOPING THAT YOU CAN GIVE US AN
UPDATE AS TO WHY THERE'S NO
LITIGATION RISK IN YOUR
BUSINESS PLAN. AND THE STATUS
OF ANY LAWSUITS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT ARGUING THAT. AND
WHETHER YOU FORESEE THAT BEING
A PROBLEM AS THE SCOPE OF THIS
PROJECT HAS MATERIALLY CHANGED
THANK YOU. I THINK THERE'S
SEVERAL ANSWERS TO THAT THE
FIRST IS- WE DO IDENTIFYING THE
RISKS OF SECTION LITIGATION AS
A- REST FOR THIS PROJECT WE
HAVE HAD LITIGATION. OVER ALL
ELEMENTS OF THIS PROJECT FROM.
OF BILLS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PASSED TO ALLOW US TO DO EARLY
INVESTMENTS LIKE IN THE
CALTRAIN. CORRIDOR THAT WERE
LITIGATED- WE WANT EARLY COURT
DECISIONS ON THOSE I BELIEVE
THE- THAT'S STILL ON THE
BALLOT- IT TODAY- WE- HAVE
SETTLED. ALL KINDS OF
LITIGATION THE VALLEY'S
BROWNING OF OUR MIDDLE
DOCUMENTS AND- WE WANT PREVIOUS
CASES. ON HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH SPENDING BOND
DOLLARS OR OTHER FUNDS
DEDICATED TO THIS PROJECT TO
BUILD WHAT WE'RE BUILDING. OUT
SO. YES LITIGATION IS ALWAYS A
RISK ON THIS PROJECT IT HAS
BEEN SINCE DAY ONE. I IT HAS
COST THE SCHEDULED TIME AND
MONEY- AND WE HAVE- EITHER
SETTLED OR- THEN VICTORIOUS ON
VIRTUALLY ALL LITIGATION. UP TO
THIS POINT- AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE STAND
ON LITIGATION I GUESS I WOULD
DISPUTE. THE CHARACTERIZATION
THAT SAYS WE'RE GETTING AWAY.
FROM PROP ONE NAY. I THINK IT.
IS EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE
WHAT WE ARE DOING. IS
RECOGNIZING. AS WAS THE CASE
THAT THEY THE BOND BILL WAS
APPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
BUILD THE ENTIRETY. OF PHASE
ONE. SO WE COME FORTH WITH
PLANS ON HOW WE GET THERE
INCREMENTALLY. THE ULTIMATE
DESIGN AND OPERATION OF THE
SYSTEM WILL MEET ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FACE. OF
THE PROP ONE A SYSTEM. AND WE
ARE NOT THE ONES ADVOCATING TO
GET AWAY FROM ELECTRIFICATION.
ON THE CONTRARY WE'RE THE ONES
PUSHING. FOR ELECTRIFICATION.
ELECTRIFICATION IS THE ONLY WAY
YOU GET HIGH SPEED RAIL.
ANYWHERE WITHOUT IT DON'T HAVE
HIGH SPEED RAIL. AND SO WE ARE
PUSHING FOR THAT. WE HAVE. TO
LAY OUT A VISION BECAUSE J.
WHAT LOU THOMPSON JUST TALK
ABOUT. BECAUSE NEVER BEEN A IS
NOT A STATE SOURCE FUNDING THE-
AND BUILD ALL OF THE PHASE ONE
SYSTEM. WE LAY OUT HOW WE WILL
GET THERE WITH WHAT WE HAVE.
AND WHAT WE PUT IN THIS
BUSINESS PLAN IS ELECTRIFIED HI
SPEED SYSTEM. BETWEEN MERCED
AND BAKERSFIELD AS THE FIRST
BUILDING BLOCK. THE COMPLETION
OF ALL OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS FROM LA TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND ANNA- THAT WOULD
LAY OUT THE PATH IF THE TRACK.
OPERATIONAL MODE IN THE DESIGN
SHOULD MAKE THE PROP ONE EIGHT
REQUIREMENTS AND WE WILL NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO DELIVER
THAT AND WE HAVE NEVER SAID
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THAT. AND
CERTAINLY SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
I'VE PREPARED BEFORE THIS
LEGISLATURE MANY TIMES AND I'VE
SET. I'M GIVING YOU EXACTLY
WHERE OUR CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES ARE ARE JOB IN
THESE PLANS IS TO LAY OUT OUR
PATH TO DO IT. AND AS LUKE
THOMPSON AND L. A. L. HE SAID
THE BIG CHALLENGES WE HAVE TO
DO IT WITHOUT HAVING SUFFICIENT
FUNDS TO BUILD AT ALL. SO WE
LAY OUT PROPOSAL OF HOW WE'LL
DO IT UNDER A BILDING BLOCK
APPROACH. JEFF MORE FEDERAL
MONEY COMES IN WE WILL DO MORE
AND WE WILL EXTEND FURTHER. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO. WE DON'T
KNOW THAT AS OF TODAY SO WE
HAVE PUT FORTH A PROPOSAL ON
HOW WE CAN GET ONE. I JUST
GOING. UP OUT WITH THE FUN THAT
WE- A THAT'S WHAT WE LAID OUT.
ASSEMBLY AND AS A HAS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND THANK YOU
TO THE PANEL THAT'S HERE BRIAN
I APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
AND- ALSO JUST FOLLOWING UP ON
OUR CONVERSATION FROM LAST WEEK
I I'D BE INTERESTED AND CURIOUS
TO KNOW AND FOR THE RECORD. I
AND MOST VERY STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THIS PROJECT I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN MY ONLY AND THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS. MY ONLY FRUSTRATION IS
THAT THIS PROJECT STARTED IN
CENTRAL VALLEY AND NOT IN- LOS
ANGELES CONNECTING TO NORTH
LANCASTER PALMDALE WHERE- AS
I'VE SAID BEFORE THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT TRAFFIC CONGESTION
AND A GREAT DEAL OF NEED. THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PROJECT AND
I DON'T SEE IT AS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO NECESSARILY THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT ISN'T TAKE
CONNECT LA TO BAY AREA BUT ITS
IMPORTANCE IS THE REGIONAL
CONNECTION. IT'S TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE UTILIZING THEIR
INDIVIDUAL VEHICLES LESS IN
THOSE SHORT SHORT ONE HOUR TWO
HOUR INTERVAL DRIVES WHICH THEN
BECOMES EVEN LONGER BECAUSE OF
THE CONGESTED IMPACT AND THE
WEAR AND TEAR ON EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT ENSUES BECAUSE OF
THAT- SO GETTING OFF OF THE
SOAPBOX FOR A MINUTE AND
GETTING INTO PRACTICAL NUMBERS
AND TO THE QUESTION PLEASE.
THANK YOU. HOW MUCH DO YOU
ENVISION COMING IN FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WHAT THAT'S
A GOOD QUESTION I MEAN I LIKE
TO START WITH GETTING THE
BILLION BACK THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TRIED TO TAKE-
I'VE WORKED WITH I THINK WE'RE
ALL GOING TO SEE MORE- AS THE-
CONGRESS MOVES PASSED THE
STIMULUS CONVERSATION AND
APPEARS TO BE GETTING INTO AN
INFRASTRUCTURE CONVERSATION-
YOU KNOW WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
ENOUGH TO BILL BEYOND THE
CENTER ABOUT- WHETHER THAT'S
SOUTHWARD TO PALMDALE AND
CERTAINLY INTO THE THAT GET THE
VALLEY TO VALLEY SYSTEM GOING
INTO THE BAYAREA. THAT'S
EXPENSIVE AND IT WILL TAKE A
LOT OF MONEY BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW BIG EXACTLY THEY'RE
PLANNING TO GO I KNOW THEY WERE
THERE SEEMS TO BE A REAL PUSH
TO BUILD THIS KIND OF STUFF WE
DIDN'T ASK FOR A SPECIFIC
DOLLAR SIGN BUT WE ARE ASKING
FOR A SUBSTANTIAL COMMITMENT
WHAT WE WOULD ULTIMATELY LIKE
TO SEE HAS. YOU KNOW TO DATE
WITH THE FEDERAL MONEY WE HAVE
RECEIVED IN THE STATE
COMMISSION ON THIS PROJECT THIS
IS A FEDERALLY FUNDED
PARTNERSHIP PROJECT BUT AS OF
TODAY THE STATE IS SPENDING
THIS IS ACCOUNTING FOR MORE
THAN 80% OF THAT BUDGET AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT BALLOTS
FOR AND IF WE IF WE GOT THAT TO
MORE TRADITIONAL SORT OF STATE
FEDERAL COMMITMENTS THAT WOULD
ALMOST REVERSE AND THAT WOULD
ENABLE US TO DO AN AWFUL LOT
MORE. SO I DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC NUMBER THAT WE'RE
EXPECTING I JUST DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'VE HAD COMMUNICATION
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT THESE KINDS
OF PROJECTS ARE UP TO THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
COUNTRY OKAY SO IT IF THE
CHURCH DOESN'T MIND ME
CONTINUING I KNOW WE NEED TO
WORK WITH GOALS AND I THINK I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE CAN ALSO
BE- OF HELP IF THERE ARE
SPECIFIC GOALS THAT WE CAN
TARGET SO WHAT IS YOUR WISH
LIST WHAT DO YOU THINK WHAT IS
IT THAT YOU WANT. WHAT. IS IT
THAT YOU WANT IS. A REALISTIC
NUMBER. OF WHAT ARE THE BENCH.
AND WHAT IS IT WHAT WE CAN BE
PUSHING FOR AND STRIVING FOR.
OUR APPROACH THIS AGAIN KEEPING
IN MIND I KNOW I HEARD WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT YOU KNOW.
UNFORTUNATE FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT STARTED IN THE
VALLEY. I DIDN'T MAKE THAT
DECISION YOU CAN MAKE THAT
DECISION- BUT THAT IS THE PLACE
THAT IT STARTED IN SO THE FIRST
THING I WOULD SAY IN TERMS OF
OUR GOAL IS. WE DON'T INTEND TO
LEAVE THE VALLEY WITHOUT HAVING
A VALUABLE SYSTEM THERE. SO I
WOULD SAY THE FIRST THING IS TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN GET AN
OPERATING SYSTEM GOING THERE
THAT MAKES SENSE SECONDLY. I
WOULD. HI I'M BETTING COURAGE
BY WORK IN THE BAY AREA AND THE
IDENTIFICATION OF POTENTIAL
REGIONAL MATCHING FUNDS FROM
THE BAY AREA TO EXPAND OUR
VALLEY SERVICE FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY INTO SILICON VALLEY.
WHICH HAS TREMENDOUS RIDERSHIP
BENEFITS FOR US SO THAT IS A
GOAL AND OBJECTIVE THAT WE
WOULD LIKE FEDERAL HELP. IN
GETTING TO I THINK THE
COMBINATION OF FEDERAL DOLLARS
REGIONAL DOLLARS AND- WHAT WE
CAN BRING TO THAT CAN BE
HELPFUL. AND I THINK OUR FIRST
STEP AT LEAST THE FIRST LOOK
INTO THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION. IS HOW WE WILL BE ABLE
TO WORK OFF OF THE COMPLETION
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT
ON DEL LATER THIS YEAR AND SEE
IF WE I CAN'T START TO WORK ON
THE CONNECTING POINT YOU TO
THAT POP DOWN. A CORRIDOR AND
THERE'S A LAPSE IN AMBITIOUS
LIST RIGHT THERE SO WE DO HAVE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO
ASK QUESTIONS- OUR ADJUSTER SAY
WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES
LEFT- BEFORE WE NEED TO BEGIN
OUR SECOND PANEL- MISTER
BENNETT IS JUST OUT ON IS A-
ASKING HIS FIRST QUESTION. AND
UNLESS THERE'S SOMEBODY ELSE
WANTS TO ASK A QUESTION IN THE
FIRST ROUND WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
AROUND TO AT LEAST TWO PEOPLE.
ON THE LIST FOR QUESTIONS AND
ROUND TWO AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL
BE ABLE TOGET TO ALL THOSE
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF CREDIBILITY IS-
FOR THE OVERALL PROJECT. IT IS
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN SHAKEN- YOU.
HAVE DO YOU WE HAVE THE OF THE
TO REALISTICALLY COME UP WITH A
CREDIBLE OVERALL NUMBER THAT WE
NEED. TO DO THE FULL SCOPE OF
THIS PROJECT SO THAT WE COULD
TALK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS THAT'S WHERE. WE'RE AT I
MEAN DO WITH THE ORIGINATED
EIGHT OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW BUT
THAT OPPORTUNITY COULD BE LOST
IF WE DON'T HAVE. SOME
CREDIBILITY WITH A CREDIBLE
NUMBER DO YOU THINK IT'S
POSSIBLE TO COME UP WITH A
CREDIBLE NUMBER AFTER WEEK SO.
DRAMATICALLY UNDER. ESTIMATED
THIS IS A- POLITICS AFTER THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW WHAT I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT YOU KNOW MY APPROACH SINCE
I'VE TAKEN THIS JOB IS TO. NOT
TALK ABOUT THE- COST ISSUES IN
IN RANGES RIGHT NOW BECAUSE-
WE'RE- YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS THAT IS
THE EARLY STAGE. OF A OF A
MASSIVE CONSTRUCTION PROJECT.
AND SO- WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO
TO REFINE THOSE COSTS TO GET
THEM TO GREATER CERTAINTY AND
THAT'S WHY. WE ARE RECOMMENDING
IN OUR BUSINESS PLAN THAT ONCE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK IS DONE.
WE IMMEDIATELY ADVANCED DESIGN
WORK AND DO. FURTHER NECESSARY
WORKS WORKS FINE. BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A CREDIBLE RANGE THAT WE
NOW- ARTICULATE IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN. FOR SEGMENTS THERE'S A
PAGE IN THE BUSINESS PLAN THAT
HAS A SEGMENT. BY SEGMENT COST
ESTIMATE- TIED TO IT. AND AGAIN
IT'S RELATIVELY EARLY BECAUSE
WE'RE JUST WORKING THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS AND I'D
LIKE TO SEE. DESIGN ADVANCED.
BUT CERTAINLY WE KNOW OF A
BROAD FEDERAL PROGRAM- THAT
WOULD ENABLE US TO. THINK
BEYOND THE VALLEY GET INTO THE
BAY AREA GETS FURTHER SOUTH.
WITH A LONG TERM FEDERAL
COMMUNITY COMMITMENT TO
ELECTRIFY HIGH SPEED RAIL. BUT
WOULD BE HELPFUL IN HELPING US
ADVANCE THAT WORKS FINE THOSE
COSTS IN. THAT CAN GET THERE
BUT WE. DO HAVE IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN GET. HE SAID VICE- ACOSTA.
AND ARE TO THAT SAME THIS PLAN
THAT A BASED COSTS ESTIMATE.
FOR THIS SURVEY CERTAINLY
ENOUGH TO OUR TICKET TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WHAT IT
WILL TAKE TO GET TO THE AREA
WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO GET TO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BASED.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO MOVE TO
ROUND TWO NOW I HAVE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. PATTERSON AND
SMITH. IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO ASK A MISTER
KELLY TO TRY TO BE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE MUCH TIME AND I
THINK A LOT OF US HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS TO TRY TO PLEASE BE
CONCISE. WITH YOUR ANSWERS. SO
FIRST I AM INTERESTED IN THE
SINGLE TRACK A PROPOSAL. GIVEN
THAT YOUR- THE GOAL ONE OF YOUR
GOALS IS TO BUILD RIDERSHIP AND
YOUR RIDERSHIP NUMBERS THAT
I'VE SEEN ARE BASED ON THE DUAL
TRACK SYSTEM WITH A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF TRAINS RUNNING SO I'M
JUST WONDERING JUST QUICKLY.
WITH THE SINGLE TRACK HOW MANY
TRAINS SHOULD BE RUNNING HOW
THAT AFFECTS YOUR- OF. THE
NUMBER OF TREE TO BE RUNNING
PER DAY AND HOW IT AFFECTS THE
SPEED OF THIS TRAIN SINCE I'M
ASSUMING IF IT'S MORE THAN ONE
TRAIN. TRAINS HAVE TO PULL OVER
AND STOP. AND IF IT'S JUST
WONDERING THAT WAS RADICALLY
IMPACT THE- THE PROMISE OF WHAT
WAS IT FIFTEEN TRIPS ADAY. OR
WHATEVER IT WAS HE SAID AND HOW
DOES ALL OF THOSE AHEAD OF
THOSE OPERATIONAL CHANGES THEN
CHANGE THE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS.
BOB OUR ESTIMATION ON WHAT ON
ONE TRACK WE WILL STILL BE ABLE
TO MEET EIGHTEEN TRAINS PER
DAY- BECAUSE OF THE-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRACKS. FOR
TRAINS TO. KNOW COOPER PASS
EACH OTHER AT MAINTENANCE AND-
CITING. DISABILITIES WE HAVE A-
LOT OF ANALYSIS ON THIS THAT
IT. THAT EXPLAINS THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU- IN
YOUR OFFICE BUT- THERE IS NO
CHANGE IN THE- OUR DAILY TRIPS
WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT WITH EITHER
ONE OR TWO TRACKS- THERE. IS
SOME IMPACT- MINOR IMPACT ON.
RIDERSHIP IN THE 2% RANGE
SYSTEM WIDE UP FROM FROM ONE
TRACK TO MANDATE A MINOR IMPACT
ABOUT TWO POINT 2% ON.
ESTIMATED REVENUE UP FROM ONE
TRACK TO BUT AGAIN WE HAVEN'T
MADE A FINAL DECISION ON ONE.
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE OF THE
SPEED OF THE TRUCK OF THE TRIPS.
YEAH THEN AGAIN- TRAINS WILL
TRAVEL AT THE MAXIMUM SPEED- IN
CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF THAT. OF
THAT SYSTEM TO BE PARTS OF IT
WERE THEY'LL TRAVEL XPW MILES
AN HOUR AND THEN THEY'LL SLOW
DOWN TO GET INTO. IN THE
STATION SO THAT THE SPEED ISSUE
IS AGAIN NOT AFFECTED BY THE
ONE OR TWO BUT TRACK THAT
ISSUE- AFTER STOP AND WAIT FOR
A TRAIN TO GO BY. I KNOW THE
WAY THAT I THE WAY THAT THE
SYSTEMS AND COMMUNICATIONS WILL
WORK- THE TRAINS UP MOSTLY HAVE
TO SLOW DOWN COMING IN AND OUT
OF STATIONS- THERE MAY BE
PASSING ELEMENTS WERE TRAINED.
WILL WAIT FOR THE ONE TO PASS
BEFORE IT PROCEEDS BUT THE WAY
WE WORK OUT THE OPERATING
ELEMENTS OF THAT AGAIN I CAN
SHARE THE ANALYSIS WITH YOU-
BUT CHANGE WILL ACTUALLY
PROBABLY WANT TO TRAVEL A
LITTLE HIGHER SPEED ON THE-
SINGLE TRACK OPTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT CAN MEET THE
CONNECTING POINTS. ON BOTH ENDS
AND SO. AGAIN I HAVE A FULL
ANALYSIS ON THAT WE CAN SHARE
WITH YOUR OFFICE BUT AGAIN WE
BELIEVE WE CAN MEET THE
OPERATING REQUIREMENTS OF THE
TWO OR ONE TRACK. JUST FOR THAT
INTERIM SECTION AND AGAIN.
OTHER OPTIONS INCLUDE BUILDING
ADDITIONAL CITING IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO.
AT THIS TIME OUR ANALYSIS IS WE
CAN MEET THE OPERATING
REQUIREMENTS OF EITHER OF THE
TWO TRACK OR SINGLE TRACK
SYSTEM. FOR WHAT WE PROMISED
NUMBER SET THE BAKERSFIELD
STRETCH AND AGAIN I'M HAPPY. TO
SHARE OUR ANALYSIS WHICH ARE.
MISTER PATTERSON. MISTER KELLY-
I HAVE NOTICED SOME MYSTERIOUS
ACTIVITY IN THE PUBLIC RECORDS
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. SOME TIME BACK A
SPECIAL MATTERS COMMITTEE WAS
FORMED IT HAS BEEN MEETING
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS ON A WEEKLY
BASIS CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THIS
SPECIAL MATTERS COMMITTEE IS
MEETING ABOUT SO REGULARLY AND
IN SECRET- YEAH I MEAN AS YOU
PROBABLY ARE AWARE OF BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS JIMMY TO.
DISCUSS PERSONNEL MATTERS AND-
THAT IS WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
BEYOND THAT BECAUSE IT'S A
PERSONNEL MATTER I CAN'T
COMMENT. HAS THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY RECEIVED A
FEDERAL SUBPOENA IN THE PAST
YEAR. AFTER A SEPARATE QUESTION
ALL- OUR BE WILLING TO BET THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO GET TO IT BUT
LET'S HEAR FROM MISTER SMITH
AND HAS AMASSED CHECK THIS IS A
FOLLOW UP. TO HIS HIS ANSWER
HE'S SAYING THAT THIS HAS
EXECUTIVE IN I'M ASKING HAS THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
RECEIVED A FEDERAL SUBPOENA IN
THE LAST YEAR. YEAH I THINK THE
ANSWER TO THAT WOULD BE I THINK
IT'S SO US THE SIMILAR
QUESTION. TEN MONTHS AGO WHEN I
APPEAR BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE ANSWER IS AS I SAID
THEN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OFFICE WAS. YEAH VALUE WAITING
AT A NOT A SEPARATE PERSONAL
MATTER NOT THE SAME ONE TRIED
TO. WHAT ARE BORDERS THAT
MEETING ON WHY AND I TOLD YOU
THEN THAT I THINK THEY WERE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ON THAT AND THEY- HAVE
SOUGHT. DOCUMENTS TO WELCOME.
TO CONDUCT THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION AND I'LL TELL YOU
IN THE TEN MONTHS SINCE WE LAST
SPOKE. I HAVE NOT HEARD. A WORD
UP DOWN OR SIDEWAYS ABOUT BUT
WHERE THAT IS SO I HAVE.
NOTHING NEW TO ADD FROM WHAT I.
POSTED BY TOO MUCH SO I
EXPECTED THAT KIND OF ANSWER
SOONER OR LATER SIR YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO LET. THE
AUTHORITY GOING HAVE TO LET US
KNOW AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
KNOW WHAT HAS BEEN THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS SECRET MEETING WEEK AFTER
WEEK THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE OUT OF IT. OF COURSE OPEN
THIS QUESTION IS AND
TRANSPARENCY. MISTER SMITH
PLEASE. THIS IS A- YOUR
QUESTION PLEASE. ZERO MISTER
CHAIR MY QUESTION IS FOR MR
THOMPSON ACTUALLY FROM THE PIER
VIEW REVIEW COMMITTEE. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF WILL GIVE ME A
COUPLE SECONDS TO GET UP BUT-
IN YOUR EXCITEMENT ALEVE TO AN
EXPERT SIR. IN YOUR EXPERT
OPINION IS- WHAT IS THE
ADVANTAGE TO BUILDING A SINGLE
TRACK. OTHER THAN CUTTING THE
COST. IN THERE DO YOU KNOW OF
ANY SINGLE TRACK HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN THE WORLD. WELL THE
ADVANTAGE TO BUILDING THE
SINGLE PRACTICE OF PATIENTS THE
MONEY REQUIRED TO ADD THE
SECOND TRACK OUT IN TIME. HELLO
BUT THAT COMES AT THE RISK OF
HAVING TO THE TOTAL COST WHEN
THEY FINALLY DO IT. BUT AGAIN
THIS IS THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF
CONSERVING MONEY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH AS THEY
WOULD WITH BRITNEY AND IN ORDER
TO COMPLETE THE SYSTEM. I DON'T
KNOW OF ANY ALL HIGH SPEED
RAILROADS ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
THAT OPERATE ON SINGLE TRACK
ALL THOSE THERE'S ALWAYS A
RAILROAD EXCEPTION TO
EVERYTHING. THAT HAVING BEEN
SAID I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
IDEA OF A SINGLE TRACK
OPERATION IF YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
KIND OF SCHEDULE PLANNING SO
THAT THE TRAIN STOP IN THE
STATIONS ARE AND PASSAGE OTHER
AND STATIONS OVER AT OTHER
SIGHTINGS. IT COULD WELL HAVE
AN IMPACT ON THE SCHEDULE THAT
THEY CAN OPERATE AND I CAN
CERTAINLY HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
RELIABILITY OF THE SCHEDULED.
TO OPERATE. BUT AS A AS AN
INTERIM MEASURE ALL AS LONG AS
THIS IS PART OF A COMMITMENT TO
COMPLETE THE SYSTEM EVENTUALLY.
AS A STEP ALONG THE WAY I DON'T
HAVE ANY GREAT CONCERN ABOUT
THIS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
MISS FRIEDMAN WERE BACK TO YOU
THANK YOU THREE MISTER KELLY
AGAIN PLEASE BE BRIEF A WHY ARE
YOU NOT LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES TO ELECTRIFIED
HIGH SPEED RAIL THAT ARE JUST
AS CLEAN. GIVEN THAT WE'RE A
FEW YEARS AWAY FROM THE STRAIN.
CARRYING PASSENGERS AND
CERTAINLY MANY YEARS AWAY FROM
THE FULL SYSTEM BEING
COMPLETED. SO TECHNOLOGY LIKE
FUEL CELL TRAINS AND OR ANY
OTHER DEVELOPING INNOVATIONS
ISN'T IT A RESPONSIBLE TO NOT
CONSIDER EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES.
AND DO YOU BELIEVETHAT THE
VOTERS DIDN'T INTEND FOR
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES TO BE
CONSIDERED. BY HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THE BOND BILL THAT THE BOND.
SORRY THE BOND BILL THAT THE
VOTERS APPROVED- HAS
PERFORMANCE REQUIREMENTS IN IT
IN TERMS OF TRAVEL TIMES IN
SPEECH THAT WE MUST REACH I
KNOW OF NO FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY
TRAINING THAT CAN MOVE AT THE
SPEECH THAT WE ARE REQUIRED
UNDER THE BOND BILL TO MOVE.
AND THE ONLY TECHNOLOGY THAT I
KNOW OF THAT CAN ACHIEVE THAT
IS ELECTRIFIED STEEL ON STEEL.
GOOD INTO YEARS OUR TIMING SO
YOU DON'T THINK THAT TWO YEARS
OR THREE YEARS FROM NOW THE-
FUEL CELL TRAINS THAT NOW
OPERATE OF. A LIGHT RAIL FOR
INSTANCE THAT AS THEY DEVELOP
THOSE AND I KNOW OF SEVERAL
THAT ARE IN DEVELOPMENT AROUND
THE WORLD YOU KNOW WHO DOES ANY
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY WILLBE
THE PREFERRED TECHNOLOGY THAT
CAN MOVE AS FAST AS ELECTRIFIED
TRACK. I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO BE MOVING IT TWO
HUNDRED PLUS MILES PER HOUR BUT
THEY MIGHT BE AND WE CAN
CONSIDER. THOSE KIND OF OPTIONS
I SUPPOSE. IF AND WHEN THAT
MATERIALIZE OKAY BUT WHAT I
KNOW NOW IS THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE ARE ON NOW IS PROVEN. IT
OPERATES AROUND THE WORLD
FISSION LEE AND FAST. AND IT
CUTS TRAVEL TIMES MAGNIFICENTLY
GREAT AND IT IS ALSO. JUST I
THINK YOU'VE ANSWERED LET'S
LET'S KEEP GOING WITH THE OTHER
QUESTIONS- MR FONG HAS MISSILE
WILL COME RIGHT BACK TO YOU.
BUT A DIFFERENCE OF THE JAGS OF
ONE QUESTION AND I'LL- I'LL
GIVE MY TIME BACK BY A TO THE
L. A. L. IF THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVES- THIS FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR CORPORATION WHICH WE'RE
EXPECTING WILL COME AT SOME
POINT WHAT WHAT THE COST OF THE
DEBT SERVICE B. I JUST
GENERALLY CURIOUS- IF WE
CALCULATED THAT. WE HAVEN'T I
HAVEN'T DONE A SPECIFIC
CALCULATION ON THAT ONLY THE
FOUR BILLION BANK OVER TIME
USUALLY IN ABOUT DOUBLES THAT
I'M NOT TOO KEEN TO ACCOUNT THE
FACT THAT FUTURE I DOLLARS ARE
TYPICALLY SERVE OF THE LAST
VALUE THAN. THE CURRENT DOLLARS
BUT BUT USUALLY IT'S SORT OF
WITHIN THAT RANGE OF COURSE
IT'S GOING TO DEPEND ON A
VARIETY OF FACTORS INCLUDING
WHEN THOSE BONDS ARE SOLD IN IT
BUT WHAT INTEREST RATE.
CURRENTLY INTEREST RATES ARE-
YOU NEAR HISTORIC LOWS BUT BUT
CERTAINLY AND YOU SAID THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE COSTS AND LIKE
PROBABLY- COMPARED TO THAT BUT
IT WOULD DEPEND ON IT IF.
ACTUALLY ULTIMATELY WHEN
THEY'RE SOLD- WHAT WHAT RATE
THE STATE GETS BACK YES THERE
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH REPAIRING.
THOSE- DO YOU THE INTEREST. J.
SURVIVE ABOUT- TO SO I BACK-
BECAUSE THERE WAS A- USING.
COULD BE DONE THAT. USUALLY
THAT'S OF THE ROLE OF THUMB
HOUSING. ROUGH RULE OF THUMB-
IT'S GOING TO DEPEND ON THIS OF
THIS- AND THE INTEREST RATES
ARE AND I HAVEN'T DONE IT I
SPECIFIC CALCULATION FOR THAT
FOUR POINT. ONE BILLION DOLLARS
SO I'M HESITANT TO GIVE A
SPECIFIC NUMBER AT THIS POINT
OKAY I'VE UP I'LL GIVE MY TIME
BY THE CHURCH. THANK YOU ALEJO.
I HAVE MS FRIEDMAN- THIS MISS
DAVIS HAVE HER. OH I'M SORRY I
MISSED YOU- MS DAVIS. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT. MR KELLY DO YOU
THINK THE VOTERS WOULD HAVE
APPROVED PROPOSITION ONE A FONT
THEY WOULD BEEN TOLD THAT THE
INVESTMENT WAS ONLY ENOUGH TO
ALMOST BUT NOT TOTALLY COMPLETE
A SINGLE TRACK. SLOWER SPEED
TRAIN SERVICE WITH MINIMUM
STATION CONNECTING TO MERCED
AND BAKERSFIELD. I THINK THE
VOTERS APPROVED PROP ONE A. TO
BUILD IT AND KNOWING BECAUSE
THE- GENERAL. ELECTION VOTER
PAMPHLET SAID THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH YOUR TO BUILD AT ALL. SO
I THINK THE VOTERS WOULD HAVE
SAID. BOB WOULD HAVE APPROVED
US MOVING FORWARD ON
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND LA.
AND I IC. RECENT POLLS THAT
SUGGEST THEY STILL SUPPORTED AT
ROUGHLY THE SAME AMOUNT. OF THE
PASSAGE OF THE ORIGINAL BOND
BILL. IS FRIEDMAN. THANKS I'M
NOT EXACTLY SURE WHO THIS
QUESTION IS FOR- BUT IF CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE PROJECTS AREN'T
MOVING FORWARD THIS YEAR LIKE
THE- TRACKING SYSTEMS
CONTRACTED ANY DEVELOPMENT OF
THE PROJECT BEYOND THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILES. WITH THE
APPROPRIATION OF THE ADDITIONAL
FOUR POINT ONE BILLION A
PROPOSITION ONE A FUNDS NEED TO
BE. NEEDED IN THE- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. TO THE
EXTENT THAT DIRECTOR TOWARD ME
THE ANSWER IS. YES BECAUSE. WE
ADVOCATING THE BILL THE- FOR.
TO COMPLETE THE COULD. OF THE
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES YEAH
THE- THE PATIENT WHICH CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS. COMMAND WILL
KEEP PACE WITH THAT
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED. ARE THE BOND BILL
APPROPRIATION TO COMPLETE. THE
WORK ON SCHEDULE IN THE CENTER
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE MINUTE- MS
FRIEDMAN TO HAVE A I DO NOT
QUESTIONS AND ACTUALLY I THINK
THE NEXT PANEL WON'T HAVE AS
MANY QUESTIONS I WOULD
APPRECIATE. JUST BEING ABLE TO.
ASK THESE. A HOW. WELL I DID
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE NEW
OPERATING SUBSIDY REQUIRED BY
PROPOSITION ONE ABLE FOR THE L.
A. O. BUT- OF ALL SKIP THAT-
I'M WONDERING HOW HIGH SPEED
RAIL FITS INTO THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND SEVENTY
NINE DASH TWENTY IN HIS ORDER
THAT THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY AND OTHERS. CHAU
IDENTIFIED NEAR TERM ACTIONS
AND INVESTMENT STRATEGIES TO
IMPROVE. IT IMPROVE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION EXCEPT FOR A
WHILE CONTINUING A FIX IT FIRST
APPROACH TO OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM SO HOW DOES FIX IT FIRST
FIT IN. WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL. I
THINK FICTION FIRST IS
CONSISTENT WITH- WELL IF THE
TENANTS THAT CAME OUT OF PASSED
THE ONE THAT WERE REALLY DRIVEN
AT CRITICALLY ON THE ROAD AND
HIGHWAY SIDE OF MAKING SURE
THAT BRIDGES AND ROADS ARE IN
SUCH GOOD CONDITION ASKING. IN
A WAY THAT STREETS ROADS
HIGHWAYS BRIDGES. ARE VERY
SAFE- AND IN GOOD STRUCTURAL
CONDITION. I THINK THE OTHER
PART OF THAT IS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND REALLY THROUGH
AGENCY WHO IS DOING THE WORK TO
IMPLEMENT- THE ISSUES AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ARTICULATING
THE KIND OF PRIORITIES FOR
BROADER CLEAN. I TRANSIT AND
CALIFORNIA TOOLS THEY HAVE TO
FORWARD THOSE CLEAN TRANSIT
OPTIONS IN CALIFORNIA BUT I
THINK ASSURING THAT
CONNECTIVITY AMONG THOSE OTHER
OPERATORS WITH SYSTEMS LIKE
HIGH SPEED RAIL- ARE- COME TO
FRUITION. AND I WOULD EXPECT
THAT THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
YOU WILL SEE AS THEY COME FORTY
THIRD JULY THANK YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR MR THOMPSON THE
PEER REVIEW GROUP RECOMMENDED
THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY EXECUTE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN. JOINT HERS OF THIRTY
BEFORE EXECUTING THE TRACKING
SYSTEMS CONTRACT DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT MO YOU THAT IT'S BEEN
ENTERED. INTO SATISFIES YOUR
RECOMMENDATION. WELL I THINK
THE- THANK Y. INTERGENDER I
THINK THE MO YOU IS A STATEMENT
OF INTENTIONS BUT IT IS NOT IN
AGREEMENT AND THERE ARE NO
COMMITMENTS TO LIVE UP TO THOSE
INTENTIONS. BECAUSE OF THE
SUCCESSFUL OPERATION OF THE
INTERIM SYSTEM THAT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS PROPOSING.
BECAUSE THAT IS HIGHLY
DEPENDENT ON THE ACTIONS OF THE
STATE AND THE SAN JOAQUIN JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY AND DAIS- I
THINK IT WOULD BE PRUDENT THAT
THAT IN MY VIEW BE CONVERTED
INTO A MUCH CLEARER SET OF
COMMITMENTS OF WHO'S GOING TO
DO WHAT AND WHERE THE MONEY IS
COMING. FROM THAN WHAT YOU HAVE
NOW THEN I THINK YOU WOULD HAVE
A LOT MORE CONFIDENCE THAT THE-
THAT THE- INTERIM SYSTEM
INCLUDING THOSE LINKS COULD BE
MANAGED COULD BE COMPLETED AT
MADDOX. HAVE YOU EVER GIVEN ANY
THOUGHT AS TO WHETHER A
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS
CALTRANS AT SOME POINT WOULD BE
BETTER SUITED TO RUNNING THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. I
BELIEVE THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY- IN
THE LONG RUN IS TO OPERATE THIS
WINTER BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
ALL RIGHT THE SHORT TERM I
THINK THE OF SAN JOAQUIN
SERVICES ALREADY BEING PRETTY
WELL OPERATED AND- AND
EXTENSION OVER THE HIRES PEOPLE
INTO SOMETHING THAT THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO MANAGE PRETTY WELL.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN THIS MY LAST
QUESTION FOR YOU THAT THERE'S
IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. ABOUT
WHEN SOME OF THESE DIFFERENT
DECISIONS SHOULD BE MADE
BETWEEN YOU AND HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND I'M WONDERING IF I THAT'S A
CORRECT TAKE AWAY ON MY- ON MY
PART. I DON'T. MEAN BRANDS
SHOULD ALSO ANSWER THIS BUT I
DON'T SEE THAT THERE'S MUCH OF
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. I
THINK WE'RE BOTH SAYING THAT.
THAT HAVE THAT THE NECESSARY
IMMEDIATE TERM ACTIONS ARE TO
COMPLETE THE FEDERAL COMMITMENT
FROM THE ERA. OF GRIMMETT THAT
SHOULD BE DONE. BUT WE HAVE SIX
MONTHS TO A YEAR TO SEE HOW A
LOT OF THINGS DEVELOPMENT
BEFORE DEVELOP BEFORE
COMMITMENTS OUTSIDE THAT AREA
WILL BE NECESSARY. SO YOU KNOW
TO GO BACK TO THE OTHER ISSUES
THIS IS A GOOD TIME TO HEDGE
BETS AND SEE HOW THINGS DEVELOP
BEFORE. LONGER TERM COMMITMENTS
OUTSIDE THE CVS OR RITE I GUESS
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE I'M NOT
CLEAR WHETHER HIGH SPEED RAIL
SHARES THAT OPINION OR NOT. BUT
WE COULD BE YOU COULD BE RIGHT.
MY LAST QUESTION IS ACTUALLY
FOR THE L. A. WHICH IS WHETHER
THE L. A. IS CONSIDERED WHAT
INVESTMENTS IN SHARED MOBILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE THE SHE SHOULD
BE MAKING TO REDUCE. THE MOST
AMOUNT OF GREENHOUSE GASES. AND
TO ADDRESS CONGESTION AND
EQUITY ISSUES. AND WHETHER WE
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE ENOUGH.
PICTURE OF THE STATE'S MOBILITY
NEEDS. TO I DON'T WE'VE DONE A
COUPLE REVIEW OF THAT WOULD-
CERTAIN EIGHT WOULD BE A THING
GAP AND I EVEN WHAT THE
AUTHORITY DID WHICH WAS LOOKING
REALLY IT JUST YOU KNOW A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS ALONG THE
ALIGNMENT WAS WITH A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK AND
SO CERTAINLY LOOKING AT ALL THE
TRANSPORTATION COST- DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WILL BE WITH YOU A LARGER
ENDEAVOR FOR SURE SO- I DON'T
THINK WE'VE DONE THAT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO- ESPECIALLY
THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
MISTER KELLY. MISTER THOMPSON
AND MISS CHRISTINE AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO. PANEL NUMBER
TWO. RELATING TO INVESTMENTS IN
OTHER CORRIDORS ARE. LISTS ON
PANEL TO OUR HOUSE ON A
CONSTANTLY. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS STEPHANIE WIGGINS
THE CEO OF METROLINK. AND
STACEY MORTENSEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ALTAMONT
CORRIDOR EXPRESS. WELCOME TO
ALL OF YOU. MISTER A CROWD TO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR FRIEDMAN CHEN
BROOM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. HI MY
NAME IS HAS SIGNED A CONTRACT
ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
SANDAG SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS. THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED FOR THE FUTURE OF
TRANSIT. WITH THE LEADERSHIP WE
HAVE IN WASHINGTON DC AND IN IN
SACRAMENTO THE MOMENT TO INVEST
IN OUR JAIL SYSTEM. AND FINALLY
GIVE CALIFORNIA'S THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THEY HAVE
ALWAYS DOES HAVE IS NOW. IN SAN
DIEGO- WE HAVE EMBARKED ON A
MAJOR VISIONING PROCESS
REIMAGINING THE FUTURE OF
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM ASSIGNED
YET. ONE OF THE KEY COMPONENT
TO THIS VISION IS THE CREATION
OF A COMPLETE NETWORK OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL. SERVICES THAT. TO
LAND USE LINKED TO HOUSING
CONNECT ME TO GET ADMIN AREAS
WITHOUT USING DATA IN WAYS THAT
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE TO MAKE
SURE OUR PLANNING. IS DONE THE
RIGHT WAY. BONTA IN THE
BEGINNING THE FUTURE IS WHAT WE
CALL THAT TRANSIT THE- AND THE
JEWEL OF THAT IS THE MOST TIME
COULD HAVE GONE HIGHLIGHTED
THAT READ HERE. THE LAW
SANCTITY DOLLAR. IS THE
BACKBONE TO THE REGIONAL PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. THE
NATION'S SECOND BUSIEST RAIL
CORRIDOR IT WAS MORE THAN EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE AND ONE BILLION
WORTH OF GOODS EVERY YEAR. WE
BELIEVE LOSS ON COULD BE A
FEEDER FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM. N. AS MR CALLINAN AND I
APPRECIATE HIS PRESENTATION.
NOT WHEN WE WHEN I WAS- WITH
SKAGGS WE SIGNED AND MORE
YOU'LL SPECIFICALLY TO LOOK AT
THE POPULATION CENTERS IN THE
STATE THE LINCOLN TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL. THAT WAS THEN AND I STILL
BELIEVE TODAY. ONE GOAL SHOULD
BE LINKING THE POPULATION
CENTERS FROM SAN LEANDRO
THROUGH LA TO SAN FRANCISCO I
BELIEVE- AND INVESTMENT IN THE
LOSS AND K. DOLLAR WILL REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
MAKE IT CONVENIENT AND BETTER
THAN DRIVING ON THE I. FIVE. TO
GET THE REGION GREATLY WE HAVE
INVESTED THE BILLION DOLLAR
THIS CANADA. AND WE HAVE ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF PROJECTS THAT
ARE SHOVEL READY TODAY. YOU
PROBABLY HEAR. THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS THE LAST WEEKEND IS- THE
SEA WALL COLLAPSE OF THE PAGE
ANOTHER ADVIL MARC LEVINE-
FAILURE. WE HAVE THE FUNDING TO
TEMPORARILY STABILIZE IT BUT WE
NEED TO KNOW MORE REMOTEAPP. SO
MY AGENT TODAY TO ACCOMPLISH
THE GOALS OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL LINE LINKING THE
TRANSPORTATION CENTERS FROM SAN
GENERAL ALL THE WAY TO SAN
FRANCISCO. AND LINKING IT TO
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION MY
HOPE IS PART OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL- PROGRAM WHICH WE SUPPORT
IS DOING THIS IN THESE BOOK
ENDS SO BY THE TIME THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. CONSTRUCTION IS
COMPLETE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WE HAVE A CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE BOOKENDS IN CALIFORNIA. ONE
OF THE PRIMARY. ELEMENT OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND IN
THE BEGINNING BUT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS AND YET
WAS WHAT WE CALLED MOBILITY
HELP THIS IS WHAT LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION INTERSECT THIS
IS WHAT WE NEED TO BE SMART
ABOUT WHERE WE PUT FUTURE
HOUSING AND FUTURE GROWTH. AND
FOR THAT REASON INVESTMENT IN
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS IMPORTANT
THAT ONE EXAMPLE ISWHAT WE'RE
DOING IN SAN DIEGO FOR THE SINS
FROM ABILITY HELP WHICH WE
WOULD HOPE BECOMES ONE MAJOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL STATION IN SAN
DIEGO- CHAIR FRIEDMAN CHAIR
BLOOM THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I'LL- BE AROUND
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT I GUESS
WHEN I. I LIKE THE FACT THAT
WITH THESE INVESTMENTS WE WOULD
ACHIEVE THE SOCIAL EQUITY GOALS
FOR CALIFORNIANS BY INCREASING
THEIR ACCESS. TO HIGH QUALITY.
HIGH SPEED RAIL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY. NEXT WE
HAVE THE MS WILLIAMS. GOOD
MORNING CHAPEL MANAGED CARE FOR
WON'T WORK BECAUSE OF THE
ASSEMBLY CHANCE COMMITTEE AND
BY STUFF. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO APPEAR BEFORE
TODAY AND STUFF AND WITH OF
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL RAIL. ALSO
KNOWN AS MUCH. WE'VE BEEN AND I
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS.
PEOPLE IN THE SOUTHERN CAL.
REGION HOW. JOB HEALTHCARE
EDUCATION AND LEISURE TRAVEL
DESTINATIONS WELL THE THIRD
LARGEST REGIONAL RAIL OPERATOR
IN THE COUNTRY AND THE LARGEST
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE A
POPULATION OF MORE THAN SIXTEEN
MILLION LIVING WITHIN THE- AREA
OF OUR SYSTEM. IT FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN WITH FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS NINE MILLION
BOARDINGS THE MOBILE NINE POINT
THREE BILLION A CAR TRIP FROM
OUR CONGESTED ROADS AND
REDUCING A HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND METRIC. TONS OF G. H.
G. THE OF REGIONAL PASSENGER
RAIL HAS. SLOWLY IMPORTANT.
TOMORROW MARKS ONE YEAR FROM
THE DATE THE W. H. O. DECLARED
NINETEEN THE GLOBAL HEALTH
EMERGENCY. AND SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE STATE HOME
ORDERS THAT FOLLOWED WE HAVE
BEEN AN ESSENTIAL SERVICE.
HEALTHY SOCIAL WORKERS CONTINUE
TO GET TO WORK DURING THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC. AND WE
HAVE MANAGED TO KEEP OUR
PROJECTS ON TIME DURING THIS
PERIOD. WE ARE CURRENTLY
DELIVERING ON ABOUT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN MOSTLY STATE LOCAL
INVESTMENT OR TEN BILLION
DOLLAR STOCKTON CALIFORNIA
OPTIMIZED RAIL EXPANSION
PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS SCORE. IN
FACT WE EXPECT IN FINALLY CLEAR
SEVEN GEN AND START FINAL
DESIGN ON NINE PROJECTS BY THE
END OF THIS MONTH. ALSO WE WILL
HOLD GROUNDBREAKING ALL FIVE X.
THIS YEAR IN BURBANK ANAHEIM
SACRAMENTO CA AND CHESTNUT. THE
BY THE MINISTRY BILL BACK
BETTER ON INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE.
TO THAT FOR THINKING STATE
INVEST. AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
COMMITMENTS FROM THE STATE TO
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
SUPPORT SECOND FULLY FUNDS FOR
AND MAGNIFY THE BENEFITS OF THE
STATE DOLLARS. ALSO WE'RE
EXCITED THAT BRIGHTLINE WEST IS
LOOKING TO INVEST PRIVATE
DOLLARS FOR HIGH SPEED
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN NATURALLY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND LAS
VEGAS. THE STORE PROGRAM GIVES
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY
BECOME A WORLD CLASS SERVICE
THAT BENEFITS MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE BUT TO ALSO CREATE
LASTING GENERATIONAL IMPACTS
BUT THE MOST POPULOUS REGION OF
THE STATE. WE ALSO SERVE AS A
SPONSOR AND AS AN EXTENSION OF
THE BACKBONE FOR THE STATE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICE WHEN IT'S
READY TO COME TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ADDING TO OUR LOS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION SCORE WILL CREATE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THIRTEEN
THOUSAND HIGH PAYING
CONSTRUCTION JOBS YOU FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT GAMES. AND
MORE OVER THE L. EDC PROJECTS
THAT SCORE WILL ELIMINATE THREE
POINT FOUR BILLION THE EMPTY AT
FIFTY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
METRIC TONNES OF GHG. WHEN I
LAST APPEARED BEFORE YOU 52% OF
OUR FLEET HAD TIER FOUR
LOCOMOTIVES IN SERVICE WHICH
REDUCE EMISSIONS BY UP 285%
FROM THE EQUIPMENT THEY
REPLACE. TODAY 71% YOUR FOR
WHAT THE LAST LOCOMOTIVE
EXPECTED BY JUNE WE'RE OFF BUT
DANCING EIGHT ZERO FOSSEL
YOU'LL USE YOUR- BY PILOTING
RENEWABLE DIESEL TODAY AND
ADVANCING OUR CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN. THE FIRST OF ITS KIND FOR
AGENCIES. OF VISION TO
ACCELERATE OF THE OMISSIONS
FUTURE THAT OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WILL CONSIDER LATER
THIS MONTH. WE ARE READY TO ACT
NOW FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR
LOCAL AND STATE FINANCE
ECONOMIC AND POLITICAL. MEASURE
LIKE IT'S NOT ONLY SHOVEL READY
BUT ALSO SOME WORRY. HAVING THE
ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFITS OF THE PUBLIC DOLLARS
TODAY WELL WHO ARE MADE A
REGION AS WELL AS FOR THE STATE
HIGH SPEED RAIL WHEN THEY'RE
READY. THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR.
BEFORE YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND OUR FINAL SPEAKER STACEY
MORTENSEN. STACEY HAS TO SHARE
HER OWN SALON- SO WE WILL GET
THAT GOING. WELL THE STEAM
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY OUR DAILY RADIO
PROGRAM IS ON THE MOVE. AND IT
IS A COMBINATION OF BOTH ACE
AND SAN JOAQUIN AMTRAK SERVICE
SHOWN ON THE MAP THERE HEADING
NORTH OUT OF MERCED IN THE
GREEN AND PURPLE LINE'S TAKES
US OFF TO OAKLAND SAN JOSE AND
THAT NO THOMAS AREA WHICH IS
JUST TO STONE THROWS FROM THAT
SACRAMENTO AIRPORT. IF THE
STATE WIDE MAPPING HERE SO YOU
CAN SEE OUR RELATIONSHIP TO
EVERYONE ELSE LOW SAND CAPITOL
CORRIDOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
SEGMENT. THE VICTORVILLE THE
BIGGEST SIGN BUT ALSO THE
DASHED LINES SHOW YOU A FAR
REACHING THROUGH A VAST
NETWORK. THERE ARE USED BY
NEARLY HALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
WRITERS VERY IMPORTANT TO
CONNECT PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
OTHER OPTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. MORE IMPORTANTLY THOUGH
THIS IS A BLOW UP YOU FOR THAT
PASSENGER THIS NEW NETWORK
CONNECTS THEM TO CALTRAIN VTA.
BART CAPITOL CORRIDOR FUTURE
VALLEY LINK SERVICE. HIGH SPEED
RAIL SEGMENT SACRAMENTO
AIRPORT- IN A VERY INTEGRATED
WAY IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHERE MUCH MORE CONNECTED THAN
WE KNOW. BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE
ROOM WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE THIS
CONNECTED NETWORK SEEM LESS FOR
THE TRAVELER. RIGHT NOW THE SAN
JOAQUIN TRAINS DO RUN FROM
BAKERSFIELD BUT THAT WILL GIVE
WAY IN THE FUTURE TO THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICE IN OUR
PORTION WILL FOCUS ON THIS
NETWORK YOU SEE HERE. IT'S A
COMBINED PROGRAM FOR ASYNCIO MY
CANS AND IN HAND WE HAVE ABOUT
ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN A MAJOR BOOST TO
THE SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM IS
RIGHT IN THE CENTER OF THE MAP
AT THE STOCKTON STATION WHERE
THE- GREEN AND PURPLE ALL COME
TOGETHER. THIS IS SIMILAR TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S COLTON
CROSSING A HUGE BOTTLENECK
WHERE BNSF AND UNION PACIFIC
CROSSEY VERY DIFFICULT PROJECT
TO GIVE ALL THE PLAYERS. AT THE
TABLE VERY DIFFICULT PROJECT TO
GET FUNDED BUT THROUGH A GOOD
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
RAILROADS THE STATE LOCAL
AGENCIES AND THE FEDERAL BILL
GRAHAM. WE HAVE THAT PROJECT
UNDER WAY AND LOOKING TO
CONSTRUCTION IN THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS THIS UNLOCKS IN STOCKTON.
CONSTRAINTS THAT HAVE PLAGUED
THE RAILROADS THE COMMUNITY AND
THE PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE FOR
DECADES. AND WE'VE EXPERIENCED
VERY GOOD COOPERATION FROM THE
FREIGHT RAILROADS. WE'VE
DEVELOPED AGREEMENTS WITH THEM
COLLABORATIVELY THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO PHASE IN THE PROJECTS YOU
SEE HERE IN ABOUT FOUR WAVES
THE FIRST THREE WILL BE
HAPPENING FROM. IN CONSTRUCTION
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. AND EACH OF THE
SECTIONS ALL JUST BRIEFLY TALK
ABOUT THEY THEY PRETTY MUCH
HAVE DOUBLE TRACK SECTIONS
CITING BRIDGE WIDENING. AND
THEN STATIONS AND LYFT LAYOVER
FACILITIES- DEPENDING ON THEIR
PARTICULAR LOCATION. OUR WAY
EVERYONE IS REALLY GOING SOUTH
FROM THE EXISTING ACE TRUNKLINE
IN THE LATER BAY AREA RIGHT
WHERE THAT LITTLE- SORT OF
UPSIDE DOWN TRIANGLE COMES
TOGETHER. WEEKS IN TWENTY FIVE
MILES SOUTH. OR WAVE TO AND
WE'RE GOING TO PIGGY BACK THAT
ONE RIGHT ON WAVE ONE WILL
EXTEND US NORTH FROM STOCKTON
ABOUT FIFTY SEVEN MILES. UP
TOWARDS THE SACRAMENTO AIRPORT.
AND THEN ARE WE THREE HEADS
BACK TO THE- AND TAKES US FOR
THE CERES STATION ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO MERCED NOW THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL SERVICE WITH A
LITTLE BIT MORE LIMITED TRAINS.
BUT WAIT FOR COMPLETE ALL THE
STATIONS ALTHOUGH CIRCLES YOU
SEE ON THE MAP IN THE GREEN AND
THE PURPLE. IN ADDITION TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDING NEEDED
TO GET US TO SIX TRAINS DIVERS
AT THAT WAS OUR PLAN. FOR
REALLY DECADES IT BECOME BECAME
MORE IMPORTANT AND IN FOCUS
FROM THE SCHEDULE STANDPOINT AS
HIGH SPEED RAIL. GETS MORE
CLEAR ABOUT THEIR SCHEDULE I
THINK MORE IMPORTANTLY IT THAT
OUR PLAN IS HOW ARE WE
PROGRESSING ON THE PROGRAM. SO
WE GET A PLEA ONE RAILCARS SIX
LOCOMOTIVES PRODUCTION FOR THIS
EXPANSION. IN A WAVE ONE
PROJECT IN THE DESIGN AND
ENGINEERING PROCESS IN ABOUT
ONE YEAR FROM NOW WE INTEND TO
BE IN CONSTRUCTION. WITH NEW
SERVICE ON THAT ROUTE BY MID TO
LATE TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO
REALLY BEFORE WE KNOW IT. WE
WILL HAVE TRAINS RUNNING ON
THOSE- SECTIONS WAIT TO SAME
THING BIG BASS OF THE-
CONTRACTS ARE TO BID NOW FOR
FINALLY. AND WE EXPECT
CONSTRUCTION TO BE ABOUT SIX
MONTHS FOLLOWING THE WAVE ONE
WITH NEW SERVICE AND LIKE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND THEN
OUR FINAL EXPANSION TO MERCED
CLOSER STOCKTON DIAMOND THOSE
OF THE TWO BIGGER SEGMENTS OF
THEPROGRAM. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEARANCE WILL BE IN THE FALL
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE DO OF
ALL THE INITIAL AGREEMENTS WITH
THE RAILROADS WHICH IS THE
BIGGEST LEFT. SO NOW WE CAN
JUST FOCUS ON THE ENGINEERING
AND THE CONSTRUCTION WHICH
WOULD BEGIN IN LATE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SO I JUST WANT TO
GIVE YOU A HIGHLIGHT OF THE OF
PIECES OF WORK UNDER WAY THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT IN THIS
NORTHERN CONNECTION TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN MERCED AND I
THINK YOU FOR THE TIME TO SHARE
OUR PROGRAM. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO ALL OF OUR
SPEAKERS THAT WAS KIND OF A
LIGHTNING ROUND- TRANSPORTATION
A VISION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND TO- TO THINK
THAT- OF THESE PROJECTS COULD
BECOME A REALITY SOME DAYS
SAID- TRULY AMAZING AND- AND-
THAT THE KIND OF THINGS THAT
WILL. REALLY- WHO'S CALIFORNIA.
DECADES TO COME. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR OUR ESTEEMED
PANELISTS BEGINNING- CHAIR
FRIEDMAN I HAVE JUST ACTUALLY
THREE QUESTIONS SO I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAVE OTHERS WILL FIND
OUT WE HAVE ABOUT FORTY
MINUTES- FOR QUESTIONS AND TO-
WERE KIND OF A- LIGHT IN THE
ROOM RIGHT NOW SO WHY DON'T YOU
ASK- ALL THREE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS AND WE'LL SEE. WE'LL
DO OUR BEST TO FIT EVERY
EVERYBODY THANK YOU THE FIRST
SEASON AS HE SAID IT'S REALLY
EXCITING AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL NEED TO
REALLY WORK FOR IS GETTING
THESE PROJECTS BUILT BECAUSE
HUGE HUGE JUST FOR DIFFERENCE
EVERYBODY'S LIVES CALIFORNIA. A
FIRST FOR MS WIGGINS ARMS I AM
WONDERING- LET'S ASSUME THAT
HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL HOPEFULLY
EVENTUALLY COME DOWN AT LEAST
TO THE BURBANK AIRPORT IF NOT
BEYOND. WHAT IMPROVEMENTS CAN
WE MAKE TO THE METROLINK WHAT
IMPROVEMENTS YOU NEED TO MAKE
TO THE METROLINK TRACKS TO
ALLOW THAT AND WHAT WHAT.
BENEFITS WOULD THAT GIVE YOU.
EVEN WITHOUT THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL. IN OTHER WORDS I KNOW WE
HAVE TO DO IT BUT BUT DOES
DOING IT HEALTHCARE OPERATIONS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR
ACTUALLY MADAM CHAIR SO AS A
BOOKEND IDENTIFIED OPERATOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL- I WANT TO
FOCUS ON OUR BURBANK TO ANAHEIM
CORRIDOR WHERE THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS THAT
COULD BE MADE TODAY THAT-
BENEFITS ARE MAKING REGION AS
WELL AS THE STATE OF. BECAUSE
OF OUR UNIQUE GEOGRAPHY OUR
ABILITY TO- IMPROVE AIRPORT
CONNECTIVITY BURBANK AIRPORT AS
WELL AS START TRANSIT
PARTNERSHIPS IN THE REGION PART
OF THE RGION WHETHER IT'S
SPORTS COUNTY AS WELL AS L. A.
METRO- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST AND GENERATE ADDITIONAL
RIDERSHIP IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS AND BUILD SOME. OF THE
EARLY IN THAT. RAIL WAY IT'S-
WHEN IT ALTMAN GETS HERE SO WE
MIGHT. RENO TO FIVE BILLION
THAT'S IT NEEDED BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WITHIN THE QUARTER
IT WOULD BE GREAT MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
JOBS. AS WELL AS- THIRTY THREE
OF THE PROJECTS THAT COMPRISE.
ONE DOLLAR NEED- TOTAL HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE BILLION AND THOSE
ARE SHOVEL READY TODAY WHICH
GOOD GREAT EIGHTY SEVEN HUNDRED
JOBS IN THE OR THE TYPES OF
IMPROVEMENTS TRACK A PATH
STATION. GREAT CROSSING
IMPROVEMENTS RIGHT SEPARATION
IMPROVEMENT OF COURSE SOME OF
THE ROLLING STOCK. THANK YOU-
AND NOW FOR- IS- MORTENSEN- MY
QUESTION FOR YOU I HAVE A
SIMILAR QUESTION WHICH IS-
BERMAN. YOUR. ABOUT BOOZ
INVESTMENTS IN THE A SYSTEM
THAT YOU WILL NEED TO CONNECTED
TO HIGH SPEED RAIL TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT WHAT
INVESTMENTS I KNOW YOU DID TALK
A LITTLE ABOUT THIS I WONDER IF
YOU COULD JUST ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT INVESTMENTS
YOU NEED TO CONNECT AND WE'RE
AT THIS POINT HE BELIEVE THE
FUNDING IS GOING TO COME FROM.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE ONE POINT THREE BILLION
OUT OF ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN
ONE POINT EIGHT. MILLION DATED
WE DON'T HAVE A FULL ESTIMATE.
UP WE KNOW HOW TO GET AS TO THE
MERCED STATION. DEPENDING ON
WHETHER IT WILL BE A GREAT
WEATHER WILL BE ELEVATING THAT
WILL MATTER ON THIS LAST LITTLE
SEGMENT HOW WE TIE INTO IT.
THEN ADDITIONALLY THE SAN
JOAQUIN'S NEED TO CONNECT FROM
THEIR SEPARATE LINE ON THE BNSF
ABOUT A MILE AND A HALF. HEART
WE WILL NEED TO CLOSE THAT GAP
HOLD THE- SAN JOAQUIN TRAINS
INTO THAT NEW JOINT HUB IN
MERCED. AND SO AGAIN WE CAN
HAVE ESTIMATES IT'S PROBABLY
CLOSE TO A COUPLE BILLION
DOLLARS IF IT'S ELEVATED. AND
THEN MUCH LESS SO IF IT'S A
GREAT SO WE'REWE'RE IN A BIT
OF A WAIT AND SEE PATTERN UNTIL
WE- CAN GET SOME OPTIONS FOR
ALL OF THE ENGINEERING. THAT
MEETS THE MERCED STATION THAT'S
ULTIMATELY BUILT AND WHAT IS
THE TIMETABLE FOR THAT WHAT IS
SORT OF YOU'RE ASSUMING YOU
HAVE THE FUNDING. WHEN COULD
THAT BE BUILT BECAUSE THEY'RE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS REALLY DEPEND
ON BEING ABLE TO CONNECT TO
YOUR SYSTEM. AS WELL. WHAT WE
WOULD HOPE TO PIGGYBACK THAT ON
THE WORK THAT'S GOING ON THAT
THAT WAY BEFORE. THAT WILL BE
UNDER WAY IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE IN TERMS OF ITS FINAL
DESIGN. AND SO WITH THAT
THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME TO HELP
THAT CONSTRUCTED. BY THE TIME
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL IS OUT
MERCED. SO WHAT ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING IF YOU'RE GONNA
THROW A YEAR OUT FOR EVERYTHING
BEING DONE TRAINS RUNNING
PEOPLE ABLE TO GO FROM
BAKERSFIELD AND GO INTO YOUR
SYSTEM TO GO TO THE BAY AREA.
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE DONE THERE
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. AND THAT
ALLOWS FOR ANY LAST MINUTE
CHANGES THAT MIGHT HAPPEN WITH
MERCED AT AS PART OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TERMINUS BUT LACKS
AS HAVE THE BULK OF. OF THE
APPROACH RIGHT WE GET RIGHT TO
THE APPROACH THE LAST- TANGENT
POINT BEFORE WE HAVE TO MOVE
OFF TO MEET THAT MERCED
CONNECTION SO I DON'T SEE ANY
PROBLEM WITH TWENTY TWENTY SIX
TO TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. I KNOW
MY STEP THAT SHOOTING FOR
TWENTY TWENTY SIX BUT THERE ARE
SOME EXTERNAL THINGS BEYOND OUR
CONTROL. THANKS AND LAST
QUESTION HIGH SPEED RAILS
PROPOSINGTO LEASE THE INTER
REAL SERVICE TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY. AND THE
ALTAMONT CORRIDOR EXPRESS HOW
WOULD THIS WORK. SO IT WOULD
WORK MUCH LIKE WE'VE LEAST
TRACK FROM THE FREIGHT
RAILROADS TODAY. WE LEAVE TRACK
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN WITH THE
BNSF LEAST TRACK FROM THE UNION
PACIFIC FOR THE A STRAINS AND
WE NEGOTIATE A AN AGREED UPON
LEASE PRICE FOR THE USE OF THE
SYSTEM THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
SYSTEM SOME CAPITAL
REPLENISHMENT OF THE SYSTEM.
AND SO OUR NATIONAL DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY HAVE BASICALLY FOLLOW
THAT THAT RECIPE. WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE ATO'S
ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW OF WHAT
THOSE COSTS WILL BE. AND AS
THEY GO AND SO WE ARE IN
DISCUSSION WITH THE AUTHORITY
IN THE ETL AS AS MORE
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE AND
ESPECIALLY AS THE- THE
EQUIPMENT DECISIONS ARE MADE
ABOUT THE- YEAH THERE ARE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF EQUIPMENT
THAT HAVE DIFFERENT MAINTENANCE
COSTS DIFFERENT SPEAKS ETCETERA
SO. BE PRECISE EQUIPMENT WILL
MATTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
HAS A QUESTIONS. GREAT OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION HERE TODAY AND- MR
CHRONOSPHERE LEADERSHIP DOWN
HERE IN SAN DIEGO DEEPLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THE VISIONARY WORK THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO RE IMAGINING
THE NETWORKS- I WONDERED IF YOU
COULD ELABORATE AND EXPAND A
LITTLE BIT ON ON THE- ESSENTIAL
NEED THAT WE HAVE AROUND THE
TOWN MORE PLUS- ON THE
DIFFERENT- THE TIME LINES AND
INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO- SECURE A BETTER
ALIGNMENT AND THROUGH THE AREA
AND I KNOW THERE'S OTHER.
DOUBLE TRACKING ISSUES ALONG
OUR COASTLINE AS WELL WHAT
WOULD THE TIMELINE RESOURCES
LOOK LIKE TO REALLY FULLY
REALIZED- A- RELIABLE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM THROUGH THE
SAN DIEGO REGION. THANK YOU US
MEMBER WATER THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND- JUST BRIEFLY. AND
AS I INDICATED MY PRESENTATION.
THE LOSS AND CANADA IS THE
SECOND BUSIEST IN THE COUNTRY.
EIGHT MILLION PASSENGERS A
YEAR. A LOT OF FREIGHT
MOVEMENT. THAT CARRIED OVER HAS
SEVERAL CHALLENGES AND ONE OF
THEM EIGHT WELL ONE POINT SEVEN
MILEAGES ON THE BLUFF. IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS WE EXPERIENCED
IN THE ROUGH COLLAPSES THAT WE
HAVE TO IMMEDIATELY PAY
ATTENTION TO. EVENTUALLY THAT
LIFE HAS TO MOVE A LOT. NOT IN
THAT CATEGORY HE ALSO TO BE
STATE AND THEN THE MINIMUM CARE.
YEAH WE BELIEVE IF WE DO THESE
IMPROVEMENTS THIS CABLE CAN GO
TO ONE HUNDRED TEN MILES PER
HOUR SO I KEPT FROM SENTIMENTAL
TO LOS ANGELES UNION STATION
WHEN NOT TAKE THREE AND A HALF
HOURS BUT WILL TAKE LESS THAN
TWO HOURS. AND THAT IS BUT THEN
THEN THEDRIVING ON THE I.
FIVE. THAT WE HADN'T INVESTED
ABOUT THE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS CASE WE HAVE ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
SHOVEL READY PROJECT TO BE
INVESTED. AND WE HOPE FOR A
FEDERAL STATE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND TO
THE GENTLEMAN'S QUESTION IS
WHEN CAN WE DO IT. IF WE HAVE
THE MONEY WE CAN STOCK RIGHT
NOW. AN IMPROVING THIS
CHARACTER THAT'S NATIONALLY AND
STATE WIDE THEN REGIONALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND I BELIEVE IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL WHEN IT'S BUILT IN THE
FUTURE YOU CAN NOT HAVE A HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM THAT'S
EFFECTIVE. WITHOUT LINKING. THE
POPULATION CENTERS OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR SO. THANK THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM AS MEMBER LENA. THANK.
THANK YOU SEE SHARE I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE ALSO
CHAIR FRIEDMAN QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW ACE WILL BE CONNECTED AND
BENEFITING TO THE BAY AREA AND
OF COURSE HIGH SPEED RAIL I
JUST WANNA DANCE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR MORTENSEN THAT IF DO
YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OR METRICS
ABOUT HOW THIS CONNECTION
BETWEEN THIS IMPROVEMENT OF THE
CORRIDOR- WILL IMPACT THE
GREATER ECONOMY OF THE BAY AREA
I REPRESENT THE REAR FOR OF THE
STATIONS ON THE LINE AND KERRY
SAID. ABOUT IF THERE'S ANY DATA
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THE IMPACT
ON THE BEARS ECONOMY. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION ALL OF THE
STUDIES THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGH THE BARE AREAS ECONOMIC
GROUPS. REALLY POINTED TO THE
FACT THAT ACCESS TO ECONOMIC
CENTERS NO MATTER WHERE YOU
ARE. IN THE VALLEY OR IN THE
SUBURBS IS CRITICAL TO THE
OVERALL ECONOMY. AND AS WE ALL
KNOW THERE'S MEGA REGIONS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND RAIL
IS REALLY SHOWN TO BE ONE OF
THEM. THE KEYSTONE ELEMENTS TO
MAKE THAT SUCCESSFUL ALLOWING
FOR SATELLITE OFFICES AND
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO TRAVEL
BACK AND FORTH. I WILL KNOW I
HAVE TO SAY SHAMELESSLY I
COPIED. STEPHANIE WIGGINS OUT
REACH TO HER PASSENGERS BECAUSE
AS NON WRITERS WE CAN ASK
OURSELVES WILL PEOPLE COME BACK
TO THE TRAINS. AND I THINK YOU
KNOW AROUND THE DINNER TABLE
YOU CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WHERE YOU THINK KNOW THAT
PROBABLY WON'T. BUT WHEN YOU
ASK THE PASSENGERS THEMSELVES.
AS A METROLINK GET IN AS WE
HAVE DONE THE PASSENGERS REALLY
DO WANT TO COME BACK AND THEY
EXPRESS. AN INTENT TO COME BACK
EVEN IF THEY ARE GRANTED- MORE
TIME TO WORK FROM HOME SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY WE SEE THAT.
THE OF THE RIVER RECOVERY FROM
CO THAT. AS A POSITIVE ASPECT
OF OUR PROGRAM OVER A COURSE OF
IT A COUPLE YEARS. AND THEN THE
ECONOMIC BENEFIT IS CLEAR THAT
THE MORE BROADLY WE CAN CONNECT
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH NO
OPTIONS. THE MORE WE RAISE. THE
WHOLE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. THERE
APPEAR TO BE NO MORE QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS AND SO- I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS FOR
YOUR EXCELLENT AND CONCISE.
PRESENTATIONS AND WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND FOR THAT I WILL
TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO MY- CO
CHAIR. MS FRIEDMAN THANKS TO
HAVE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANYONE SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
DOING PHONE. OUR TESTIMONY- THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND IT
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS SO
EVERYONE GET YOUR PENS THE
NUMBER IS AND THIS IS A TOLL
FREE NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. AT. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS CODE. TWO
WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT THE
TESTIMONY TWO ONE MINUTE WHAT I
SUGGEST IS YOU STATE YOUR NAME
IF YOU'RE WITH ANY AFFILIATED
ORGANIZATION. AND ANY COMMENTS
YOU WANT TO MAKE. UP OPERATOR
YOU MAY BEGIN. BAKER AS
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU DO HAVE COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE- AND
EDUCATION BEEN PLACED IN Q. AND
EIGHTEEN TO SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER. WE WILL NOT YOUR LINE
NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY TO
SPEAK. AS MADAM CHAIRMAN SAID
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD BALL BY YOUR COMMENT. IF
YOU'RE ON A SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP YOUR HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING ANY BUTTONS IN
ADDITION MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE-
IF YOU'RE WATCHING BY WAY OF
ZOOM MAKE SURE YOUR DEVICE. FOR
THE ZOOM IS ON MUTE. YES MUTED
RATHER. WE WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. BY THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BRIAN MCCAULEY THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY
AFFAIRS SPECIALIST I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALTRAIN IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORITIES WERE BY
TWENTY TWENTY DRAFT BUSINESS
PLAN. CALTRAIN AND THE SEVENTH
LARGEST COMMUTER RAIL SYSTEM IN
THE COUNTRY CONNECTING SILICON
VALLEY IN SAN FRANCISCO PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC ARE AVERAGE
RIDERSHIP WITH OVER SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND PASSENGERS PER
WEEKDAY. INITIATING ELECTRIC
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AT PROPOSED IN THE PLAN
WILL ENSURE THAT THE PROJECT IS
DELIVERED AS QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE THE
STORY WILL BE A FUTURE OPERATOR
ON THE CALTRAIN OWN CORRIDOR
INDIGNANT CORDON PARTNER IN THE
FUNDING AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
OUR ON GOING ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT. FINISHING THE SEGMENT
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
BEGINNING AN INTERIM OPERATION
WILL ALLOW THE TECHNOLOGY TO BE
DAMAGE TO BE DEMONSTRATED AS WE
WORKED WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
UPGRADE OUR OWN CORRIDOR TO
COMEDY INCREASED REGIONAL
TRAVEL AND PREPARE FOR THE
INTRODUCTION OF HIGHER SPEED
SERVICE. RECENTLY CALTRAIN
ADOPTED A LONG RANGE SERVICE
STATION WHICH OUTLINED OUR
SYSTEM APPARITIONS TO GROW
WHILE REAFFIRMING OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE BLENDED
PICKED THEM OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR SHARED FUTURE WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL WE ARE IN AGREEMENT
WITH THE PATH PROPOSED BY THE
AUTHORITIES REVISED BUSINESS
PLAN WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
IMPLEMENT PLANNING WORK THAT
MUST BE MARKED ON BETWEEN
CALTRAIN AND THE STORY AND
WORKING TOWARD MAKING THAT
VISION A REALITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WILL BE LINE FOR. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARES
FRIEDMAN BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF
THE RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES THIS
IS ON THE US ARMY DOES ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANSBAY JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY WHICH OVERSEES
THE OPERATIONS OF THE MULTI
MODAL SALESFORCE TRANSIT CENTER
IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO HERE
TO SUPPORT- THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL FORTY TWENTY TWENTY
DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN. IN
ADDITION TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEARANCE AND COMPLETION OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PORTION OF THE
PROJECT WHICH WE SUPPORT AND-
THE DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN SETS
FORWARD A PATH TO GET
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED TRAINS
RUNNING AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
WHILE CONTINUING TO ADVANCE THE
ENTIRE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO LOS
ANGELES BASIN. SUCH WE'RE INTO
THE OPTIC ABOUT THE EMPHASIS ON
ADVANCING CONSTRUCTION ON THE
BOOK AND PROJECTS IN THE BAY
AREA AND LOS ANGELES OF WHICH
THE TRANSIT CENTER WOULD BE THE
NORTHERN TERMINUS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. FIFTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING HERE
FREEMAN SHARE BLOOMING
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
LAURA TOOK UP TRANSPORTATION
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR BURKE
THROUGH RESEARCH EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY FOR WORKERS TO MAKE
THE BAY AREA AND EQUITABLE
SUSTAINABLE AND PROSPEROUS
REGION WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
WITHIN COMMENTING ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL FOR MORE THAN A DECADE AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE REVISED
BUSINESS PLAN AND ENCOURAGE THE
STATE TO CONTINUE. TO RELEASE
THE REMAINDER OF PROP ONE
EIGHTY FUNDS FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND COMPLETE THE ENTIRE
CASE ONE OF THE PROJECT THIS IS
A PROMISING TIME FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND SUPPORT ADVANCING THE
PROJECT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK. YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINES. TWO HELLO MY NAME IS
DIRECTLY ALIGNED WITH THE
CARPENTERS UNION LOCAL FOUR OH
FIVE IN SANTA FE AND THAT
REPRESENTING SANTA CLARA AND
SAN BENITO COUNTY AND WE STND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
AND THEIR STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CONTINUATION OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJET THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
THIRTY NINE. HELLO YOUR HONOR
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THANK YOU
MY NAME IS YOUR BUDGET SOME OF
THE CARPENTERS UNION SAN
FRANCISCO AND I JUST WANT IT-
EIGHT THREE MUCH WHAT EVERYBODY
HAS SAID WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE. SIXTY GOOD MORNING NOT
THE GAMES THAT ARE NATIONAL
UNION OF OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL NUMBER TWELVE WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS OF THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND WE WHAT
MAYOR STRONGLY SUPPORTING THE
COMPLETION OF THE FIRST PHASE
OF THIS HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. PINE. SIXTY FOUR. HELLO
MY NAME IS RICARDO SHAME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL ALLIANCE WE'RE A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION WORKING
FOR FAST FREQUENT DEPENDABLE
TRAINS OF MANY DIFFERENT KINDS
OF LINKING ENTIRE REGIONS- WE
HAVE NEARLY A HUNDRED MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE
RECENTLY- SUBMITTED A PETITION
TO YOU- SIGNED BY- SEVEN
HUNDRED ELEVEN CALIFORNIANS
ASKING YOU TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE PLAN AS PROPOSED BY THE
AUTHORITY. IN YOUR POSITION AS
THE LEADER IN GREEN
TRANSPORTATION- FOR MANY
DECADES- BY COMMITTING TO THIS
PROJECT YOU CAN HELP ENSURE
THAT CONGRESS DOES IN FACT TO
CONTINUE TO FUND THESE- MENU
COMPLETE STRONG LEADERSHIP ROLE
IN. BRINGING HIGH SPEED RAIL TO
THE COUNTRY AND SO WE URGE YOU
TO CONTINUE FORWARD WITH
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S. PROPOSED DISPLAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
NEXT QUESTION PLEASE OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S AUGGIE BELL
CHAN ON THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL REPRESENTING THE FORTY
SIX NORTHERN COUNTY EAST WE
STRATEGY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S REVISED BUSINESS
PLAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BY. FIFTY EIGHT.
MORNING MY NAME IS SEAN BEAN
KALE AND I'M WITH RAIL
PASSENGERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE'RE CALLING IN TODAY TO
ENDORSE THE AUTHORITIES REVISED
BUSINESS PLAN NOT JUST ON
BEHALF OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OFF OF
THIRTY MILLION PLUS AMERICANS-
CURRENTLY USING IN EACH CITY
RAIL NETWORK COMMITMENT
CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP PERSON
AND WITH THIS PROJECT OVER THE
PAST DECADE IN THE ABSENCE OF
MEANINGFUL FEDERAL SUPPORT THE
A LACK OF PREDICTABLE MEDICAID
FUNDING HAS RESULTED IN DELAYED
RECALL BUT THE ABILITY OF THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA ADVANTAGE
PROJECT WILL HAVE A MEANINGFUL
IMPACT ON THE SHAPE OF THE
FINAL CONSTRUCTION BILL THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING DEVELOPED-
WASHINGTON YEP GOT IT ALL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA WILL BE
EXTREMELY WELL POSITIONED TO
BENEFIT FROM THE GROWTH FEDERAL
FUNDING PROGRAM-THAT IT HAD
KEPT ALIVE FOURTH THROUGH
EIGHTH LOCAL INVESTMENTS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY I AM
ALSO WORKING GROUP'S OTHER MAIN
VOTER APPROVED BONDS. WITHOUT
PROJECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. FIVE SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MEDINA MY NAME RICK SPA
BECAUSE CAL DISTRICT HELP AWAY-
YEAH OF DROP ZERO AND OUR
THIRTY PLUS MEMBERS YOU CANNOT
SUPPORT OF THE PROP LOGGED ZERO
THANKS FOR THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. AND. FORTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MY NEW TWENTY FOUR
ROBINSON ON THE FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL OF
LABORERS AND WE'RE CALLING
NUTRI JOINT THE STATE BUILDING
PRAISED THE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. IF
YOU WERE MARCH FOR THE- THANKS
SO MUCH FOR CALLING NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TEN TWENTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS STEVE
ROBERTS AND I AM PRESIDENT OF
RALPH TACK THE REAL PASSENGERS
SO SHE XIN OF CALIFORNIA NEVADA
REAL PACK IS AN ALL VOLUNTEER
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND
IN STRONG ADVOCATES OF
COMPREHENSIVE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK I WANTED
TO EMPHASIZE OUR MEMBERS STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE REVISED TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL BUSINESS PLAN. WILL PACK
ALSO RECOMMENDS THE
APPROPRIATION OF THE REMAINING
PROPOSITION ONE A FUNDS TO
REDUCE RISK AND PROVIDE OF
SECURE FINANCE FINANCIAL
FOUNDATION FOR COMPLETION OF
THE COR UNDER NINETEEN MILES
CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT. ALSO
PACK FEELS TO. FOCUS ON
COMPLETING A REALIGNMENT SAID
TO BAKERSFIELD AND MISSIONARY
INITIATING THE INTERIM
AUTHENTIC BELLY OPERATING
PLANT. IS THE BEST STRATEGY
FORWARD IT CREATES A TIRE
CALIFORNIA WIDE- PASSENGER
NETWORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER. LINE. FORTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALAN WHERE WITCHCRAFT ON WATER
DISTRICT WE MANAGE THE
GRAPPLING ECOLOGICAL AREA IN
MERCED COUNTY A CRITICAL
WETLAND HABITAT THAT SUPPORTS
MILLION BUT THE STATE MIGRATORY
BIRDS AND OTHER WILDLIFE WE
HAVE SINCERE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT
ON THE SAN JOSE TO MERCED
ACTIONS THAT WOULD RUN THROUGH
OUR WETLANDS. LAST MONTH THE L.
A. TIMES DOCUMENTED HIGH COST
OVERRUNS DUE TO THE RAIL
AUTHORITY'S FAILURE TO LIVE UP
TO ITS ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITMENT
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO LIMIT ANY
STATE FUNDING AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO ONLY THE NORTH SOUTH
SECTION WHICH CAN CONNECT TO
THE EXISTING TRANSIT ROUTE THAT
SERVES THE BAY AREA AND BEYOND
THE ALTAMONT CORRIDOR ANY STATE
FUNDING FOR THE EAST TO WEST
THE CZECHO PATH THE PROPOSAL
SHOULD COME WITH STRINGS
ATTACHED THAT OBLIGATE THE
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP A
MITIGATION PLAN AND SET ASIDE
FUNDING IN ADVANCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIVE SIX FIVE. HELLO GOOD
MORNING- COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BRIAN THE ENEMY I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT SOUTH OF THE
RAIL PASSENGER ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA OR REAL
PACKED. AND REAL PACKED WITH
JUST LIKE TO REITERATE THAT WE
DO SUPPORT- FUNDING OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THE INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT-
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
AUTHORITY BUSINESS PLAN WE DO
SUPPORT THAT BUSINESS PLAN WE
SUPPORT THE ALLOCATION. OF
PROPOSITION ONE A FUN- TO
COMPLETE THAT WORK. WITHOUT
DELAY- ANY DELAYS AND ON THAT
OR THE TRACKING SYSTEMS-
CONTRACT DID LEAD TO LONGER.
FURTHER DELAY IN THE- OF THE
SLEEVE MORE CAUGHT OVER ON. AND
I ALSO WANT TO REITERATE AT THE
OTHER CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE OF A
MAJOR METROLINK PAGE NOT A
LITTLE PAN CORRIDOR. THAT FUNDS
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY WORK
SHOULD NOT BE HOAXED SO TO
SPEAK THE GO TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PROJECT. I'M A FIRM
SUPPORTER OF THE METROLINX
SCORE PROGRAM. BUT- NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE WORK OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. AND IF
THERE'S ANY FUNDING THAT NEED
TO BE DIVERTED TO RAIL PROJECT
REGIONAL RAIL PROJECT WITHIN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BE
FREEWAYS PROJECT THE WAY TOO
MUCH FREEWAY EXPANSION GOING
ON- INCLUDING DESTROYING A LOT
OF HOMES AND PLACES LIKE DOWNEY
KING ON INTERSTATE FIVE. LOCAL
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR
CALLING- NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIVE TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN WHEN ANYTIME
EVERYTHING YOU REPRESENTED THE
CEMENT MASONS LOCAL SIX HUNDRED
AND BAKERSFIELD WE CAN HAVE
THAT PROJECT I'M GOING NOW IN
ALONG WITH IT THEY DON'T
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT THANKS FOR
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU CHAIR THE
MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES MATT
KREMIN CHAIR ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE HERE
TODAY IN ORDER EXPRESS OUR
STRONG AND CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
THAT TO DATE HAS CREATED
THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INCLUDING MANY
JOBS THAT BELONG TO OPERATING
ENGINEERS GIVEN THE RECENT
CHANGE IN LEADERSHIP THAT WE
HAVE SEEN A CURRENT FEDERAL-
LEVEL IN JANUARY AND GIVEN THE
ASSURANCES THAT THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION IS GIVEN
REGARDING OUR COMMITMENT TO
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. WE
BELIEVE THAT NOW IS THE TIME
THAT WE HAVE THE STATE MUST
HOLD STRONG AND SHORT
COMMITMENT TO THIS PROJECT AND
ENSURE COMPLETION WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ENDED THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO APPROPRIATE
THE REMAINING PROP WHEN IT
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS IN AN EFFORT
TO NOT ONLY SUPPORT THE PROJECT
AND SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO WE'RE WILLING PARTNERS BUT
ALSO TO ASSIST IN PROVIDING THE
MUCH NEEDED ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT COINCIDE WITH THE PROJECT
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL. PLEASE
LINE. TWENTY FOUR. SH THANK
YOU- MEDICARE MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN NOT
HERE WE HAVE THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. OR THE PROJECT WE
BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA COURTS
TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
COULD YOU DEVELOPMENT AND HIGH
THROUGHOUT- PROJECT ON THE
REVITALIZED PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE BY DEMONSTRATION IN THE
STATE- MATE MAKES CALIFORNIA
EVEN CLOSER THAN EVER TOWARD
REALIZING THAT THE HIGH FIGURES
JUST UP AFTER A CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT RECENTLY REITERATED
THAT ON THE BIKE IS A BIG
BELIEVER PASSENGER RAIL IN THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE LEADING
THE WAY YOU WANT TO COME BACK.
IT WILL BE COMING THE OTHER.
CREATED BY THE MINISTRY
DEPLOYMENT COURT THE PROJECT
CAL GOAL CONNECTED TO. PRETTY
GOOD JOB WITH THAT I'M DOING
WHILE SITE. BY CANADIAN YOUR
SESSION HI YOU UP CAN YOU TO A
TRULY WANT GENERATE BACK ON
STIMULUS. THE PARTY IS GREAT IF
YOU HUNDRED HIGH JOB OF SEVEN
PER THESE WERE COMING EIGHTEEN.
AND ABOUT LIKE. OR THE BUSINESS
THE FINAL PROP ONE EIGHT ONE
FOUR THREE. NASTIEST DALY
NUMBERS FOR GOVERNOR'S TO THE
RIGHT RAIL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. I FORTY SO. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS B. A BIT CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF PALM. I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT- WE LIKE
TO- URGE YOU CAN TO- THIS WITH
THE SYSTEM TO FINISH HIM BY
WORKING TO FINISH THE HOW TO
NINE MILE OF TRACK IN THE SAN
VALLEY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
LINE'S BEEN IT PART TO THIS OF
PALM AND WHY HAPPENS. THEY'VE
BEEN LESSONS AND ADJUSTED HAVE
BEEN I THINK THEY'VE THEIR WAY
ON THE INVESTED OF IN THE END
OF THEIR OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
JUST RECENTLY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO START ACQUIRING THE
LAND AROUND THE FUTURE STATION
THAT WILL BRING TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL ON
THE BRIGHTLINE WEST SYSTEM
ALONG. WITH OTHER MODES
INCLUDING METROLINK WE WOULD-
WE'D LIKE TO- SAY WE ENCOURAGE
THE PROJECT. TO STAY COMMITTED
AND STATE OF COURSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE. LINE.
FOURTEEN GOODMORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS EUGENE
MORE FOR CARPENTERS LOCAL ONE
FIFTY TWO IN MERCED AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
HIGHEST OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROPOSED PLAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CANNOT AND I'M WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
TWELVE THE TWELVE GOING TO
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE. FIFTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LUKE BRAND WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
NUMBER TWELVE I'M HERE TODAY
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL TO VOICE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S BUSINESS PLANS TO
INCLUDE PROP ONE EIGHTY FUNDS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
FORTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING- COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS A CHRIS SNYDER AND I'M
WITH THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL THREE ON THERE- POLITICAL
DIRECTOR- WE COVER- NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- I JUST URGE YOU TO
DO- SUPPORT HIGH SPEED RAIL-
PROPOSAL AS AS IT'S PROPOSED-
IN RELEASING REST THE FUNDS.
WE'VE BEEN SO ENGAGED IN THIS
PROJECT FOR YOU HAVE BEEN-
GOING TO MEETINGS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX SIX SEVEN WHICH
SUPPORTS THE BALLOT MEASURE AS-
ANTICIPATED SO MANY ATTACKS.
FROM ACROSS THE AISLE FROM IN
THE FORMER ADMINISTRATION- AND
YOU KNOW WE HAVE WORKERS OUT
THERE NOT LIKE HUNDREDS OF
WORKERS OUT THERE RIGHT NOW MY
YOU NEED US AL AND ITS-
EXPRESSION THE PANDEMIC'S BEEN
A LIFELINE- WE'RE ON THE
PRECIPICE OF MAKING THIS
HAPPEN. THERE'S BOOTS ON THE
GROUND- I JUST URGE YOU TO KEEP
THE FUNDING COMING AND WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH YOU. AND THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION TO FIND ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THIS AND
TELL YOU KNOW FIGHT TO MAKE THE
STRING HAPPENED BECAUSE- LIKE A
UNION THIS IS GOING TO BRING
CALIFORNIA GATHER. AND IT IS IT
IS A GOOD GREEN JOBS BUILDING
TRADES JOBS AND I JUST- SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PROJECT FOR THE
ENTIRE FUTURE OF THE STATE. AND
A TEMPLATE FOR THE NATION SO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE PROJECT AS
PROPOSED CURRENTLY THANK YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WINDS HI MY NAME IS THE
XLB AND I AM A CO CHAIR OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO TRANSIT RIDERS
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
WANTED TO- REALLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND SUPPORT WHAT IS BEEN
NOW- TWICE- IT'S BEEN-
INDEPENDENTLY AUDITED THIS
PARTICULAR PLAN AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THE MARCH SAID
MARCH BAKERSFIELD COMPLETE- I
JUST WANT TO DATE A COUPLE OF
POINTS THERE'S NEVER BEEN AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IN THE
HISTORY OF INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT HAD ALL THE
MONEY. UP FRONT SO THAT'S NO
EXCUSE NOT TO ALLOCATE THE
MONEY TO FINISH THE FIRST A
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE SECOND
POINT IS EQUITY MATTERS AND
THINKING ABOUT TAKING MONEY
AWAY FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
IS WHERE THAT THERE'S THE WORST
POLLUTION AND UNEMPLOYMENT IS
NOT THE RIGHT THING TO DO AT
THIS POINT IN TIME AND THIRDLY
LISTENS- THE CEO BRIAN KELLY
AND THE PEER REVIEW EXPERTLY
THOMPSON WHO ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
OF THE SAME OPINION WE NEED TO
FINISH THE FIRST SEGMENT OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND- ALLOCATE
THE FUNDING TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY NOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY SEVENTY.
HI MY NAME IS A KERN PRESIDENT
THE U. S. SPEED RAIL SAYS HE
ASIAN WE CONSIDER THE
CALIFORNIA PROJECT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT PROJECTS IN THE
COUNTRY AND IN OUR HISTORY.
BECAUSE IT'S BASICALLY BUILDING
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF BUILDING
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM FOR
AMERICA. SO THE IMPORTANCE OF
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY HAS NATIONAL
IMPLICATIONS AND WILL TRANSFORM
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY. IN THIS
DIRECTION- AND SO WE URGE YOU
TO STAY THE COURSE THIS IS
IMPORTANT PROJECT IT'S
CREATING- TWO HUNDRED JOBS IT
WILL CREATE ALL SORTS OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AROUND THE
STATIONS IT'LL- REARRANGE THE
HOUSING AND JOBS MAKES CREATE
OPEN. MILES OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE- AND SO AND
IT'S THE BIGGEST CLIMATE
SOLUTION THAT YOU COULD
POSSIBLY COME UP WITH SO THIS
IS THIS IS REALLY A SILVER
BULLET TECHNOLOGY WE
CONGRATULATE YOU FOR BEING
PIONEERS. AND LEADING THE
COUNTRY AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
STAY THE COURSE AND BE THE
LEADERS AND GET THIS VISIONARY
PROJECT TO COMPLETION THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OPERATOR NEXT
COLOR BLIND SEVENTY FIVE LINE.
SEVENTY FIVE. IN SEVENTY FIVE
HAS DROPPED OFF TO A GOOD LINE
FIFTY TWO. JERRY YES. MONICA
NINE CONRAD DEAN ENTRY RIDERS
I'VE BEEN COMPLAINING AROUND
FIVE GREAT AND ONE HUNDRED YEAR
THOUGHT. FOR NOW THE TWENTY
THREE OLD ECONOMY I HAD HAVE A
IT REALLY GREAT POINT. I'M
SORRY BUT THEM FOR YOU FOR
PEOPLE TALKING. I AM VERY THANK
GOD AND UNLIKE IN MOST PARTS OF
THE STATE YOU CAN IT IS NOT AND
YEAH OUR DRIVER RIGHT BEFORE.
30% EVEN IF YOU WORKING CARE OF
IT OTHER FOR OF. TRANSPORTATION
ACCORDING. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOU WILL GO
ONLINE SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS TYLER FUNDING I AM THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES OF
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF OUR
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND CIVIL
ENGINEERS AND LAND SURVEYORS IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA-
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORITIES REVISED DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN AND STRONG
SUPPORT THE COMPLETION OF THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE PROJECT. AN
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT AS
BECAUSE- NOW TIME FOR US TO
STAY ON TRACK AND IN THE CORPUS
WHICH TO WASHINGTON THAT
CALIFORNIA'S READY FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND TRADITIONAL.
FEDERAL INVESTMENT. SHE
FINISHED BE A THREE. AND THE
COURT MAKING STATIONARY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CALLER. I KNOW.
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
MY NAME IS PAUL CATCH DURING
I'M A THAT SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
OF CATCHING BY MENTAL. AND
WE'RE PROVIDING DEMOLITION AND
ABATEMENT SERVICES ON ALL THREE
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY GOING- WE START OUT
WITH SIX EMPLOYEES PRIOR TO
HIGH SPEED RAIL. AND WE'VE
GROWN TO THIRTY EIGHT. EARLY
85% OF OUR WORK HAS COME PUBLIC.
SO THE TARGETING WORK HAVE BEEN
WORKING GREAT SO OF THOSE- NEW
EMPLOYEE THAT WERE ON PUBLIC
IT'S A ARE NOW HOMEOWNER AND
DOING WELL MYSELF- EARNING
LIVING WITH THE- SPORT OF. AND
THIS IT'S A WONDERFUL UP FOR
THE BUT NOT ONLY HAS THIS
PROJECT GIVEN MY COMPANY. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITHIN A
HIGH SCHOOL RAIL IT'S ALL GIVEN
US A- TO WORK OUT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL WE- HELLO TO WHERE
WE CAN ACTUALLY WORK OTHER. OF
SIGNIFICANT WORKER BUILDING
POLICE TO AND FIRE STAY. SO
HIKES TIME YOU CAN FINISH A
SORRY. I WILL. TO SOME OF THE
THIS PROJECT AS MORE THAN
FILLED A TRAIN WHICH I'M IN
IMPAIR OF IT LIVES IN THE KEY
IT'LL KEEP- OUTSIDE OFFICE
GOING ALSO THANK YOU THANK YOU
PERFECT NOW CALLER. WHAT ONLINE
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SUCH UP REAL HOUSE ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
FRESNO MADERA TULARE KINGS
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL. I'M
CALLING IN TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED BUSINESS PLAN THIS
PROJECT HAS BEEN A VEHICLE TO
MOVE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS BY WAY OF
APPRENTICESHIP IN CONSTRUCTION
JOBS. WE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
STAND READY TO CONTINUE. AND
FINISH THE WORK WE STARTED
PLEASE ALLOW US THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. OPERATOR NEXT COLOR
PLENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT TWO. HELLO MY
NAME IS INCORRECT AND I'M A
POLICY TO OF IN THE AREA. EIGHT
NONSTOP THAT FOR A WORLD YOU IN
EQUITY TRAN THAT THEM BOTH IN
THAT NIGHTCAP BAY AREA AND IN
THE BAY HOW. AND I'M CALLING
STRONG. EXPRESSED MY SUPPORT
AND ARE ORGANIZED OR FOR THE
BUSINESS PLAN AND MOVING IF YOU
THINK THAT. MONEY BY. OR THE
ADDITIONAL OPERATING SEGMENT IN
THAT IN THAT VALLEY THE BEST I
AM. I REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CRISPY WITH THAT PROJECT- THE
MOST EXPEDIENT POP- WE HAVE ANY
HOPE OF KEEPING THE PUBLIC I'M
TO PUT. FOR THE PRIDE AND FUND
FUTURE DATED WE NOT FOR WITH
WITH THE BUSINESS PLAN AT PLAN-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. SHOULD BETWEEN THE JOB
IN THE BAY AREA AND RESIDENTS
OF CENTRAL VALLEY WITH THE
SHOULD BE OPPORTUNITY TO
HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. IN ADDITION IT
ALSO HELP ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS ACROSS THE STATE ADULT
ENABLE PEOPLE TO LIVE IN AREAS
WITH LOWER LAND VALUES BUT YET
STILL BE CONNECTED TO JOB
CENTERS WITHIN A REASONABLE
COMMUTE TIME. SO PLEASE DO
EVERYTHING IN YOUR POWER TO
KEEP THIS PROJECT ON TRACK
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ADMINISTRATION BAKER NINE
FTP OF TRANSPORTATION HOUSING
POLITICAL VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP TO THE TOP PRIORITIES FOR
MEMBERS ARE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION ALLOWING HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO CONTINUE FRWARD
IN THE PROCESS IT IS CLOSER TO
USUALLY SUPPORT ON THIS
CRITICAL AND RELATED
PRIORITIES. IF MOMENT OR NEW
ENERGY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS
THE TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO STEP
UP NOT STEP ASIDE AND ALLOW THE
COUNTRY TO BE TO CONTINUE TO
PASS UP IN THE CONSTRUCTOR AND
CONCEDED THAT POTENTIAL FEDERAL
FUNDING TO OTHER STATES. WE'RE
GOING TO STEP UP THANK YOU TIME
FOR YOUR SERVICE THE TECH
THANKS SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY NINETY. NINE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR- STEVE CREWS ON
THE OF MAJOR A CARD- IN THIS OF
SAN. OKAY TO REGISTER. FOR THE
BID PLAN AND SPECIFIC A PROBE
OF REMAINING. TO THE KIND.
ELECT THE CORD IN THE CENTER
VALLEY AND IF THE STAY TO CA
AND VALLEY SO VALLEY. OPERATION
IS FUNDED YOU KNOW. SUPPORT
TEAM REGIONAL AND PRIOR
INCLUDING. CONNECTIONS MAJOR
JOE CENTERS AND SILICON VALLEY
AND AREA. IN BRINGING HIGHS
RAIL. STATION IN SAN JOSE WERE
IMPROVE CA. TO A DOZEN
DIFFERENT COLOR AND RAIL SYSTEM.
THAT CONVERGE AT THE TRANSIT
HUB A FACT RELATED REFLECTED
RATHER IN THE NTC. PLAN AREA
TWENTY FIFTY BLUEPRINT SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE- SUPPORT- THE
UPDATED PLAN AND- J. TACTIC.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU MY NINETY NINE SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LEANNE EAGER AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF FRESNO
COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND I'M CALLING TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR THE
REVISED TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN AND TO COMPLETE THE
DELIVERY. OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT I
THINK AS MOST OF YOU HVE
HEARD- THE CENTRAL VALLEY- HAS
REALLY BEEN LEFT BEHIND FOR
MANY MANY YEARS THE PROMISE OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL THAT WE HAVE
BEEN PROMISING FOLKS AND FOR
THE LAST TEN TWELVE YEARS. IS
FINALLY COMING TO FRUITION HERE
WE SEE THE JOBS. OUT ON THE
FREEWAYS WE SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITH HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
AND HIGH POVERTY AND
UNACCEPTABLE AIR QUALITY HERE
IN THE VALLEY THIS HAS BEEN
PROMISED AS A GAME CHANGER. AND
WHO WE WOULD CERTAINLY SEE IT
AS SUCH- HAVING HIGH SPEED RAIL
CONNECTED TO THE BAY AREA AND
EVENTUALLY TO LOS ANGELES WE'LL
BRING THE CENTRAL VALLEY ON
EQUAL FOOTING WITH THE REST OF
THE STATE. THIS WILL BE WHAT WE
HAVE PROMISED IS THAT PEOPLE
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK TRANSCEND
AND TRANSFER FROM FRESNO TO SAN
FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES YOU
CAN. KIND OF WORK THAT. WE HAVE
PROMISED ABOUT. YES ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THAT WOULD DEPENDING ON YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. POZZATO LINE NINE. FOUR
NINE NINE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HELLO MY NAME'S CLINT
HENDRICKS AND THE BOARD
CHAIRPERSON OF THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF THE JOINT
POWERS BOARD OF CALTRAIN AND I
AM VICE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
SUNNYVALE I'M HERE TODAY IN MY
CAPACITY AS THE PTH HERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
DIRECTION LAID OUT IN THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED. RAIL
AUTHORITY REVISED DRAFT TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN HE HE
REGULARLY HAS PARTNERS ON THE
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS
AS WE WORK TO INNOVATE MOBILITY
SOLUTIONS FOR SILICON VALLEY.
BECAUSE OF THAT EXPERIENCE WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
BUILDING OF THE NATION'S FIRST
TRULY HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
LINKING ONE OF OUR NATION'S
MOST IMPORTANT ECONOMIC ENGINES
THE SILICON VALLEY IN THE BAY
AREA WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
DJ STANDS AS TRANSPORTATION
PARTNER IN THE BAY AREA TO
ACCOMPLISH THE OBJECTIVES LAID
OUT IN THE REVISED TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN AND WE
SUPPORT ASKING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO APPROPRIATE
REMAINING FOR BILLION IN
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHT FUNDS TO
COMPLETE CONSTRUCTION AND
ELECTRIFY THE CORRIDOR AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THANK YOUVERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PROJECT FOR OUR STATE AND
BECOMING THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT ALIGN ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- THIS IS JOE
CRUZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
FLAVORS. AND YOUR EIGHTY
THOUSAND HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN WHO MAKE UP ORGANIZATION
IN CALIFORNIA. THE LABOR HAVE
WORKED HARD TO PASS HI YOUR
AVAILABLE ON IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. THE REMAINING
STEADFAST SUPPORT OF THE
PROJECT. AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
INTRAPARTUM CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT
TO ADDRESS AIR QUALITY. AND
MOBILITY ISSUES BILL CRITICAL
TO THREAT TO OUR HEALTH.
ECONOMY AND OVERALL QUALITY OF
LIFE. WE ARE PLEASED WITH THE
PROGRESS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY GET
MADE. OVER THE PAST YEAR AND
BANKING HIGH SPEED RAIL ON THE
BALLOT INVALID. AS WELL AS TO
THE REVISED BUSINESS PLAN. AS
YOU ALL KNOW. EVERY MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS STREET.
ADDRESS FAIR SHARE OF
CHALLENGES IN CRITICS. MEET AT
THE BAY AREA WAS FAR FETCHED
THE BAKER BREAK BREAK I'M SORRY
WAS FAR FETCHED THE STATE WATER
PROJECT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN. BUT
THANKFULLY OUR GRANDPARENTS HAD
THE INGENUITY AND WHAT WITH ALL
THE BILL TO PROCEED IMPOSSIBLE.
NOW MORE THAN EVER THANK THE
CALIFORNIA LEADERS TO RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WITH THE ELECTION OF PROTEST TO
DERAIL PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT. CALIFORNIA'S CLOSER
TO REALIZING A WORLD CLASS HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM. WE BELIEVE
THE HYPE THE REAL PARTICIPATING
IN A RIGHT DIRECTION. IN ANY
EVENT THE BIBLE PROJECT THE
FUNDING. WHEN IS ALREADY
CREATING JOBS IS SHORT. SIGHTED
RESTRICT YOUR TIME YOUR WORK.
AND CONSIDER TO GETTING FUNDING
THANK YOU THANK YOU KNOW.
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY EIGHT SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE KEEP ON THE OF
THIS TOWN I WORKER I- AND THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MICHAEL MISTER
CRUZ IN JUST ADD TO
CALIFORNIA'S INUNIQUE POSITION
TO LEAD THE WAY ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN BUILD BACK BETTER PROGRAM
THAT WE ALL ANTICIPATE COMES
FORTH IN THE NEXT. SIX MONTHS-
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROGRAM HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY
TRYING TO IMPROVEMENTS UPON
THEIR BUSINESS PLAN WE SUPPORT
THEIR CONTINUED EFFORTS BEAR.
WE SUPPORT THE OVERSIGHT THIS
PROJECT HAS HAD MORE OVERSIGHT.
IN ANY MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT AND IN MODERN TIMES WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT THAT
WILL OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
YOUR- GUIDANCE TO PROVIDE.
DIRECTION ON THE PROGRAM BUT I
ALSO KNOW THAT THIS PROJECT IS
CRITICAL TO THE RECOVERY OF NOT
ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT OUR ENTIRE
NATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
IN COLLECTING SHARING AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALL. LINE ONE
HUNDRED ONE ZERO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S GEORGIA TAYLOR I AM A
RESIDENT OF RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA- I FULLY SUPPORT-
COMMITTEE ACTS PAYER AND I
FULLY SUPPORT- OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT AND THE CURRENT
BUSINESS PLAN AND URGE YOU. TO
MOVE FORWARD AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE AND TO UP LINK.
CALIFORNIA TOGETHER WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO DO IT ON
ENVIRONMENTALLY OR ECONOMICALLY
FINALLY CLEAR AND WE CAN BE A
MODEL FOR THE REST OF THE
NATION- I'VE ATTENDED- MEETINGS
INITIAL HIGH SPEED RAIL MEETING
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
LOCAL CALIFORNIA. AND
UNFORTUNATE GRAY DAVIS THE THEN
GOVERNOR I DID NOT HAVE THE
VISION OR ABILITY TO MOVE THE
PROJECT FORWARD. AND THAT
LANGUISH FOR MANY. PARTY WHILE.
AND ARTICULATE PAY PLAYING
CATCH UP AND I WOULD THAT
SYSTEM. ALL THE TIME BOTH GO
DOWN TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS POINTS IN BETWEEN SO
PLEASE- GIVE THE GREAT CONTINUE
TO DO THE GREAT WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING. I'LL HAVE TO
TAXPAYERS I FULLY SUPPORT MY
TAX DOLLARS GOING TO THIS WITH
THE PROJECT THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE OH ONE ONE HUNDRED ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET ME. HELLO
YES YOUR HONOR GO AHEAD YES WE
CAN GET. OKAY YEP. BOB I'M
DEBORAH GOOD MORNING- MAYBE
NUMBER TEN- I NEED MARKET ORDER
NUMBER RESIDENT OF SAMBAR DINO-
CALLING INTO FOR THE BUSINESS
PLAN I'D EVEN THOSE FEMENINO
WAS BASED TO AND KNOW WHAT
PROBABLY WILL NEVER SHOW UP IN
MY LIFETIME AT THE CURRENT RATE
STILL SUPPORT THE PLAN I HAVE
FAMILY LIVES IN FEDERAL VALLEY
AND I'M LOOKING VERY FORWARD
TO. BOB DRIVING SIX HOURS TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THEM BUT- THESE
DRIVING OVER THE BAKERSFIELD
HOPPING ON A TRAIN I WOULDN'T
GET ME THERE CUT THAT TIME IN
HALF- I DON'T WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE THINGS BASED ON PUBLIC
COMMENTS WERE MADE EARLIER. I
KNOW SOME PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT- MAYBE- BELIEVE THE
CHAIRWOMAN OF ASKING- MISTER
KELLY IF MAYBE WE WERE HAD LOOK
AT HYDROGEN STUFF BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT YOU KNOW IF WE'RE
LOOKING TO. MAY BE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE AND BUILD A TRAINED
AT THAT NOT FROM POINT MORE
WORK BUT IT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR EXPERIMENTAL
TECHNOLOGY AT THIS POINT WHEN
IT'S NOT BEING. USED AT. AND I
WOULD THINK TO THAT THAT- IF
THE- BOARD THE- COMMITTEE
REALLY WHAT THE- YOU KNOW TRUCK
DOLLARS. MAYBE THE BAKER. AND
IT'S PROBABLY THE BETTER AND TO
CONNECT TO MERCED NINETY NINE
THOUSAND ON THE- BUT I KNOW.
BAKER HUGHES A BIGGER CITY.
THEIR AT THE- THEY- WITH- WITH
THE AFTER. THAT COMES UP AND
FROM LA TO THAT WOULD BE A-
GREAT CONNECTION WITH THE
INTRACTABLE OTHER AND AS IN
MADERA OKAY AND- IN. LIKE TO
THINK. OBJECT THAT YOU FOR THE
POT. THANK ON SOME. THANK YOU.
THANKS- NEXT CALLER PLEASE WILL
GO NEXT. THANK YOU WITH A LINE
SIXTEEN SIX NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MISTER CHAIR- MY NAME IS
THE ENGINE MINETTI AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF FRESNO MAYOR JERRY
DIED YOU'RE REPRESENTING THE
FIFTH LARGEST CITY IN THE STATE
AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
AUTHORITIES TRACKED TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN. MANY
INVESTMENTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE IN OUR CITY AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE HAVE A
STRONG INTEREST IN SEEING THAT
COME TO COMPLETION. YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MANY STEPS TO GET TO
THE FINISH PROJECT AND WE DON'T
NEED THE BUSINESS PLAN IS THE
PART THAT IT WILL HELP ATTRACT
MORE INVESTMENTS FOR STATEWIDE
CAN ACTIVITY. AND WILL YIELD
NUMEROUS ECONOMIC BENEFITS FOR
YEARS TO COME WE URGE THE STATE
TO CONTINUE FUNDING THE PROJECT
THROUGH THE REMAINING PROP
TWENTY BOND FUNDS FOR CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT AND EARLY DESIGN
AN ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS FOR
THE STAMP AND JUST GO TO L. A.
FEES ONE LIKE ME. WE BELIEVE
THIS WILL HELP REACH OUR GOAL
GIVE IT A BEST CHANCE FOR
SUCCESS AND FINISH WHAT WE
STARTED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ALIGNED OH
FIVE ONE FIVE PLEASE GO A-
THANK YOU MANAGE CAN THE CHAIR
MEMBERS- THIS TO REACH THAT
THERE OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND I
AM PLEASED TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF OUR SISTER AGENCIES AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. AND IN
CALIFORNIA'S DISCO I ALSO
SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE TRAFFIC
GOING HOW THE BUILDING CAMPUS.
WITHOUT PROGRAMS DURING TEENAGE
WHICH IS CHARGED WITH HELPING
TO DEVELOP THE DOWNTOWN
RESIDENTIAL PROJECT WHICH IS
THAT THE FUTURE AUTONOMOUS
NORTHERN TERMINUS OF CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL WE WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE- IDEAS ABOUT THIRTY
BUSINESS PLAN. AND REQUEST THAT
PROP ONE EIGHTY NINE CENTS TO
HELP COMPLETE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT AND ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THE REST OF THE STATE.
FOR THE BAY AREA COMMITMENT
CENTRAL VALLEY TO SILICON
VALLEY THAT WILL PROVIDE A
CRITICAL LOW CARB INTRODUCTION
FOR INTERVENTIONAL CONNECTIVITY
EMPLOYMENT ACCESS WHILE
NINETEEN CREATING THOUSANDS OF
JOBS FOR OUR STATE I CONGRESS
TAKES UP FEDERAL IN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT WE
ALSO HAVE A ONCE IN A DECADE
OPPORTUNITY OF FIRST DEGREE. WE
DO HAVE STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDED TOGETHER AFTER THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR STATE THANK
YOU AGAIN AND THEN THE COLLEGES
AND- A LOCAL PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STATE TO ADVANCE IF ARE
PROGRAM IN THE COMING YEAR
YEARS NEXT CALLER. PLEASE HELLO
LINE ONE OR TWO ONE TO PLEASE
AHEAD. IT HAPPENED MY NAME IS
DAN AND I'M SENIOR UP IN
CALIFORNIA CAR RIDGE COUNCIL
FOR MADERA TO AND COUNTY- IN
THE CENTRAL WE HAVE A IN THE-
OF. MOVING FROM THE AREA LOS
AND AREAS IN FRESH MADERA
TULARE HE'S- I THIS IS DUE TO
COST OF AND ABILITY WORK FROM
DO NINE. VIDEO ME AND WORKING
TIME FROM HOME IT DEFINITELY
CHANGES NORM BUT THE CHANGES
CALIFORNIA'S A MADE IN THE NEED
FOR TRANSPORTATION WE MUST STAY
ON TRACK AND FUND THE RAIL. THE
CARD THE NEW STANDS WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TWENTY NINE TWO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS MY CLEAN ART ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
FRESNO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND WE ARE PART OF
THE FRESNO WORKS COALITION- I
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR THAT BUSINESS PLAN PROPOSAL
TO COMPLETE THE MERCED
BAKERSFIELD HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATING SEGMENT- I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SINGLE TAX
TRACK PROPOSAL AND I HOPE THAT-
AND ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE IDENTIFIED THAT THERE'LL BE
CONSIDERATION OF GOING BACK TO
DOUBLE TRACK SYSTEM- HOWARD IS
CONCERNED IS NOT DIMINISH OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE- TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN AS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
SEVENTY THREE SEVEN THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AT THE BELOW DEPUTY POLITICAL
DIRECTOR OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL THREE ON BEHALF OF OUR
NEARLY FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
INCLUDING HUNDREDS WHO HAVE AND
ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT WE
STAND WITH STATE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
AND CONTINUE FUNDING. OUR
MEMBERS LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE THROUGH
THIS WORK TO BUILD THE PROJECT
I LOOK FORWARD TO MAKING USERS
YOU NEED RESOURCES. WHAT THANK
YOU TAX. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY. ONE ELEVEN ONE ONE
TWO ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS P. SCOTT I'M ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR SAID ARE A- FOUNDER OF
PROGRAM OF BOYS BUT TRANSIT
AND- THE SAN FRANCISCO TRANSIT
RIDERS FOR BUT SPEAKING TO YOU
AS A- I HAVE- PUT IN ENOUGH
HOURS LAST TIME- WHILE MY
DAUGHTERS ONE STILL IN LOS
ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO CA AND
THEN UP HI. MY MORE NO ONE. HI
I I'M SO. IN THE CASE ON THE-
AS I'M SURE THOSE OF WHO ARE
FROM SOUTHERN CAL. AND THE
LEGISLATURE SACRAMENTO HAE TO
I URGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
CONTINUATION ARE WE WORK ON
THIS PROJECT AND IN PARTICULAR
OUR COMPLETION OF THE VALUE
SEGMENT. ON WHICH WORK IS NOW
UNDERWAY IS A GENERATIONAL
PROJECT COMPLETION IS ESSENTIAL
YOUR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
BUSINESS PLAN. AND BOB RELEASED.
SO TOP OF- H. R. OF ONE.
FUNDING TO COMPLETE THE INITIAL
SEGMENT ON THE BENCH THIS THE I
AS THANKS THANK YOU AND NOW
CALLER. LINE ONE TO ONE ONE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING I'M RON MILLER
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE
AILING WHICH COUNTY BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. WERE IN FULL SUPPORT
ALONG WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES WITH THIS PROJECT WE
NEED TO GET THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
BUILT IN LIKE THE CALLER BEFORE
WE SAID THIS IS A GENERATIONAL
PROJECT THAT'S GOING TO
BENEFIT. ALL OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
IT'S DONE THANK YOU THANKS FOR
ON NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
OH SIX ONE HUNDRED SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS GERRY KOTOWSKI- RETIRED
MILITARY LIVING IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA AND I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY AND
ADOPT- THE BUSINESS PLAN
INCLUDING- APPROPRIATING THE
FUNDS FOR PROPOSITION- ONE
EIGHT- AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO GROW ESPECIALLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OUR CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURES UNSUSTAINABLE.
FREEWAYS WE ARE ARE BEYOND
CAPACITY AND WHITING THEM IS
ONLY A SHORT SHORT TERM FIX
LINKING LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FRANCISCO AND EVENTUALLY
SACRAMENTO BEE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
KEEPING THE STATE A TRACK PLACE
TO WORK AND LIVE IT'S A VITAL
TOOL TO MEETING THE STATE'S
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS. AND
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
INTEGRATED NETWORK OF TRAINS
AND BUSES THAT WILL IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE CALIFORNIANS REALLY NEEDS
AND DESERVES HIGH SPEED RAIL
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU IN OUR- COMMENT IN QUEUES
FOR LINE ONE TWELVE ONE ONE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DAVE SANDRA FROM A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
NUMBER TWELVE. STRONG SUPPORT
THIS PROJECT WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED WORK FOR
MEMBERS OF MY TRADE BUT FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN OF ALL TRADES
PRETTY GOOD PAYING JOBS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGH OUR STATE. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
OPERATOR IF ANYONE ELSE IN Q.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC FOR CALLING IN WE
WILL CERTAINLY NEED THAT
ENTHUSIASM AND MORE AS WE MOVE
THIS PROJECT FORWARD SO THANKS
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT I WANT TO
THANK THE PANELISTS AS WELL IN
MY CO CHAIR- MISTER BLOOM- I
BELIEVE THAT THESE HEARINGS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THAT
SUPPORTERS OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECT SHOULD ENCOURAGE
QUESTIONS- WE SHOULD BE. AS
TRANSPARENT TO OURSELVES IN THE
PUBLIC AS POSSIBLE WE SHOULD
NOT SEE A QUESTIONS AS AN
INCONVENIENCE- OR NECESSARILY
AN ATTACK BUT AS AN EXPLORATION
AS THE OF THE BEST WAY TO MOVE
THIS PROJECT FORWARD- WE ALSO
SHOULD BE EXPLORING ALL OF OUR
OPTIONS BECAUSE THIS IS A
PROJECT THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE AS MANY
OF YOU HAVE SAID IN FACT THE
WHOLE NATION. AND YET LACKS THE
FUNDING THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
COMPLETED AND SO AS WE
ANTICIPATE FINDING THE BEST WAY
TO COMPLETE THE PROJECT WE
SHOULD BE OPEN TO ALL OPTIONS
TO DO JUST THAT TO EVENTUALLY
HAVE HIGH SPEED RAIL IS A
REALITY. NOT JUST FOR A HUNDRED
TWENTY MILES NOT JUST FOR A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALL THE WAY UP
AND DOWN THE STATE AND
HOPEFULLY REACHING OUT TO OTHER
STATES AS WELL THAT'S THE
VISION THAT I WILL WORK FOR AND
I KNOW MANY OTHERS WILL AS WELL
WE WILL ONLY DO THEM DO THAT.
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT BY BEING
AS TRANSPARENT AND OPEN AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN- WITHOUT ALL SEE
IF MR BLOOM IS ANY CLOSING
REMARKS ARE AT THANK YOU MS
FRIEDMAN I'LL BE VERY BRIEF
THIS WAS A VERY INTERESTING
HEARING AND THAT IT COVERED A
LOT OF GROUND IN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME SO WE'VE HEARD-
OVERALL. ON WHAT COULD BE TRULY
AN AMAZING VISION FOR
TRANSPORTATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK- OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT BUT
IT'S ONLY ONE PART OF- OF THE
TRANSFER YOU NEED FOR THE STATE.
HAS AND THE- SO LIGHT I HOPE
THAT THIS. GOT A- NOT ONLY. A
FOCUS EVERYONE ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT BUT ALSO
OPENS OUR EYES TO GREATER
HORIZONS. THAT WILL BENEFIT THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MANY MANY WAYS. AND
WITH THAT WILL STAND ADJOURNED.